Wir blicken noch ein letztes Mal in dieser Saison auf den europäischen Top-Fußball bei den Männern. Der große Ligatour-Saison-Rückblick. Ich freue mich sehr auf Jakob Haffke für die Liga 1, auf Fabian Pakulat für La Liga, auf Christian Bernhardt für die Serie A und Uli Hebel ist auch hier für die Premier League. Wir legen los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Wann baue ich eine Zehn-Sekunden-Version dieses Intros und werde alle meine Gäste völlig unvorbereitet treffen. Denn die haben sich schon dran gewöhnt, dass sie dann nochmal mit dem Hund rausgehen können, einen neuen Kaffee aufsetzen und so weiter und so fort. Ich sehe es euch doch genau an. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid, ihr vier.
Ich glaube, wir müssen nicht allzu viel über den Meister sprechen. Der hat ja am Ende doch jetzt nicht so viele überrascht. Wir haben es ja auch kurz schon so ein bisschen angesprochen. Das ist dann ja auch im Grunde das geworden, was man erwartet hat auch vor der Saison. Aber wir hatten ja immerhin zumindest so bis ins Frühjahr hinein zumindest die Möglichkeit auf einen Titelkampf. Und wir hatten ja immer mal wieder so die Frage, ob Lens es schafft, Paris tatsächlich bis zum Ende wirklich dann zu treiben. Und es war ja auch so, dass dann erst im vorletzten Spiel die tatsächliche Entscheidung gefallen war. Also da war es dann auch rechnerisch nicht mehr möglich. Es war dann natürlich in dem verhängnisvollen, direkten Duell zwischen den beiden Teams, was ja auch weit nach hinten verschoben wurde. Das ist sicherlich so ein Aspekt, das hatte ich mir eigentlich für später aufgehoben. Aber jetzt, wo ich es schon anspreche, ist es natürlich so ein bisschen bitter, dass die Liga da so ihr eigenes Produkt mit abgewertet hat. Denn es geht ja darum, dass eigentlich viel früher das direkte Duell zwischen Paris und Lens anstand und es dann aber verschoben wurde, da Paris in der Champions League zwischen den Liverpool-Spielen gewesen sein müsste, dass sie da halt das Wochenende frei bekommen. Das ist jetzt an sich nicht unüblich. Das hat man auch in den letzten Jahren in der Liga schon gemacht. Und das gab es ja auch schon in dieser Saison auch bei anderen Spielen. Und es war auch nicht nur Paris, also auch ein Straßburger Spiel wurde verschoben. Allerdings war es halt in dem Zusammenhang, dass es eigentlich ja das Saisonhighlight ist, wenn die beiden besten Teams, die damals auch noch in einem sehr nahen Abstand zueinander standen, gegeneinander spielen, dass man dann als Liga-Verband sagt, vor allem auch wenn Lens sich ja dagegen ausgesprochen hat, okay, wir verschieben das Spiel, ist jetzt in Zeiten, wo ja auch die Ligue 1 wirklich einen keine guten Fernsehgelder hat und so, dass man dann sagt, okay, wir werten das eigene Produkt so krass ab und verschieben das Spiel dann auf unter der Woche Mittwochs und jetzt natürlich dann auch in dem Zusammenhang, dass es davor eigentlich auch schon entschieden war. Es ist schon extrem schade, dass das so gelaufen ist, denn wer weiß, was gewesen wäre, wenn Lons das Spiel gewonnen hätte. Man hat gesehen, dadurch, sie haben so ein bisschen den Rhythmus verloren, weil das auch im Anschluss an eine Länderspielpause war. Das heißt, sie hatten eigentlich so drei Wochen gar kein richtiges Pflichtspiel, hatten dann zum Saisonende hin mehrere englische Wochen, obwohl sie ja vor der Saison gar nicht damit rechnen konnten, weil sie halt nicht in Europa waren. Das heißt, der Kader war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt dafür ausgelegt und so kam dann eins zum anderen und das ist dann schon schade gewesen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist Launce die positive Geschichte dieser Saison, auch wenn sie jetzt am Ende nur in Anführungsstrichen Zweiter geworden sind. Selbst das ist schon ein Riesenerfolg, denn sie haben halt auch nur ein Etat eines Mittelfeldteams. Also eigentlich alle anderen Top-Teams, will ich es mal sagen oder Teams, die man oben erwartet, haben schon auch mehr Geld zur Verfügung. Und sie haben ja auch dann vor zwei Wochen oder anderthalb Wochen noch den Pokal gewonnen, das erste Mal in ihrer Vereinsgeschichte. Also da auch dann dieser herausragenden Saison die Krone aufgesetzt, das 120-jährige Vereinsjubiläum wirklich fantastisch gefeiert. Sie sind jetzt auch das letzte Team, was schon mal Meister geworden ist, das jetzt auch den Pokal gewonnen hat. Also alle anderen Meister haben auch schon den Pokal gewonnen und haben ja also wirklich eine fantastische Saison. Spielen jetzt nächstes Jahr wieder Champions League. Und ich hatte es gerade schon angesprochen, das mit ja verhältnismäßig kleinen Mitteln. Wir hatten ja auch in dieser Saison schon über die Super-Transfers gesprochen, die sie getätigt haben. So der Spieler der Saison für mich ist auch Florian Thauvin, der jetzt im eher fortgeschrittenen Alter wieder zurückgekommen ist nach Frankreich, nach den Ausflügen nach Mexiko und ja auch in Italien, wo er kurz bei zwei oder drei Saisons war. Also der war auch dann der Schlüsselspieler bei Lens, obwohl der eigentliche Star natürlich so ein bisschen der Trainer ist mit Pierre Sage, der ja bei Lyon entlassen wurde, auch unter durchaus kritisierten Umständen. Also das hat man in Lyon auch nicht so ganz verstanden, weil er da eigentlich auch super gute Arbeit geleistet hat und das hat er jetzt bei Lens halt gnadenlos fortgeführt. Also er hatten auch im Sommer einen riesigen Umbruch. Pierre Sage hat ja auch erst im Sommer übernommen, zahlreiche neue Spieler integriert und das hat wirklich praktisch alles direkt geklappt. Sie hatten dann ja auch ein paar Verletzungsprobleme in der Saison und auch wenn man jetzt das Gefühl hatte, es wäre okay, ihnen ist vielleicht zum Ende ein bisschen die Luft ausgegangen. Es ist trotzdem eine ganz fantastische Saison, die sie gespielt haben und es sind halt auch nicht so viele Faktoren, die man jetzt kritisch sehen kann, wenn man sich zu den gesamten Vereinen anschaut. Denn es ist ein traditionsreicher Verein, kommt so ein bisschen aus der Bergbau-Region, ist sehr in der Region verankert. Sie haben richtig, richtig guten Support, vor allem aber auch einen Support, der nicht dafür bekannt ist, über die Strenge zu schlagen. Also es gibt ja in Frankreich viele Teams, wo der Support auch, ich nenne es mal, feurig ist, aber es dann halt auch, wenn es negativ ist, es durchaus mal über die Strenge schlägt. Oder wir hatten ja auch schon zu Beginn der Folge darüber gesprochen, selbst im Erfolgsfall gibt es dann auch manchmal Ärger. Und das ist bei Lens nicht so, sondern es gibt eine fantastische Unterstützung. Es war jetzt auch nach dem Pokalfinale so, dass es im Stadion in Lens ein Public Viewing gab und die Mannschaft ist direkt im Anschluss an das Pokalfinale auch nach Lens gefahren und dann um 4 Uhr morgens im Stadion noch mal vor die verbliebenen Fans. Also da waren auch tausende Fans noch im Stadion, sind da verblieben und haben dann die Mannschaft noch gefeiert direkt im Anschluss. Und das waren auch wirklich schöne Szenen. Und so ist das definitiv die Feel-Good-Story der Saison in Frankreich.
Sarge übrigens Kandidat bei Crystal Palace, habe ich vor ein, zwei Tagen vernommen.
Er hat vor ein paar Tagen im Interview gesagt, dass er bleiben wird auf die Frage, ob er auch in der nächsten Saison noch Trainer ist. Ob man das jetzt hundertprozentig dann schon sicher sein sehen will. Keine Ahnung. Er hat irgendwann noch mal in einem Interview gesagt, dass es sein Traum wäre, Liverpool zu trainieren. Also mal schauen.
Gut getimt, das Interview, wenn er das vor ein paar Wochen gesagt hat. Ist kein Königsmörder, aber hat schon mal den Hut in den Ring geworfen. Ne, den Ring in den Hut geworfen. So ist es richtig. Aber das macht es ja noch bitterer, nachdem was du jetzt zu Lance uns nochmal zusammengefasst hast, dass es eben einfach diese systematische Benachteiligung bzw. Bevorteilung von PSG gab. Ich meine, wir alle wissen um die Situation von Nasser Al-Kelaifi, der halt sowohl in der UEFA im Exekutivkomitee sitzt, als auch der Chef von Baying Sports ist, zumindest über eine weitere Bande, als auch eben in der Liga verankert ist und eben bei PSG derjenige ist, der das Sagen hat. Also er verhandelt durchaus hin und wieder mal mit sich selbst. Und ich weiß auch, dass Al-Kelaifi nicht unkritisch gesehen wird. Also es gab ja viele transparente Fans anderer Teams, die sich direkt auf ihn konzentriert haben. Ihm scheint das ehrlich gesagt komplett egal zu sein, aber da wäre er ja nicht der Erste, der eben in einer anderen Welt lebt. Aber wie kritisch ist denn diese Situation? Denn die komplette Liga ist ja durch alles, was in den letzten 3, 4 Jahren passiert ist, mit TV-Vertrag, der auseinanderfällt, mehrere Clubs stehen kurz vor der Insolvenz. Man schließt den schlechtesten Investoren-Deal ab, den es jemals gab, weil man seinen Anteil an der Liga auf unbestimmte Zeit verkauft. Und nicht so, wie es alle anderen dann danach machen, auf 10 Jahre hin. Also was ich damit sagen will, ist, Ligen sind immer schon eine Solidargemeinschaft gewesen, von Unternehmen, die Geld verdienen wollen. Und die Ellbogen mussten schon ausgefahren werden in der Liga, weil schon sehr viele Teams überleben gekämpft haben in den letzten Jahren. Ist denn das überhaupt noch so eine Liga-Gemeinschaft? Kann man davon noch sprechen? Oder ist es, weil von außen sieht es ehrlicherweise so aus, als ob PSG die Liga eben noch duldet und dementsprechend aber sich auch so ein bisschen seine eigenen Räge macht, eben bis zu verschobenen Spielen? Also das ist wirklich irre, wenn man sich anguckt, wie PSG gespielt hat. Bei den Chelsea-Spielen in der Champions League und bei den Liverpool-Spielen hatten die einfach kein Spiel dazwischen. Die haben das einfach bei Back-to-Back gespielt. Und bei Bayern ja nur deshalb zwischendurch noch 2-2 gegen Lorient, weil sie dann mussten, weil ihnen dann die Termine ausgegangen sind. Ansonsten hätten sie da auch einfach eine komplette Woche frei gehabt. Das ist ja eigentlich total irre.
Ja, es wird schon auch sehr kritisch gesehen, aber es ist halt immer so ein Spagat dazwischen, dass die Vereine natürlich irgendwie auch darauf angewiesen sind. Du hast angesprochen, wo El Califi überall auch sitzt und mit Be In Sports zum Beispiel. Das war jetzt auch in dieser Saison noch einer der Geldgeber, da sie ja auch das eine Spiel noch hatten, was sie übertragen haben. Die anderen 8 sind ja inzwischen beim eigenen Ligue 1 Plus. Das wird sich jetzt ab der nächsten neuen Saison auch ändern. Da sind dann 9 Spiele bei Ligue 1 Plus und Be In Sports hat keine Spiele mehr. Allerdings fällt damit halt auch wieder Geld weg. Und dann ist halt auch so ein bisschen die Frage, also aus den TV-Geldern bleibt halt für alle Teams wirklich verdammt wenig. Und es gibt schon auch Proteste, du hast es ja angesprochen. Also Lens protestiert dann oder auch die anderen Fanlager solidarisieren sich dann auch gegen diese Spielverschiebung. Allerdings profitieren dann ja auch andere Vereine wieder davon. Also Straßburg beispielsweise hat auch ein Spiel verschoben bekommen. Und es wäre ja auch für die anderen Vereine wahrscheinlich so, dass der Liga-Verband es machen würde, allein schon um jetzt nicht diese Bevorteiligung PSG's noch mehr in den Vordergrund zu stellen. Ja, aber es sind halt super viele Showplätze. Also es ist der Liga-Verband, wo ja auch alle unglücklich sind. Also es ist ja auch so ein bisschen die Frage, Ligue 1 Plus hat ja erst ganz gut funktioniert. Jetzt gab es in den letzten Monaten aber auch eine ziemliche Stagnation in den Abo-Zahlen. Es gab auch Ärger, zum Beispiel um die WM-Rechte. Das wollte Ligue 1 Plus eigentlich auch übertragen, um vielleicht so neue Kundenstämme zu bekommen. Dann wurden sie da aber auch überboten von BN Sports. Auch da hat sich dann El Califi im Rahmen seiner Funktion bei BN Sports eigentlich gegen die Interessen der Liga gestellt, die er ja aber auch vertritt. Es gibt auch in den Ligameetings– es ist jetzt schon ein bisschen her– da gab es so ein Ligameeting. Danach kam an die Öffentlichkeit, dass er die anderen Vertreter der anderen Vereine teilweise auch gar nicht ausreden lässt. Ihm das völlig egal ist, was die sagen. Er hört immer nicht zu, wenn die anderen was sagen und dann halt vorprescht mit seiner eigenen Meinung. Also da ist auf jeden Fall die Gemeinschaft nicht so richtig vorhanden. Aber es gibt halt auch nicht so richtig eine Vereinigung der anderen Vereine gegen PSG. Und zum Beispiel im Zusammenhang mit der Super League hat PSG auch relativ schnell gesagt, okay, wir machen da nicht mit, sondern wollen halt in Frankreich bleiben. Also da haben sie dann ja auch zumindest mal ein bisschen Signale in die andere Richtung gesendet. Aber ja, vielleicht ein Problem auch, dass halt viele Vereine auch einfach mit sich selbst zu kämpfen haben. Also es gibt ja auch in ganz vielen Vereinen Unruhe um ihre Eigentümer, um die Präsidenten, um die Eigentümerstrukturen. Und ja, da haben dann auch die Fans, da hat man teilweise bei einigen Vereinen das Gefühl, die haben gar nicht den Raum, um gegen alles zu protestieren, gegen das man protestieren müsste. Und ja, es ist schon eine schwierige Situation auf jeden Fall, in der die Liga sich befindet. Und man sieht es dann ja auch darin, dass halt die Unterschiede zwischen den Vereinen so riesig sind. Wir hatten es ja auch jetzt häufiger mal angesprochen, wenn wir über einzelne Vereine gesprochen haben, dass halt manche Teams wirklich keinen Raum haben, Ablösesummen auszugeben. Also einige Teams, da war so der Top-Transfer in diesem Sommer, waren ein paar Hunderttausend oder eine Million für einen einzigen Spieler. Und das sind dann schon Verhältnisse, die für eine europäische Top-5-Liga jetzt zumindest eher ungewöhnlich sind.
Also irgendwann in den nächsten fünf bis zehn Jahren wird es im Fußball richtig knallen. Also irgendwann gehen da die Fans auf die Barrikaden. Und ich habe keinerlei Hoffnung mehr für die Deutschen. Aber Frankreich hat doch so eine Streitkultur. Vielleicht geht von Frankreich der große Widerstand aus. Ja, überall sind die Probleme ähnlich. Und Nasser Al-Kelaifi– also gut, dass du es mit dem WM-Richt nochmal angesprochen hast. Das hatte ich nämlich schon wieder vergessen. Ich habe so einen internen Notizzettel, wo ich so Themen immer wieder draufschmeiße. Da habe ich das sogar vergessen noch draufzuschreiben. Aber es geht so nicht weiter. Aber wisst ihr noch, wisst ihr, was Uli Hoeneß mir gesagt hat? Als ich ihn damals interviewt habe, habe ich ihn gefragt, ob Nasser Al-Kelaifi der neue Uli Hoeneß ist. Ehrlicherweise auch ruhig, um ihn ein bisschen aus der Reserve zu locken. Aber wir haben eigentlich ganz gut gelernt, warum. Weil Al-Kelaifi treibt die Liga vor sich her. Der hat die komplett im Griff. Und was er macht, wird gesagt. Und es gab eine Phase im deutschen Fußball, da war das in der Bundesliga auch so, nämlich so Mitte der 80er. Und dann alles mit der Kirchkrise, ihr könnt euch ja noch mal einlesen, auch hier das Geld, was da an den FC Bayern gezahlt wurde und so weiter und so fort. Da hatte Uli Hoeneß eine ganz ähnliche Rolle im deutschen Fußball. Daher kam ich. Und wisst ihr, was er gesagt hat? Weil auf diese Frage ist Nasser Al-Kelaifi der neue Uli Hoeneß. Er war innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden sehr, sehr sauer, hat es aber super ver... Also man hat es nur gesehen in der Rötung des Gesichts, aber man hat es nicht gehört in der Stimme. Und er hat gesagt, nein, denn er liebt den Fußball nicht so wie ich. Und das war sein einziges Argument. Was übrigens auch stimmt, Al-Kelaifi war ja mal Tennis-Spieler und hat so den Schalch kennengelernt und so ist er in die Rolle gekommen bei Qatar, die er jetzt hat. So kam er zu PSG und so weiter und so fort. Und jetzt muss er Leute nicht mehr ausreden lassen. Naja, schön. So, wir werden aber auch noch hoffentlich ein paar schöne Themen haben. Es tut mir auch leid, dass ich hier mit die dystopischen Bilder zeichne, aber ich komme ja nicht raus aus meiner Haut. Ich bin halt der Nörgeldeutsche. Uli, wir wollen noch mal in die Premier League gucken. Hast du eine vielgut Story für uns, oder?
Habe ich, muss ich mal überlegen. Es gibt bestimmt viele. Ja, ja, ja, es gibt ganz viele. Es gäbe, also Sunderland ist wahrscheinlich so, steht über den Dingen.
Ja, die haben ja auch mit harter Arbeit und ohne Investoren.
Ach nee, Moment. Ja, das ist halt, da gibt es auch wieder die Hoeneß-Kombo mit drei Fuß. Genau, also, in dem Fall hat der Sohn, aber.
Genau, muss man kurz erkennen, drei Fuß, dem ja Olympique Marseille gehört hat und so, auch der wegen Schwarzgirt und so weiter verurteilt wurde und so weiter und so fort. Der Uli Hoeneß damals das Geld gegeben hat, mit dem der seine Devisen Spekulation gemacht hat, Devisen Termin Spekulation warnt, wo er dann vergessen hat, leider die Steuern zu melden und so weiter.
Aber er ist ja jetzt bereit, mehr Steuern zu zahlen, habe ich in einem Interview gehört. Das war ja auch ganz witzig. Also er wäre, aber ja gut.
Uli Hoeneß wird, also, nee, wir zitieren Uli Hoeneß nicht mehr. Ich habe es zwar selber gemacht, ich mache das nur noch, wenn ich es selber frameen kann. Wirklich diese Aufmerksamkeit für Uli Hoeneß. Bitte, es muss jetzt aufhören. Bitte, mit den letzten AfD-Aussagen. Das war es jetzt.
Die Geschichte ist zu Ende.
Bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte. Genau, aber der Sohn und damit, und Dreifuß und die Familie, die ja irgendwie mehrere Milliarden Wert haben, also die eben einfach zu Milliardären auf dieser Welt gehören, die sind bei Marseille damals raus und haben gesagt, sie wollen nie wieder in den Fußball investieren, weil der Fußball eine verrottete Unternehmung wäre. Und ein halbes Jahr später ist Kilian Louis Dreifuß dann eingestiegen bei Sunderland. Also ganz so hat es nicht geklappt. Aber jetzt hat er das Märchen vollbracht. Sie sind auf Rang 7 gelandet, das ist doch schön.
Ja, das ist schon wirklich, im Grunde könnte man den Disclaimer ja überall setzen in der gesamten Liga, weil die ist ja inzwischen einfach von Investoren besetzt. Und da gibt es halt verschiedene Lager. Der Großteil kommt inzwischen aus den USA. Dann haben wir logischerweise unseren Anteil bei Manchester City und so weiter. Aus dem arabischen Raum und und und. Und in dem Fall ist es jetzt französisch sozusagen besetzt oder französisch, schweizerisch, wie auch immer. So oder so rein sportlich betrachtet bei Sunderland. Wir haben ja, wir haben die Situation gehabt, dass in den letzten beiden Jahren jeweils die Aufsteiger komplett chancenlos wieder zurückgeschossen worden sind in die zweite Liga. Richtig ernsthaft hat keiner dieser Aufsteiger irgendwas tun können. Vielleicht hätte ich auch Leads nehmen können, können wir in dem Abwasch vielleicht auch mit besprechen. Aber dadurch, dass Sunderland dann am Ende nach über 50 Jahren wieder zurück nach Europa kehrt, als chancenloser Aufsteiger über die Playoffs noch dazu zurückgekommen ist, erst dann, wie das viele erfolglos getan haben im Sommer, die ganze Truppe komplett neu zusammen gekauft haben in dem Fall. Also ganz viele Transfers, auch aus Frankreich, Sadiki, Diarra, die beide unfassbar gut funktioniert haben. Granit Xhaka, Most Random einfach so reingeworfen. Es gab halt zwei Optionen. Entweder es würde ihnen so gehen wie damals Fulham, das ist immer noch so das Team, das man als Vergleich hernimmt, damals nach dem ersten Aufstieg neu zusammengewürfelt, komplett abgeschossen in die zweite Liga. Da gab es nie irgendetwas. In dem Fall haben wir aber schon relativ schnell gemerkt mit Regis Le Bris, einen unfassbar guten Trainer, also der gefällt mir auch so ordentlich gut, der den Aufstieg schon gemanagt hat in einem Club, mit dem, wie wir alle vor der ganzen Weltjahr ausgebreitet gesehen haben, es nicht so leicht ist, gut zu arbeiten. Diese Doku bei Netflix, Thunderland, The Light Eye, die ist bis heute Gold. Es können gar nicht so viele Dinge schiefgehen und dann zeigen sie es auch noch. Wenn man sich überlegt, wie glatt diese ganzen Dokus alle sind, und da gibt es halt die und du denkst, oh Gott, wenn das schon die geglättete Version ist, wow, okay. Dann haben die nicht nur in gutem Fußball gespielt, nicht nur auch ihre Darbys gegen Newcastle gewonnen, die ja auch nicht ganz unwichtig sind, insbesondere in der Region, sondern haben sich am allerletzten Spieltag dann sogar noch für Europa qualifiziert, obwohl vorher die Gerüchte schon laut wurden, dass die Lebris eventuell entlassen würden, für den Fall, dass sie nicht europäisch qualifizieren würden, was unglaublich wäre, wenn man überhaupt nur eine Sekunde daran denkt.
Jakob, kann es nicht fassen, die Hörer und Hörerinnen.
Mein Bruder hat mir das gesagt und ich habe gesagt, ey, so blöd sind die nicht. Dann sagte er, doch, ohne Witz, schau. Er hat mir zwei Quellen genannt, die schreiben, dass darüber nachgedacht wird. Und ich habe gesagt, wow, wenn das passiert, dann sollen sie in die dritte Liga durchgereicht werden, weil das wäre ja Wahnsinn. Aber am Ende haben sie sich für Europa qualifiziert mit einem Fußball, der gut passt und auch ein paar Charakteren, die gut in diese Region passen, was glaube ich nicht immer ganz unwichtig ist. Luke O'Nine, wahrscheinlich als allererstes Beispiel, der sogar Stammspieler geworden ist als Innenverteidiger. Also keine Ahnung warum. Ist eigentlich ein Drittligal-Level-Spieler, der plötzlich dann in der Premier League auch jetzt nicht ernsthaft mithält, aber zumindest halt so den emotionalen Leader auf dem Platz gibt. Absoluter Fanliebling gewesen. Er ist auch einer der unfreiwilligen Hauptdarsteller von Sanderländel. So lange ist er schon da und das ist sicherlich was, was auch nochmal zeigt gegen die ganzen Großmächte. Also Chelsea hat sich jetzt zum Beispiel nicht qualifiziert. Kannst du trotzdem als Premier League gallisches Dorf, auch wenn das schon klar ist, also richtig gallisch ist jetzt nicht, aber kannst du dich trotzdem für Europa qualifizieren? Und das ist mit Leads gemeinsam, die wahrscheinlich weniger investiert haben, aber ebenfalls als Aufstegge drin geblieben sind, sind auf jeden Fall Geschichten, wo ich gerne drauf geschaut habe und wo ich mir auch jedes Mal wieder dachte, eigentlich kann es gar nicht passiert sein, aber es ist halt passiert.
Und man muss ja auch sagen, also ja, das Geld kommt von drei Fuß und so weiter und so fort, aber eben die ganze Struktur von Sunderland, man muss mit Bundesliga-Vergleichen vorsichtig sein, aber so ein bisschen hatte das schon Schalke 04-Vibes oder vielleicht auch 1860-Vibes, also eine irre, treue Zuseherschaft. So ein paar Tausend kommen da immer. Das hast du eben auch in dieser Doku sehr gut gemerkt, mit allen auch sozioökonomischen Begleiterscheinungen, also dass die eigentlich treuesten Fans dann zum Teil es gar nicht mehr ins Stadion geschafft haben früher, weil die Ticketpreise so hoch waren und so. Also das, was du eben auch einfach im englischen Fußball so hast. Und aber auch deshalb so ein enorm schwieriges Umfeld, um dort zu arbeiten, weil eben sich halt auch alle Augen in der Stadt auf diesen Verein richten und da sind eben regelmäßig welche dran zerbrochen, sowohl Trainer als auch Spieler. Und ehrlich gesagt habe ich das jetzt zum ersten Mal gecheckt, dass ich ja Luke O'Nine damals in der Doku gesehen habe. Und jetzt fällt es mir auch ein, das ist ja wirklich witzig, dass der jetzt mit 31 Innenverteidigungen in der Premier League ist und die Europa League einzieht. Ja, das ist wirklich eine viel gute Story.
Es gibt auch keinen sportlichen Grund dafür, aber er ist halt noch da.
Das ist auch nicht so schön.
Ganz ehrlich, da stimmt ja gar nichts. Aber egal, der hat auch in dieser Innenverteidigung, es sind da drei, die da spielen, sonst glaube ich würde das auch nicht packen. Der ist nicht schnell genug im Kopf, der macht eigentlich nichts richtig, aber er scheint halt einfach weiterhin ein wahnsinnig wichtiger Spieler in der Kabine zu sein. Und der schafft halt einfach diese Symbiose zum Publikum herzustellen. Und das darf man glaube ich nicht unterschätzen. Also es gab ganz, ganz, ganz viele Heimspiele. Das war das Team, das am spätesten ein Heimspiel verloren hat in der Liga.
Also alle anderen haben früher verloren. Ganz lange umgeschlagen, wie im Zuhause.
Genau, ein bisschen komisches Konstrukt. Aber es muss einfach eine Rolle gespielt haben. Und dann waren am Ende natürlich auch ein paar Verletzte mit dabei, sodass er dann überhaupt auf diese Halbverteidigerposition gerutscht ist. Aber er ist dann dahingerutscht. Ich habe 2, 3 Spiele gemacht, wo ich mir dachte, oh, also da hätte er jeweils auf dem Platz fliegen können. Aber er ist da und das Publikum kann sich total identifizieren. Bei dem ganzen Zusammenstellungsrausch, den es da im Sommer gab, hat zumindest das Board und auch der Trainer nicht vergessen, dass das nicht ganz unwichtig ist, dass man sich auch bei Spielern zumindest ein paar Attributen bedient, die auch nicht unsinnvoll sind in diesem Publikum. Es gab dann auch ganz andere, die sich dazu verpflichtet haben, aber sie haben schon auch darauf geachtet, auch schon vorher. Im Übrigen bei Trae Youm zum Beispiel oder bei Dan Ballard. Es ist genauso, das sind so Spieler, die ganz klassisch auch Sunderland verkörpern. Michele hat zum Beispiel eine Riesensaison übrigens gespielt. Das war so jemand, wo man eher gesagt hat, naja, weiß ich nicht, ob das hört sich so danach an, der ist jetzt ein Jahr da, dann steigt er ab und ist halt wieder weg. So wie er ja, glaube ich, jedes Jahr gewechselt hatte in den letzten vier, fünf Jahren. Also da sind ja auch Dinge dabei, da kann man sich in fünf Jahren gar nicht mehr daran erinnern. Da war mein Leverkusen dann bei Paris, in Leipzig, also irgendwie überall und nirgends. Aber die Mischung hat dann offensichtlich gepasst. Und ich habe relativ schnell, also die haben auch so einen Trend gesetzt mit eben Sardiki, den ich total fast schon verehre. Werden wir auch bei der WM sehen, ganz toller Fußballer. Die haben diese Carries, diese wirklich in wenigen Sekunden einfach 25 Meter Raum gewinnen mit Ball am Fuß. Das ist unglaublich, wie die beiden das machen. Und das Mittelfeld alleine hat die da schon durchgepowert mit eben dann dem kompletten Automaten Schacker, der einfach gar nichts falsch gemacht hat in der Saison. Ist schon richtig gut. Rubi, der ja jetzt auch mal in Leipzig war, ein paar werden sich vielleicht noch daran erinnern. Er hat da nicht ernsthaft für Momente gesorgt, an die man sich erinnern muss. Aber er hat plötzlich angefangen wirklich mit seinem sehr Kleinen, der ist ja nicht groß, aber so super Bulli, super kräftigen Stürmertypen. Er hat nicht ernsthaft getroffen, aber viele Bälle vorne festgemacht und so. Hat mir auch sehr gut gefallen. Sodass Sunderland immer, das war immer schön, die gesehen zu haben, weil da hat sich immer was gerührt in den Spielen. Und das mochte ich sehr gerne.
Ja, Kranechaka, gar nicht so schlecht. Von Leverkusen weggewechselt, die sind 6. geworden. Zu Sunderland, die sind 7. geworden. Hat er sich verschlechtert? Das tut einem natürlich dann schon ein bisschen leid, hätte er bei Leverkusen.
Im Winter gab es Gerüchte, der Christian weiß es noch, da habe ich dich mal dazu gefragt, dass er zu Milan wechselt. Plötzlich, also im Winter, wirklich nach einem halben Jahr Sunderland. Komischerweise gab es dann die Hartnäckigen Gerüchte, dass Milan den super gerne gehabt hätte.
Die hätten den schon gerne davor gehabt, auch schon nach Leverkusen. Ich wollte auch noch, schön, dass ihr ihn anspricht. Merkt man vielleicht ein bisschen Wert, den Granit Xhaka bei seinen letzten zwei Stationen für seine Clubs hatte. Was man ja auch in der Schweizer Nationalmannschaft auch ein bisschen sieht. Also vielleicht einer– jetzt unsanghero ist vielleicht ein großes Wort, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine. Nicht einer von denen, die als allererstes falten. Aber schau dir mal die letzten Jahre vor dem im Clubfußballland. Dann, glaube ich, hast du genügend Antworten.
Ja, das ist wahr. Das ist aber echt so. Uli, dann wolltest du noch kurz über Leads sprechen. Auch Aufsteiger, die sehr erfolgreich rausgekommen sind. Am Ende Rang 14. Zwischendurch sah es aber mal gar nicht so gut aus. Wir haben ja immer so einen besonderen Blick auf Daniel Fahke, weil wir ihn hier auch bei Gladbach gesehen haben. Da hat irgendwann so komplett jede Aktivität gefehlt. Und auch so manche Ausstellungsentscheidungen waren damals nicht so ganz nachvollziehbar. Die große Bensi bei Ihnen.
Einwechslungen vor allen Dingen.
Ja gut, und Einwechslungen.
Die gab es ja nicht.
Wenn man dann allerdings sieht, wie es dann so weiterging bei Gladbach, dann wiederholten sich manche Probleme und man bekam den Eindruck, vielleicht lag es nicht komplett an Daniel Fahke, um es sich jetzt mal so ganz vorsichtig auszudrücken. Wie hat es denn jetzt bei Lies gemacht? Es ist ja auch quasi eine Rückkehr gewesen. Und wie hat es sie dann letztlich ja so souverän in der Liga gehalten?
Ja, es ist total erstaunlich. Ich probiere mal, die wichtigsten Punkte abzubilden. Im Sommer ist er aufgestiegen und mit viel mehr Chaos als für eine 100-Punkte-Saison normal. Also eigentlich Rekordaufstieg für Leads-Verhältnisse zumindest. Dann wollten sie ihn im Sommer entlasten und das stimmt auch. Die 49ers Enterprises als auch Red Bull halten da ja die Anteile und beide hatten gar keinen Bock auf Daniel Fahke, weil sie ihm nicht zugetraut haben, dass er in der Premier League coachen kann, sondern nur als Aufstiegstrainer gut sei. Plus er ist halt nicht sexy genug mit den... Der hat ja so ein paar ganz eigene Marotten. Gladbach-Fans werden ganz genau wissen, was ich meine. Ist ein sehr eigener, teilweise auch so ein bisschen... Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man sagen soll, so ein Eigenbrötler irgendwie auf eine Weise. Er trägt ganz oft das Gleiche und läuft auch immer noch... Also er lief jetzt auch so lange es ging mit seiner Winterjacke rum, weil er halt denkt, dass es die, die ihm Erfolg bringt, obwohl es halt schon 25 Grad hatte oder so. Also es ist einfach ein bisschen crazy. Und die wollten den entlassen, haben ihn dann aber behalten. Hake selbst wiederum hat schon früh gesagt, diese Mannschaft ist viel zu soft, er braucht mehr Athletik, er braucht mehr Kraft, mehr Galle in dieser Truppe, um überhaupt in der Premier League bestehen zu können. Das ist eigentlich von außen draus betrachtet so la la passiert. Also ich dachte nicht im Sommer, ah ja, das sind all die Zutaten, die es aber braucht, um diesen Befund zu widerlegen. Es ging okay los in der Saison, auch da ziemlich heimstark gewesen, eine ganze Zeit lang, aber auch nur okay. Dann gab es im Dezember die Fügung, dass Mitte Dezember war klar, es würde bis Mitte Januar den heftigsten Spielplan geben, den du dir vorstellen kannst. Sie waren alle drin, City, Arsenal, mehrfach auch, Chelsea, Liverpool, you name it, auch Manchester United, der Rosenkrieg, Leeds und Manchester United. Da haben sie dann auch gewonnen, ein ganz wichtiges Spiel in der Saison. Da dachten alle spätestens alle gut, das Vorhaben, Fahke zu entlassen, wird auf jeden Fall jetzt im Dezember stattfinden. Es gab das eine Spiel gegen Manchester City, da lagen sie nach 20 Minuten mit, ich kriege es jetzt nicht mehr ganz hin, ich glaube zwei oder drei Toren zurück, das habe ich sogar gemacht damals auch. Und dann hat Fahke plötzlich umgestellt auf Fünferkette. Und schon in diesem Spiel hatte das erste kleinere Erfolge, sie haben es zwar verloren, aber haben sich eigentlich ganz gut aus der Fähre gezogen. Fortan hat Fahke dieses System durchspielen lassen, was den Effekt hatte, dass sie deutlich weniger kassiert haben und vor allen Dingen die Stärken von Dominik Herbert Lewin haben ausspielen können, der dann plötzlich als Einzelspitze drin war und einfach wahnsinnig gut, also erstens mal gesund blieb. Das war ja das größte Problem der letzten Jahre bei ihm, dass er ständig verletzt war, eigentlich ein guter Stürmer, das war auch ein Klar, der blieb gesund und dann haben die angefangen, die Spiele so eins zu null zu ergrinden. Auswärts zwar selten gewonnen, aber so gut wie nicht mehr verloren. Und so waren die dann am Ende drei Wochen vor Schluss schon recht sicher gerettet. Kleine Randnotiz auch, Anton Stach hat eine fantastische Saison gespielt sogar, richtig tolle Tore erzielt, fast ausschließlich Distanzschüsse, einer der gefährlichsten Distanzschützen gewesen, fast gar keine Fehler gemacht. Ich habe das auch mal in einem Spiel, das fanden nicht alle so gut aus seinem Camp, aber so ist es nun mal. Das Einzige, was man ihm vorwerfen kann, ist, dass er relativ häufig verletzt ausgefallen ist. Aber ansonsten scheint er auch die Standards gut gesetzt zu haben innerhalb der Kabine, was man so hört. Das ist ja auch nicht immer so ohne Weiteres in Deutschland so gewesen. Da gab es schon auch andere Gerüchte und so. Aber ich kann ihm gar nichts vorwerfen. Im Gegenteil, er ist sogar aus meiner Sicht Leads-Spieler der Saison auf jeden Fall. Wenn man weitergehen wollte, dann hätte man das sogar so benennen können, dass er sogar eine Chance hat, irgendwo so Fringe auf Spieler der Saison überhaupt, also zumindest einer der einflussreichsten Spieler, wenn man es mal so ausdrücken möchte. Und Haffke hat das Ganze am Ende gut gemacht. Ich warte eigentlich minütlich auf die Meldung, dass er geht, weil ich den so stolz eingeschätzt habe, dass er das Mikrofon fallen lässt, nachdem er jetzt gezeigt hat, was er kann. Nämlich, das hätte ich ihm auch nie zugetraut, wenn du dich an Gladbach zurückerinnerst, ich hatte immer gar keine Fantasie, dass Daniel Haffke abseits des Balles ein Team aufstellen kann. Das war immer wild, immer. Es war immer nur eine offensive Philosophie. Und er hat aus diesem Team eins der härtest arbeitenden gemacht, eins der unangenehmsten, physischsten und beststrukturiertesten Teams in der ganzen Liga. Das hat ihn am Ende die Klasse gehalten. Die Aktiefarke ist nie höher gewesen in England. Es gab auch größere Teams, gerade West Ham zum Beispiel, hat ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht, das müsste doch eigentlich der Mann sein, der uns wieder hochführt und dann stabilisiert. Auch wenn Maximilian Hahn jetzt nicht mehr da ist, Chef-Recruiter, ehemals Werder Bremen, junger Mann, der gute Arbeit geleistet hat, Deutscher. Aber noch ist er da. Ich kann mir nur nicht vorstellen, dass er in die nächste Saison geht, weil ich glaube nicht, dass er das vergessen kann. Also das ist nur meine, so wie ich ihn. Ich kenne ihn jetzt nicht gut, aber wir haben ein paar Mal gesprochen, um Podcast ja auch zu hören gewesen und so. Alles, was ich von dem so wahrgenommen habe, ist immer, dass lässt er sich nicht gefallen. Deswegen habe ich irgendwie gedacht, eigentlich nach dem letzten Spieltag wird es schon ein, das lasse ich, das mache ich ja nicht mehr mit. Tschüss, aber noch ein Sender.
Ja, und man muss auch sagen, vielleicht wäre es auch eine ganz gute Selbstanalyse, weil sie hatten so eine Phase im März, also Ende Februar, März bis so rein in den April, wo sie wirklich viele Expected Goals ergänzt hatten. Also die Gegner hatten hohe Expected Goals und sie lagen immer drunter. Und dann, und ich habe das gerade in den Statistiken gesehen und habe mal die Ergebnisse dazu abgeglichen. Dann habe ich gesehen, okay, 0-1, 0-1, 0-0, 0-0 und 2 zu 1 noch gewonnen. Also sie kamen da auch dann wirklich ganz gut weg. Das war letztlich die Phase, wo dann alles klar war, okay, also die rutschen nicht mehr unten rein. Tottenham muss es aus eigener Kraft schaffen, sage ich jetzt einfach mal so.
Generell Expected Metric, das zweithöchsten overperformende Team der Liga. Also die haben schon wahnsinnig Spielglück sozusagen gehabt oder wie auch immer. Das muss man schon nochmal fairerweise dazu sagen, dass das so ist, ja.
Ja, ich habe gelesen im Buch von Christoph Bielmann, wir sollen nicht mehr Spielglück sagen. Eigentlich ist es ja einfach nur der Zufall, der halt im Fußball eine Rolle spielt. Aber es ist so ein Wort, das sich irgendwann etabliert hat, um eben aufzuhalten.
Ja, aber ich finde schon, dass es passt. Also ich mag auch nicht so gerne benutze Formulierungen, aber es gab schon überdurchschnittlich viele Situationen in Spielen, wo ich dachte, das fällt, wenn es blöd läuft, einfach auch blöder manchmal. Und das ist halt am besten zum Schreiben, finde ich, am Ende mit Spielglück.
Ja, du, finde ich auch. Ich habe es nur da gelesen. Fand ich einen interessanten Gedanken. Also das waren Sunderland und Leeds. Dann, Christian, wollen wir nochmal nach Italien blicken. Wir haben jetzt schon das Chaos bei Milan aufgearbeitet. Was ist denn noch nach dieser Saison bemerkenswert?
Ja, wenn Uli jetzt schon mit viel Gut ums Eck gekommen ist, dann bleibe ich doch wieder beim problematischen Bart oder beim traurigen Bart. Dann gehe ich wieder zurück. Juwe. Dann sind wir bei Juwe. Dumm dumm dumm dumm. Dann sind wir bei Juwe, denn nicht nur Milan wird nächstes Jahr nicht Champions League spielen, sondern auch Juwe. Kleiner Fun-Fact, wirklich beeindruckende Statistik, wie ich finde, zum ersten Mal seit 35 Jahren spielen weder Milan noch Juwe in der Champions League. Krass. Das zeigt schon ein bisschen, dass die zwei aus Italien da schon immer relativ verlässlich dabei waren. Wo fangen wir an? Also, Juwe, ganz kurz, wie es dazu kam. Bei Juwe kam es nicht am letzten Spieltag dazu, sondern Juwe hat doch vorletztes Spieltag das Genick gebrochen. Also Juwe war am vorletzten, also vor Anpfiff des vorletzten Spieltags war Juwe dritter. Also war auch total, hatte alles selbst in der Hand. Am Ende sind sie jetzt sechster geworden und hatten ein Heimspiel gegen die Fiorentina, die schon gerettet war und verlieren dieses Heimspiel 0-2. Und waren dadurch dann am letzten Spieltag auf Schützenhilfe angewiesen. Die kamen nicht mehr und abgesehen davon, dass sie auch das Derby nicht mehr gewonnen haben, aber das war unter so realen Verhältnissen, denn da war es schon zur Halbzeit klar, dass Juwe nicht mehr in die Champions League kommen kann. Am Ende haben sie dann 2-2 gespielt. Ja, Juwe zum ersten Mal, auch vielleicht ganz interessant. Juwe zum ersten Mal seit 2012, 2013, dass sie sich nicht sportlich für die Champions League qualifiziert haben. Also klar, es gab das eine Jahr vor wenigen Jahren, wo sie dann durch den Punktabzug rausgerutscht sind und europäisch eben überhaupt nicht gespielt haben. Aber auch in der Saison unter La Liga hatten sie sich sportlich für die Champions League qualifiziert. Also es ist jetzt wirklich eine Zäsur. Und ja, bringt Juwe vor große Probleme. Ich stehe auch dazu, ich war der, der vor ein paar Monaten noch gesagt hat, ich traue Juwe nächstes Jahr den großen Sprung zu. Weil sie eben, wie ich finde, eine gute Basis gelegt haben. Gerade mit Spalletti, der ja übernahm von Tudor. Und ich ihnen wirklich zugetraut hätte, wenn sie jetzt im Sommer ein, zwei cleverere Moves auf dem Transfermarkt gemacht hätten, glaube ich, hätten sie nächstes Jahr zumindest interkitzeln können. Jetzt, ohne diese Champions League, steht halt vieles mit großen Fragezeichen. Denn in Italien sind immer so die Schätzungen, 60, 70 Millionen Euro flöten. Also die sind jetzt erstmal nicht da, die die Champions League gebracht hätte. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, dass Juve seit vielen Jahren mit großen finanziellen Geschichten zu kämpfen hat. Also Juve ist ja börsennotiert. Es gab in den letzten Jahren immer wieder Kapitalerhöhungen im Bereich von Hunderten von Millionen Euro. Also diese Champions League Millionen waren eigentlich schon so der Grundstock, der Juve quasi da wirtschaftlich gehalten hat. Jetzt fallen die halt zum ersten Mal weg. Und aber anders als bei Milan, ich habe da... Deswegen ist es schön, dass die zwei, finde ich, unterschiedlich sind. Denn bei Milan, ich habe vorhin ganz wenig über Allegri gesagt, aber jetzt den einen Satz bringe ich noch. Allegri ist ein Trainer, den du über Resultate definierst und der sich auch über Ergebnisse definiert. Und wenn das Ergebnis dann nicht kommt, wie dieses Jahr bei Milan, dann ist das eine absolute Fehlleistung. Ganz klar. Punkt. Bei Spalletti bin ich genau auf der anderen Seite. Also ich finde, Spalletti ist nicht das Problem, sondern auch jetzt noch die Lösung von Juwe. Denn Spalletti hat Juwe viel gebracht. Er hat ja Ende Oktober übernommen. Ich glaube jetzt am Ende vielleicht auch dieses Unentschieden im letzten Spiel ist es nicht mehr, aber er war eigentlich bis zum vorletzten Spieltag Nummer 2 hinter Inter, also sozusagen in der Spallettitabelle. Juwe ist statistisch in all den großen Statistiken auf Platz 2 hinter Inter nur. Zweitbester Angriff, zweitmeistete Torabschlüsse, zweitmeisten Expected Goals. Also er hat Juwe viel gebracht. Er hat eine Struktur reingebracht. Juwe hat wieder einen erkennbaren Offensivfußball gespielt. Aber– und jetzt kommen wir halt zum Punkt– bei Juwe ist das Problem, und das haben wir hier auch schon das eine oder andere Mal angerissen, weil Juwe ist ja mit die jüngste Mannschaft der Serie A. Also letztes Jahr war sie die zweitjüngste der ganzen Liga. Also die Zeiten sind vorbei, als Juwe mit erfahrenen Haudegen ums Eck kam. Und man muss sagen– und ich mag mich, glaube ich, zu erinnern, dass ich das auch mal gesagt habe vor ein paar Wochen oder Monaten hier– ich bin gespannt, ob sie den Druckstand halten. Und man muss jetzt sagen, nein, sie haben nicht den Druckstand gehalten. Denn Juwe hat die letzten drei Heimspiele gegen Sassuolo– lange schon gerettet– Hellas abgestiegen und die Fiorentine lange schon gerettet. Und aus diesen drei Heimspielen haben sie zwei Punkte geholt. Wenn sie nur eines dieser Spiele gewonnen hätte, wären Juwe in der Champions League. Und das zeigt für mich, dass dieser Kader, eben diese fehlende Leadership, über die wir hier schon immer wieder mal kurz angerissen haben, dass ihnen das das Genick gebrochen hat. Weil du musst von Juwe verlangen können, dass ich diese Heimspiele gewinne. Und das sind wir jetzt halt bei der Kaderstruktur, die darauf ausgelegt ist, dass da mit allen vor allem logisch Kinn in Yildiz, das Gesicht des neuen Juwe ist. Viele talentierte Jüngere, Kalulu, Concesau, Turam, Kefren Turam, das sind viele Spieler, die sind entwicklungsfähig, die haben schon gute Schritte gemacht. Aber die haben jetzt halt den Druck von Juwe zu spüren bekommen. Von der Größe dieses Klubs, die er immer noch hat, auch wenn er seit Jahren nicht mehr erfolgreich ist. Und ich würde sagen, die sind an dem Druck, hauptsächlich die Spieler zu pochen und Ballett, die nämlich da explizit zu großen Teilen, logisch kann ich nicht zu allen Teilen, aber zu großen Teilen aus der Rechnung.
Aber wie ist denn jetzt die Perspektive von Juwe? Also, weil es war jetzt ja schon im Grunde seit vielen Jahren, seit vier, fünf Jahren ist es ja schon so, dass Juwe seine sportlichen Ziele nicht erreicht und schlechter spielt, als es könnte. Und man aber immer das Potenzial gesehen hat, na gut, jetzt schaffen sie den Umbruch. Jetzt schaffen sie den Umbruch. Und de facto ist es aber so, es wurde ja schon stückweise immer schlechter. Und das betrifft beides, sowohl die finanzielle Situation als auch die sportliche Situation. Also, ohne ins Detail gehen zu wollen, aber allein in den letzten drei Jahren hat Juwe vor Steuern einen Verlust von 551 Millionen Euro gemacht. Das ist mit weitem Abstand Rang 1 in der Serie A. Roma, Inter und dann Milan sind die anderen Vereine, die dahinter liegen, was eben so quasi aus der Spitzengruppe diejenigen angeht, die Verluste machen. Aber da reden wir von 100 Millionen, 150 Millionen sogar schon weniger. Also, du hast es ja mit den Kapitalerhöhungen genannt. Das haben die letztlich gebraucht, um einen Cashflow aufrechtzuerhalten, weil die laufen ansonsten eigentlich auf eine Zahlungsunfähigkeit zu. Das wird nicht passieren, weil im Fußball funktionieren so Bilanzen und so weiter, funktionieren anders. Aber das ist eigentlich schon dramatisch. Wenn das einem anderen Team passieren würde, würden wir sagen, boah, die stehen aber wirklich so kurz davor, die müssen jetzt nur einmal, nochmal die Champions League verpassen und dann gehen die so Richtung BVB Anfang der 2000er und sind in einem ganz tiefen Loch. Wie groß siehst du denn die Gefahr und wie ist die Perspektive letztlich jetzt von Juwe?
Ja, die Perspektive ist jetzt eben schwierig. Das ist ja der Punkt. Ich habe ja auch immer darauf hingewiesen. Also fangen wir mal so an. Der Druck von Juwe, wie du ja sagst, Juwe hat seit Jahren nicht mehr den Druck, Meister werden zu müssen, weil da waren sie länger weg. Letztes Jahr haben sie auch erst am letzten Spieltag durch einen Elfmeter von Locatelli in der 80. bei Venedig den Champions League-Einzug klar gemacht. Also der Trend ist es schon länger. Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt plötzlich, oh, Opala, jetzt sind die halt ausgerutscht. Die sind die letzten zwei, drei Jahre auch immer gerade so vierter, dritter geworden. Also das ist, genau, ist nichts Neues. Der Punkt ist nur, sie haben es halt immer noch geschafft und dann durch diese Champions League-Millionen sozusagen weiterhin, sag ich mal, ja, ihr, ihr Dasein oder auch ihr potentielles Wachstum, was ich weiterhin sehe, Klammer zu, äh, aufrechterhalten können. Aber jetzt hast du eben das riesen Problem, jetzt ist es zum ersten Mal passiert, dass du rausgerutscht bist. Nochmal 60, 70 Millionen Euro weniger. Ähm, jetzt werden bei deinen durchaus talentierten Spielern, die du ja hast, weil du hast die letzten zwei, drei Jahre, da durchaus einen interessanten Kader, ein entwicklungsfähigen Kader auf die Beine gestellt. Ich glaube, wir müssen alle keine Propheten sein, dass jetzt bei den Beratern von Yildiz, Toram und Co. immer wieder Anrufe eingehen werden, wo es heißt, oh, hat euer Kollege nicht Lust, nächstes Jahr Champions League zu spielen. Also jetzt bist du erst mal total in der defensiven Position auf dem Transfermarkt. Jetzt musst du erst mal abwehren, dass deine durchaus interessanten Spieler bleiben. Plus, könnt ihr euch erinnern, haben wir eh hier beim letzten Mal gehabt, Bernardo Silva war zum Beispiel ein Thema. Bernardo Silva, glaube ich, wäre genau– ich nenne jetzt einfach Bernardo Silva als Symbol, ich weiß nicht, wie weit da die Gespräche waren– aber Bernardo Silva wäre genau das gewesen, was Juve gebraucht hätte. Genau das. Einer, der extreme sportliche Qualität hat, der Erfahrung hat, der Winnermentalität hat. Einen, den du da vielleicht reinsetzt und dann ziehen sich die Locatellis und Torams an dem hoch. Und ziehen auch weiter voran. Aber Bernardo Silva kommt logischerweise nicht ohne Champions League, ist ja ganz klar. Der spielt Champions League. So, also mit diesem Fiorentiner Heimspiel war das vom Tisch gewischt. Also auch dieser nächste Entwicklungsschritt ist schwierig. Und das dritte eben, dir fehlen diese 60, 70 Millionen. Ja, wie holst du die rein? Ja, du musst jetzt erstmal verkaufen. Und ein Name, der gerade fällt, ist Bremer. Weil bei Yildiz bin ich mir sicher, dass sie alles probieren werden. Keine Ahnung, ob das... Also ihn zu halten, weil er wirklich das Gesicht nicht nur der Gegenwart, sondern auch der Zukunft sein wird. Ob es klappt, weiß ich nicht. Wenn ich jetzt einen Tipp abgeben müsste, würde ich schon sagen, dass Yiliz nächstes Jahr auch noch bei Juve spielt. Aber keine Ahnung, was sich da im Sommer entwickelt. Aber Bremer ist zum Beispiel einer, der hat schon vor Monaten gesagt, als Juve noch gut dastand, hey, wir dümpeln hier bei Juve seit 5, 6 Jahren rum. Und darauf habe ich relativ wenig Lust, weil ich will auch Erfolge haben. Ich will umgroße Titel spielen. Und so einen wie Bremer musst du jetzt womöglich opfern, um eben sozusagen dieses Geld, dieses fehlende Geld reinzuholen. Und dann fällt dir halt ein Puzzlestück raus, womöglich das ein sehr wichtiges ist, der ja auch einen wichtigen Teil sozusagen in dieser Mannschaft auf dem Sprung ist. Also, Max, du merkst es gerade, ich kann es dir auch nicht genau beantworten, wie die Perspektive ist. Auf jeden Fall Fakt ist, dass es diese sehr verpasste Champions League ein krasser, harter Einschnitt ist. Und nochmal, Spalletti hat das logisch mitverantwortet. Sehr klar, er ist der Cheftrainer, er geht auch damit nach Hause. Aber ich finde, dass Spalletti vieles gemacht hat, vieles Gutes gemacht hat. Und deswegen kann ich Juve nur wünschen, dass sie mit ihm weitermachen. Schaut auch im Moment danach aus. Ich sehe die Probleme eher im Kader. Wie gesagt, wenig Leadership. Wenn Locatelli dein Kapitän ist, vollen Respekt für Manuel Locatelli. Er ist ein guter Spieler, der kann auch bei Juve spielen, ist nicht der Punkt, ist auch ein Europameister von vor wenigen Jahren. Aber wenn Manuel Locatelli der Juve-Kapitän ist, dann zeigt es schon ein bisschen, dass vielleicht die Leadership nicht mehr die ist, wie es sie mal war. Und wenn dann deine Transfer sitzt über zwei, drei Jahren, wenn du für Openda, Cobmeiners und Douglas-Louis akkumuliert 150 Millionen Euro ausgibst, also jeweils um die 50 für die drei im Schnitt. Und wir reden hier nicht über den Premier League-Club, sondern das sind für italienische Verhältnisse krasse Ausgaben für den einzelnen Spieler. Und wenn die drei alle nicht funktionieren, weil Openda, Cobmeiners und Douglas-Louis keiner hat zu Null funktioniert, dann kriegst du jetzt die Rechnung. Weil dann irgendwann kannst du das nicht mehr auffangen. Solche Transfers in solcher Größenordnung müssen bei einem italienischen Club im Moment, wie die italienischen Clubs im Weltfußball wirtschaftlich positioniert sind, die müssen zünden. Die haben nicht gezündet. Und jetzt ist das ein großes Problem.
Ich meine, sie haben noch das Club-WM-Geld, wobei, wenn ich das jetzt hier auf die Schnelle richtig gesehen habe…
Das ist schon der Bilanz, ne?
ist es in der Vorjahresbilanz. Genau. Man hat schon gesehen, dass sie jetzt die letzten Jahre immer mehr versucht haben, bei den Gehaltskosten runterzugehen. Also insgesamt eben schlanker zu werden. Weil, also, die haben ja auch die Verluste gesehen, die sie jedes Jahr gemacht haben.
Aber krass. Das war ja auch Teil der Verjüngung. Also du hast dich von den Spielern– und da rede ich jetzt gar nicht von Christiano Ronaldo, das ist schon lange her– aber ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, auch solche Angel, die Marias waren noch vor wenigen Jahren bei Juve. Die haben unfassbare Gehalter gefressen. Von denen haben sich alle getrennt, auch die Bonuccis. Das waren große, große, wie sagt man, Gehaltsposten, die ihm alle abgegeben wurden oder nicht mehr verlängert wurden, um eben Yildiz, Thurams zu holen, die du eben nach oben bringst. Und ich finde, der Weg hier weiter ist kein schlechter. Wie gesagt, deswegen auch ein Punkt Welden, vielleicht mit dem Bernardo Silva der Situation. Kannst du, glaube ich, Juve, könntest du es nochmal ein großes Stück nach oben bringen. Aber das wird jetzt halt, durch diese letzten Spieltage, verdammt schwer. Drei zahlen nur noch, weil ja eben Spalletti, klar, der geht jetzt heim damit, er ist der Trainer, der Juve nicht in die Champions League geführt hat. Aber in diesen drei Heimspielen gegen Sassuolo, Hellas und der Fiorentina hatte Juve jeweils zwischen 2,5 und 3 Expected Goals. Gegen Sassuolo haben sie in der 87. Halfmeter verschossen beim 1-1. Und haben insge- also was habe ich gesagt? 2,5, 3 Expected Goals und sie haben in diesen drei Spielen zwei Tore geschossen. Da muss ich sagen, irgendwann, sorry, ja, wir können viel über Trainer sprechen, aber irgendwann müssen es dann auch die Spieler richten. Und vielleicht das Bild dazu, Concesão, der quirlige Portugiese, den kennt ihr auch alle. Das ist ein feiner Fußballer, der ist gut im 1 gegen 1. Der ist aber halt so ein bisschen das Sinnbild für Juve in der Saison. Der hatte den Expected Goals Wert von um die 8 und geht mit drei Toren aus der Saison. Also er bringt sich immer wieder in gute Situationen. Die Systematik von Spalletti bringt ihn in gute Situationen. Und der Mann, der kommt zu wenig dabei rum. Und das finde ich, deswegen bin ich schon auch ein Freund davon, da dann auch die Spieler die Verantwortung reinzunehmen. Weil ich finde, ein Trainer kann die Systematik mitgeben. Kann der Mannschaft gerade im Spiel mit Ball helfen, Lösungen zu finden. Das hat Spalletti getan. Am Ende geht jetzt Juve aus der Saison mit minus 13 Expected Goals raus. Also die haben Expected Goals von 74, Platz 2 in der Liga und gehen mit 61 Toren raus. Ich finde, da kann man dann schon auch über die Spieler sprechen.
Das kann aber auch Hoffnung machen, weil normalerweise sich Expected Goals über einen längeren Zeitraum als 38 Spiele dann auch amortisieren. Also habe ich gerade 38 gesagt, 36 Spiele meinte ich. 38 in der Zahl, stimmt ja. Nee, doch, stimmt. Hatte ich schon richtig. Na ja, egal. Auf jeden Fall. Normalerweise pendet sich das eigentlich so wieder ein. Aber wirklich interessante Situation bei Juve. Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Fabian, du hast vorhin bei meiner ersten Frage, was ist so los in der Liga? Hast du alle Fragen beantwortet? Was hast du dir übrig gelassen?
Noch ein paar Feel-Good-Stories. Dazu müssen wir wieder zurück auf die positive Schiene kommen.
Ja, sehr gerne.
So nämlich.
Meine Freunde von, also es gibt eigentlich drei Clubs, die ich da herausstellen möchte. Das ist Celta Vigo, Betis Sevilla und den FC Villarreal. Und ich fange gleich sehr gerne mal mit Celta Vigo an, weil Vigo, die hatten wir schon ein paar Mal in der Ligatur auch besprochen. Die hatten vor eineinhalb, zwei Jahren jetzt, glaube ich, ja, standen sie mit dem Rücken zur Wand, haben dann einen drastischen Trainerwechsel gemacht oder eine drastische Entscheidung getroffen, dass sie quasi ihren Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft, das Vertrauen ausgesprochen haben, Claudio Chiraldes, 38 inzwischen. Und der hat Vigo jetzt wieder international sexy gemacht. Er hat es vor allen Dingen nicht mit enormen finanziellen Mitteln geschafft, sondern mit sehr viel Eigengewächsen, die er natürlich kannte aus der zweiten Mannschaft, aus dem Reservateam, und hat aber jetzt auch geschafft, das Team punktuell zu verstärken. Auch dieses Jahr wieder ein paar interessante Spieler geholt. Borja Iglesias ist zurückgekommen, der inzwischen 33, der spanische Nationalspieler, der mit 14 Toren ordentlich gebombt hat, hat keiner ihm mehr zugetraut und ist aber, spielt bei seinem Heimatklub, also von daher, läuft Borja noch mal den einen oder anderen Meter mehr wahrscheinlich. Und man hat mit Ferdinand Jutkla einen geholt, der aus der Masiya, aus der Basa-Akademie stammt und der über Brügge den Weg jetzt zurückgeschafft hat in La Liga zu Vigo. Und ja, die haben vor allen Dingen in der Offensive jetzt sich ordentlich Alternativen geschaffen und wir haben es ja auch gesehen bis ins Viertelfinale der Europa League geschafft. Dort für mich relativ überraschend deutlich dann gegen Freiburg ausgeschieden. Hätte ich mehr, hätte ich so nicht, habe ich so nicht gesehen. Aber spricht vielleicht in dem Fall eher für Freiburg als gegen Vigo, weil Vigo eigentlich schon, wie gesagt, eine sehr, sehr ordentliche Saison spielt und jetzt auch Tabellen 6 der nächstes Jahr wieder. Europa League spielt mit einem Budget, das eigentlich eher so Mittelfeld, wenn überhaupt, oder ein bisschen weiter runtergeht. Also, die bauen sich da was Gutes auf, haben, wie gesagt, einen jungen Trainer und haben ihm die Verantwortung gegeben und der macht einen richtig, richtig guten Job dort.
Und was können sich andere Teams von Celta, Vigo abgucken?
Ich finde vor allen Dingen, es ist sehr interessant, dass man halt auch– in Spanien ist es so, dass man inzwischen nicht nur junge Spieler in den Reserve-Teams aufbaut, sondern auch Trainer vor allen Dingen ausbildet. Und was ich in den letzten Jahren in Spanien mitbekommen habe, ist, dass diese jungen Trainer, auch wenn sie vielleicht mit der 2. Mannschaft jetzt nicht immer den Erfolg haben, dann doch in der 1. Mannschaft Erfolg haben, wenn sie eine Philosophie vorgeben, eine Spielphilosophie, die zum Verein passt und die dann vielleicht auch zu den Spielern passt, oder man sich eben die Spieler dort eben dann so hinzüchtet. Und da gibt es einige gute Geschichten in Spanien mit jungen Trainern, die dann eben diesen Schritt geschafft haben. Auch Xavi Alonso kam ja über die 2. Mannschaft von Real Sociedad damals in den Kontakt mit dem Profi-Fußball usw. Und das ist so ein Rezept, das im Moment sehr, sehr gut funktioniert. Kleiner Slideback zur 2. Liga beim FC Malaga. Dort hat man diesen Januar dem Trainer der 2. Mannschaft das Vertrauen ausgesprochen, weil man von seiner Philosophie überzeugt war. Und die waren letzter in der 4. oder 5. spanischen Liga. Und der hat den FC Malaga jetzt von Abstiegsringen bis in die Playoffs geführt. Also man muss diesen Mut auch mal haben, vielleicht diesen, ja, diesen Jungen vielleicht, ja auch eben gut ausgebildeten Trainer dann die Chance zu geben. Und sie zahlen es einem, nicht immer, aber in Spanien, immer öfter heim. Und das finde ich eine sehr, sehr spannende Entwicklung, weil die eben auch für einen frischen Fußball stehen und vor allen Dingen halt auch taktisch und technisch und von der Spielidee her eben weiter denken als vielleicht etablierte Trainer, die man immer wiederholt, wenn es irgendwo brennt, irgendwelche Feuerwehrmänner oder so weiter. Und da den Mut zu beweisen und dann eben auf die eigene Jugend zu setzen und auf den eigenen Jugendcoach und so weiter. Und dann vielleicht auch mal Rückschläge in Kauf nimmt und sagen, ne, wir wollen aber hier was aufbauen. Das ist eine Entscheidung oder das ist, ja, das ist eine Sache, die man in Spanien immer öfters sieht. Teilweise natürlich auch finanziell geschuldet bei einigen Clubs. Wollen wir nicht drumrum reden. Aber die jetzt zum Beispiel im Falle von Zelta Vega sehr, sehr gut funktioniert hat. Und da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, was die Entwicklung der kommenden Jahre anbelangt.
Also man muss so ehrlich sein, nach expected points wären sie auf Rang 12. Allerdings gibt es da ein extrem breites Mittelfeld an Teams, die sehr, sehr eng beieinander liegen. Das war letztlich das, was wir vorhin auch schon gesagt haben. Aber definitiv Zelta Vigo mit dem erneuten Europa League Einzug. Und sie waren ja auch die beste Offensive der Europa League, bis sie dann gegen Freiburg gespielt haben. Und da hat es dann nicht mehr so geklappt. Wirklich beeindruckende Saison. Aber dem stehen ja die anderen beiden, die du genannt hast, in nichts nach.
Also, Villarreal muss ich sagen, wirklich überragend und gleichzeitig kurios, denn der Trainer hat verkündet, dass er nächstes Jahr nicht mehr das Team trainieren möchte. Marcelinho, ein guter, alter Spanier– alt ist er ja noch gar nicht– aber einer der talentiertesten spanischen Trainer jetzt schon in den letzten Jahren und auch bei Villarreal schon öfter am Zug, hat aber sich mit der Vereinsriege nicht einigen können oder bzw. gehen dort die Erwartungen oder die Spiele auseinander und wird den Verein verlassen. Eine wirklich, muss ich sagen, sehr, sehr starke Saison, bei denen vor allen Dingen auch wieder mal die Offensive gezündet hat. Wer sehr, sehr gut funktioniert hat und den Jakob wahrscheinlich noch kennt, den georgischen Mittelstürmer Georges Mikatauze, wenn ich den jetzt richtig ausgesprochen habe, der wirklich top eingeschlagen hat, bester Torjäger war für Villarreal, die aber auch mit Nicolas Pepe, den kennt man noch von Arsenal, der war vielleicht früher ewiges Talent, der aber auch richtig aufblieb bei Villarreal, der ist glaube ich schon in dem zweiten oder dritten Jahr jetzt hier. Top-Assist-Geber, auch immer gefährlich. Sie haben mit Alberto Molero von Las Palmas einen richtig starken 22-jährigen offensiven Mittelfeldspieler geholt, der auch mit seinen Toren beteiligt war dieses Jahr. Und ja, die haben wirklich, also vor allen Dingen vorne, einen richtig, richtig starken Kader sich inzwischen zusammengeschustert. Und ich bin gespannt, was da jetzt passiert. Erstens natürlich auf dem Trainerstuhl und zweitens natürlich dann auch, was Neuverpflichtungen anbelangt. Vierreal hat ja einen finanziell starken Background. Da ist der Miteigentümer einer der größten Supermarktketten hier in Spanien. Und das ist ja eigentlich ein relativ kleines Kaff, aber die sind es finanziell zumindest immer so ausgestattet, dass es eigentlich für die Champions League weichen sollte. Und wie gesagt, dieses Jahr sind sie an Atletico Madrid vorbeigezogen. Und das war auf jeden Fall, würde ich sagen, äußerst beachtlich. Und dann haben wir noch meine Freunde von Betis Sevilla, für die es mich besonders freut. Spanischer Traditionsclub, Fünfter geworden. Jetzt wegen der Champions League Saison. Dann reicht dieser fünfte Platz, um dass sie nächstes Jahr dabei sind. Da sind alte Bekannte dabei, wie Manuel Pellegrini, der Trainer, den wir alle ja noch kennen. Da spielt immer noch Isco mit 34 ein Zauberfüßchen, der nach wie vor Spaß macht. Und ja, haben ein neues Stadion, bzw. bauen sich gerade ein neues Stadion. Das, glaube ich, wird dann auch nächstes Jahr so fertig. Und ja, finde ich einfach, freut mich persönlich sehr, weil ich den Verein sehr, sehr mag. Die Trainer sowieso, der auch bei Malaga ja eben große Erfolge feiert hat. Isco, wie gesagt, macht sehr, sehr viel Spaß. Sie haben sich mit Chucho Hernández, einen Mittelstürmer geleistet am Anfang der Saison, der jetzt mit 11 Toren auch dazu beigetragen hat. Haben aber auch in der Offensive wirklich ordentliche Optionen. Anthony kam ja von Man United dann fix. Das haben sie irgendwie hinbekommen, der nach wie vor absolut performt. Und ja, das sind auf jeden Fall, bevor das große Gefälle in La Liga kommt, diese drei Teams muss man hervorhaben. Die haben wirklich ihren Job richtig, richtig gut gemacht.
Stimmt, Anthony spielt da ja auch. Das habe ich gerade verdrängt.
Kann ja nicht alles positiv sein bei Führung.
Ja, leider offenbar nicht. Stimmt, stimmt. Ja, das habe ich wirklich einfach. Ist mir wieder entfallen, aber natürlich davon abgesehen von den Dingen, was man jetzt von ihm persönlich hält, eine wirklich erfolgreiche Saison. Ich glaube, auch die anderen Teams, die in der Champions-League spielen, die können sich freuen, gegen Betis zu spielen. Weil es ist eben halt was Besonderes, bei diesen Vereinen anzutreten, gerade auswärts. Egal, wie das dann sportlich läuft. Das ist dann vielleicht auch nicht das Wichtigste. Aber es ist doch schön, dass wir so negativ über La Liga eingestiegen sind und dann gleich drei Positivgeschichten haben, Fabian. Du musst mal den Blick lösen von den großen Dreien.
Ja, ja, das war der ganze Liga-Überblick. Aber ich bin tatsächlich sehr happy, wer sich jetzt auch europäisch qualifiziert hat. Das sind wirklich Vereine, die eine tolle Fan-Kultur mitbringen und die in Europa mit Sicherheit das ein oder andere Ausrufezeichen setzen werden. Gute Auswärtsreisen. Wenn hier Fans von anderen Teams herkommen, ist immer Party-Stimmung in der Stadt. Hier wird ja Fußball zelebriert. Und zwar nicht nur auf dem Platz, sondern auch neben dem Platz. Und deswegen freut es mich wirklich sehr. Und dann natürlich auch mit den Aufsteigern, die ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe. Ich blicke dann doch positiver in die neue Saison, was zumindest diese ganze Fan-Kultur anbelangt, was sich La Liga dann wieder einfallen lässt, wann die Spiele stattfinden und wie auch immer, und was die Tickets kosten. Lassen wir mal auf einem anderen Platz stehen. Aber nach zwei Saisons, wo wir jetzt wirklich das Gefühl hatten, es geht eher runter, bin ich jetzt leicht optimistisch, was das nächste Jahr anbelangt.
Und unfassbar, dass Pellegrini schon 311 Spiele als Trainer an der Seite bei Bethesd stand. Also gefühlt war der doch vorgestern bei Manchester City, aber ich lese gerade, das war ja 2013, 14 bis 15, 16.
Bei City lange, bei Vier Real auch lange gewesen, bei Malaga davor auch ein paar Jahre. Also Pellegrini, muss man schon sagen, der setzt sich hier das ein oder andere Denkmal. In Malaga hat er schon eins, in Sevilla wird er auch eins bekommen in Vier Real.
Und Christian hat schon Bock geholt.
Ist auch bei Milan gefallener Name, keine Sorge, Cardinale wird den schon auch angerufen haben.
Aber der ist doch, der ist doch, ist der nicht irgendwie 72?
72, ja genau.
Ja, ja, der ist schon, eigentlich ist er schon drüber, aber also Ergebnis stimmt.
Also du hast vorhin bei Marcelino, hast du gesagt, der ist ja noch ein junger Trainer und dann dachte ich mir so, Moment, hab nachgeguckt, er ist 60 Jahre. Also offenbar ist er auch ein bisschen schön.
Aber der sieht so jung aus, deswegen nach wie vor. Der hat immer noch dieses jungen Gesicht und deswegen.
Aber der ist auch, glaube ich, Marcelino ist doch auch Quartrainer geworden, oder? Das ist doch auch schon die zweite Amtszeit, wenn es überhaupt reicht bei VRL.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn es überhaupt reicht, hast du recht, ja, der ist dann öfter, der ist auch ein sehr spezieller Charakter und der sagt halt auch mal nein, wenn es ihm nicht passt und dann zieht er auch Konsequenzen.
Sieht man ja jetzt.
Das hat er jetzt mal wieder gemacht, genau.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich…
Hey, 60 Max, mach mich nicht fertig.
Was soll ich denn?
James Miller hat aufgehört, wir werden halt alle alt. Also es ist halt so.
So ist es. Und wenn ihr mal wirklich, wirklich traurig werden wollt, dann guckt euch die Doku an, die es jetzt gibt zum WM-Titel 1990. Ich habe sie noch nicht gesehen, aber ich habe Ausschnitte gesehen und mich mit Leuten unterhalten, die sie gesehen haben. Und dann vergleicht einfach, wie alle Spieler aussehen, wie alle Spieler interviewt werden und setzt da Kalle Riedle daneben. Und ihr werdet den Glauben an Alterungsprozesse verlieren. Oder vielleicht hat er irgendwie ein Bild von sich im Keller hängen, das ganz fürchterlich aussieht. Wobei eigentlich war es ja gar nicht im Keller, es war ja auf dem Dachboden. Das Bild ist des Dorian Gray. Warum spricht man da eigentlich immer vom Keller? Naja, das ist jetzt was anderes. Bevor es jetzt zum Literaturpodcast wird, schauen wir nochmal in die Liga. Jakob, was hast du uns denn mitgebracht? Welche 70-jährige junge Trainerlegende steht da am Seitenrand?
Ich wollte tatsächlich später auch nochmal kurz über Trainer sprechen, aber ich habe jetzt erstmal nochmal eine der nicht so schönen Stories oder so einen nicht so schönen, überspannenden Geschichtsbogen aus Frankreich mitgebracht. Denn wir hatten es ja in dem Segment vorher schon angesprochen. Es gibt viele Vereine, die so auch in sich bestehend viele Kämpfe auszutragen haben und wir reißen es ja auch eigentlich in jeder Folge mindestens einmal an, dass es da in Frankreich ja ganz besonders um das Multi-Club-Ownership-Konstrukt geht und das wird auch nicht weniger. Man hat ja sowieso kaum noch Vereine, die nicht innerhalb eines solchen MCOs sind. Jetzt sind mit Nont und MES auch noch zwei Teams abgestiegen, die keine Multi-Club-Ownership-Teams sind. Dafür sind zwei neue Multi-Club-Ownership-Teams hochgekommen aus der Ligue 2 mit Le Mans, die man ja– was man wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen mitbekommen hat zumindest. Also gab es zumindest jetzt vor ein paar Tagen auch einen Artikel bei The Athletic drüber, weil die ja relativ prominente Eigentümer haben, mit Djokovic, Courtois, dann den beiden VOR-M1-Fahrern, Philippe Massa, Kevin Magnussen und die so ein bisschen Wrexham bzw. Como sich als Vorbild genommen haben. Also so ein prominenter Standort, vielleicht nicht unbedingt wegen Fußball, den gleich Le Mans auch vor ein paar Jahrzehnten mal in der Ligue 1 war, also jetzt auch nicht ein komplett traditionsloser Verein ist, den aber auch gleichzeitig mit Curitiba, ein Team in Brasilien gehört. Also es ist eigentlich auch eine Investorengruppe mit Ursprüngen in Brasilien, daher auch die Verbindung zu Philippe Massa beispielsweise. Und die sehen das auch bisher, zumindest haben sie das öffentlich so kommuniziert, nicht als richtiges MCO-Projekt, sondern eher so als Partnerschaft. Mal schauen, wie das dann wird, ob dann nicht doch irgendwie, wenn man sieht, okay, bei Le Mans läuft es jetzt ganz gut, ob dann nicht doch plötzlich ganz viele brasilianische Talente rüberkommen. Zumindest ist es aber, wenn man es jetzt aus rein französischer Sicht betrachtet, kein Multiclub-Unership-Konstrukt, wo der französische Club in der Zuliefererrolle ist, was ja ein viel größeres Problem ist. Zum Beispiel auch beim zweiten Aufsteiger bei Troyes, die ja zur City Football Group gehören, von denen ja auch vor einem Abstieg viel Protest aus der Fangruppe, weil man das Gefühl hatte, es ist der City Football Group eigentlich relativ egal, was da geschieht. Also zum Beispiel wurde da ja auch so ein Savino mal durchgeschleust. Es ist Troyes Rekordzugang immer noch, ohne jemals für die gespielt zu haben. Und genau, also die sind jetzt zwar wieder oben, allerdings da auch nicht so ganz glücklich. Aber die beiden Paradebeispiele in der Ligue 1 bleiben natürlich Straßburg und Nizza. Bei Straßburg haben wir ja zur Genüge darüber gesprochen, auch über die ganzen Transfers. Einerseits von Spielern zu Chelsea, dann das im Winter ja mit Liam Mourissigneaux, auch der Trainer weggenommen wurde. Es war jetzt unter Gary O'Neill gar nicht unbedingt so viel schlechter sportlich. Und gerade die Pokalsaisons bei Straßburg, also sowohl in der Coupe de France, wo sie ja bis ins Halbfinale gekommen sind, als auch die Conference League, wo sie ja auch im Halbfinale erst ausgeschieden sind, unter anderem ja Mainz, dann im Viertelfinale rausgenommen haben, auch mit einem richtig schönen Spiel im Rückspiel. Also im Hinspiel wurden sie ja phasenweise überrannt von Mainz. Im Rückspiel war es dann wirklich andersrum. Das hätten sie auch 7-0 oder so gewinnen können. Und das macht das Ganze, dass es so ein bisschen ambivalent auch ist, das Verhältnis von den Fans weiterhin zur Blue-Co-Group. Also es gibt ja schon seit Beginn der Saison und auch schon vorher viele Proteste. Gab ja jetzt auch vor ein paar Wochen eine gemeinsame Demonstration von Chelsea und von Straßburg-Fans gegen die Eigentümergruppe. Aber in Straßburg gibt es halt auch Fans, die sagen, okay, trotzdem geht es uns ja besser, als es lange Zeit war. Denn Straßburg war vor gut zehn Jahren auch insolvent, war dann in der vierten Liga teilweise, ist jetzt also auch sukzessive wieder hochgekommen, sodass dann der sportliche Erfolg noch, will ich mal sagen, über einiges auch so ein bisschen hinwegtäuscht oder zumindest einige Eigentümer vertröstet. Allerdings ist es jetzt halt so, dass man trotzdem ja durchaus mit den hohen Investitionen zum Saisonende eigentlich mit nichts so richtig dasteht. Denn man war jetzt zwar in zwei Halbfinalen, sowohl europäisch als auch national, aber man hat sich halt nicht über die Liga nochmal für Europa qualifiziert, sondern ist nur 8er geworden. Und dann bleibt halt eher so das Gefühl, okay, wir sind ja doch nur ein besseres U23-Team, weil das spiegelt die Mannschaft auch so ein bisschen auf dem Platz wieder. Man spielt halt phasenweise wirklich berauschenden Offensivfußball. Ich finde, dass es tatsächlich auch so europaweit, wenn Straßburg ins Laufen kommt, ist es mit das Schönste, was man sehen kann an Offensivfußball. Aber in entscheidenden Momenten fehlen dann halt logischerweise die erfahrenen Spieler oder die Säulen auf dem Platz. Und ich denke mal nicht unbedingt, dass das jetzt besser wird in der nächsten Saison oder in den nächsten Jahren, solange sich halt nichts ändert. Sodass das eins der beiden Negativbeispiele auf jeden Fall auch ist für diese Multiclub-Ownership-Teams.
Aber besteht Anlass zur Hoffnung, dass sich da dran irgendwas nochmal verändern wird? Wenn jetzt schon Chase und Strasbourg-Fans gemeinsam protestieren, wo sich wahrscheinlich dann die Owner denken, wie schön, dass wir jetzt auch schon gemeinsame Fan-Kultur hier leben. Die Familie, sie wächst zusammen.
Genau, also ich gehe mal nicht davon aus. Also ich glaube, wir haben bisher europaweit ja auch noch nie so eine richtige Strategie gesehen, wie man aus den Klauen von Eigentümern gut wieder rauskommen kann. Das Einzige ist dann ja immer das Hoffen, dass irgendein Besserer kommt. Aber gerade innerhalb dieser MCO-Konstrukte gibt es jetzt auch gar nicht unbedingt den Druck, dann ein Team loszuwerden. Also glaube ich jetzt nicht unbedingt, dass es so viel besser wird. Man kann natürlich sagen, ok, vielleicht vertröstet Bluko Strasburg so ein bisschen und baut den Kader ein bisschen um, dass man vielleicht innerhalb Frankreichs erfolgreicher wird. Dann hat man wieder das Argument, ja ok, der sportliche Erfolg vertröstet halt. Aber ich glaube so das Grundproblem, das wird man ja nicht wirklich los.
Und Nitza hast du vorhin kurz erwähnt, das muss man vielleicht noch sagen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die haben es in die Relegation geschafft. Und dagegen sah Etienne, also das ist ja auch so ein richtiger Arbeiterverein, da haben sie sich dann durchgesetzt mit 4 zu 1. Also sie konnten sich noch mal drin halten. Und Nitza, da hängt, das ist Jim Redcliffe, der dahinter steht.
Genau. Und das ist so ein bisschen das andere Beispiel. Da gibt es ja tatsächlich immer wieder Gerüchte, dass sie die eigentlich auch loswerden wollen. Also ich hatte das irgendwie auch oder ich weiß gar nicht, irgendwer hatte es, also es wurde auf jeden Fall auch schon thematisiert, dass ja Sir Jim Redcliffe auch häufig schon gesagt hat, dass ihm Nitza komplett egal sei, weil die eh keinen guten Fußball spielen und er sich deswegen auch die Spiele nicht anschauen würde.
Er ist einer von uns.
Genau und das ist ja auch so.
Ich habe mir Nitza Spiele auch nicht gerne angeguckt.
Nein, also es ist halt auch bei denen ist ja auch krass, die haben den viert oder fünft höchsten Etat der Liga, trotz dessen, dass sie eigentlich ja vernachlässigt werden von ihren Eigentümern sozusagen, waren letzte Saison ja auch noch vierte, also haben zu Saisonbeginn noch in der Champions League Quali gespielt, haben dann ja die grandios schlechte Europa League Saison gespielt, wo sie, glaube ich, die ersten sieben Spiele in der Liga-Phase alle verloren haben und da also dann auch ein ganz schlechtes Bild abgegeben haben. Dann gab es ja zu Jahresende den Angriff der Fans auf die eigenen Spieler und auch unter Claude Puel, also da haben sie auch so ein französisches, einen erfahrenen Trainer, will ich mal sagen, wieder auf die Trainerbank zurückgeholen. Ja, das stimmt. Und der konnte auch diesen Niedergang überhaupt nicht stoppen in der Liga. Also sie sind dann ja am letzten, am vorletzten Spieltag auf den Religationsplatz gerückt, hatten dann auch in der Relegation echt Glück. Also das Hinspiel war eins der schlimmsten Spiele aller Zeiten wirklich. Da gab es keinen einzigen Torschuss in dem ganzen Spiel von keinem der beiden Teams. Ich glaube, ein kombiniertes Expected-Goals-Wert von 0,4 oder so und im Rückspiel war das ja auch.
Sieben zu vier Schüsse, das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Ich hatte gehört, dass es nicht voll war.
Ja, kein einziger Schuss im Strafraum von sein. Okay, immerhin, Nizza hatte zwei Schüsse im Strafraum. Kein einziger aufs Tor. Um Gottes Willen. Ich hatte gelesen, dass es nicht besonders schön gewesen sein soll. Ich hatte Meme dazu gesehen. Aber ehrlich gesagt habe ich mir dabei, Nizza ging es ja nicht so viel erwartet. Deswegen bin ich da nicht hellhörig geworden. Krass. Okay.
Ja, und dann im Rückspiel ja auch bis zur 60. Minute oder so 0-0. Und dann hat Nizza es ja aber noch mit 4-1 gewonnen am Ende und ist jetzt so in der Liga geblieben. Was natürlich auch angesichts der Finanzen eine absolute Katastrophe gewesen wäre. Man musste ja sogar das Rückspiel vor leeren Rängen, also im eigenen Stadion, aber vor leeren Rängen absolvieren, weil es ja am 34. Spieltag nach Abpfiff einen Platzsturm gab aufgrund der Frustration der Anhänger. Aus Frankreich habe ich auch so gehört, dass es vielleicht für Nizza sogar eher ein Vorteil war, dass man so ein Geisterspiel hatte, weil die Atmosphäre so toxisch ist teilweise im Stadion, dass da die Unterstützung gar nicht unbedingt hilft. Und ja, gerade Sontetien auch eine sehr, sehr große Fanszene hat, die auch sehr unterstützungskräftig ist. Und ja, also bei Nizza ist jetzt halt die Frage, ob vielleicht der Verein irgendwann verkauft wird. Man kann es für die Nizza-Fans auf jeden Fall nur hoffen, denn jetzt auch für die Zukunft sieht es nicht so richtig gut aus. Also ich glaube, Claude Puel ist jetzt auch nicht so die Dauerlösung auf der Bank. Man hat natürlich eigentlich schon die finanziellen Mittel, nicht weiter gegen den Abstieg kämpfen zu müssen, aber vor der Saison halt auch scheußliche Transfers getätigt. Also einige Spieler haben überhaupt nicht eingeschlagen. Kevin Carlos kam so als Sturmhoffnung. Der hat in der Liga kein einziges Tor geschossen, obwohl er relativ viel gespielt hat. Und ja, es ist schon ziemlich übel mit anzusehen, gerade dann halt auch mit dieser Spaltung innerhalb oder zu den Fans zwischen Eigentümer- schaft und Fans.
Ach, ach, ach, was soll man sagen? Oh Gott, ey, dieses Hinspiel. Es gab insgesamt 19 Ballkontakte in den jeweiligen Strafräumen. 7 hatte Netzer und 12 hatte Sajedjan. Oh Gott, Herr Zwillen. Naja, gut, wir mussten es ja nicht sehen. Du hast es wahrscheinlich gesehen, Jakob, im Nachhinein. Beileid dafür. Aber gut.
Ja, 0,08 Expected Goals aus dem Spiel heraus.
Für beide kumulierend.
Ja, insgesamt.
Das ist einfach ganz fantastisch. Relegation einfach immer die besten Spiele. Man soll es, ja, Relegation abschaffen. Aber da sind wir uns ja eh alle einig.
Aufstiegsrelegation, die ist gut. In England ist immer alles tiptop. Also das sind die schönsten Spiele. EFL, Ligue 2, Ligue 1, Champions League. Das ist die Werbung dafür, dass man es so machen muss.
Aber wie sind die letzten Spieltage davor? Also wie sind die Spieltage davor, wenn quasi jemand weiß, ich lande unter den ersten, also Platz 3 bis wohin auch immer es geht? Da bin ich jetzt schon sicher drin. Schonen die dann ihre Spieler? Lassen die dann austrudeln?
Das ist nicht ganz so leicht zu sagen, weil die ja sowieso Mittwoch, Sonntag spielen oder Dienstag, Samstag spielen. Das heißt, da ist sowieso mehr Rotation drin als sowieso. Aber klar, je weiter du runtergehst, League 2 und League 1, da ist halt vor allen Dingen die Verletzungsmisere dann auch da. Weil das einfach in den Phasen gar nicht so zu lösen ist. Also das ist jetzt anekdotisch, was weiß ich, ob das so ist. Das müsste man datentechnisch überprüfen. Aber von dem, was ich wahrnehme und ich steige ja dann insbesondere auch in 3. und 4. Liga dann immer relativ spät zu. Weil ich so viel Zeit habe ich dann auch nicht, dass ich mir dann die kompletten 46 Spieltage aus der 2., 3. und 4. Liga auch noch reintue. Aber wenn ich zusteige, dann sind die Schlüsselspieler einfach immer gerade mit so verletzten Erwütungserscheinungen sozusagen draußen. Oder man sieht ihnen zumindest an, dass da ganz offensichtlich nicht die totale Frische herrscht.
In der Serie B kann ich das auch bestätigen. In der Serie B in Italien, 2. Liga, gibt es auch die Aufstiegsrelegation, die war auch letztes Jahr schon dieses Jahr auch wieder mega aufregend. Also da ist echt viel Bewegung drin. Vielleicht auch, Max, vielleicht eine Antwort auf dich. Es geht ja– jetzt kann man darüber streiten, ob das sinnvoll ist, aber du bist halt bis zum Schluss auch als 8. oder 9. noch potenziell in der Verlösung. Oder als 10. oder 11. Also in der Serie B, die ist eh so wahnsinnig eng. Da bist du oft noch als 12., da hast du zwei Spieltage vor Schluss. Hast du die Chance, oben rein zu rutschen in die Aufstiegs-Playoffs oder noch unten rein zu rutschen in die Playdowns sozusagen. Nochmal, ob das jetzt sinnvoll ist, steht auf dem anderen Platt Papier, aber es ist schon von der Spannung her und dann auch die Spiele selbst in der Serie B geht in die Richtung wie für die Eigenschaft.
Und das schreibe ich in Spanien übrigens auch. Also da ist auch jetzt Aufstiegsrelegation und da ist nochmal richtig Feuer im Kettel.
Das ist auch in Spanien auch immer echt cool.
Das ist richtig, richtig cool. Platz 3 bis 6 spielen dann nochmal den letzten Platz aus.
Genau, wie in Italien zwänglich.
Und du hast recht, wie du gesagt hast, Christian, da kann halt auch der 8. oder 9. Shield vielleicht nochmal nach oben und unten geht es auch.
Und traditionell die Formstärkeren rutschen auch nochmal mit rein, die vielleicht jetzt keine gute Saison gespielt haben, aber in den letzten paar Wochen. Und dann gibt es so eine schöne Mischung, finde ich, dass da manchmal Teams drin sind.
So ein bisschen Play-off-Feeling, wie halt aus Nordamerika.
Ist es dann aber ein neutraler Ort und Einspiel oder im eigenen und im Stadion des Gegners Hin- und Rückspiel?
In Italien ist es Hin- und Rückspiel und bei Torgleichheit geht da besser Platzierte weiter. Also wenn du als dritter 2-0 das Hinspiel gewinnst, dann reicht dir auch im Rückspiel eine 2-0-Niederlage. Weil sozusagen das schlechter Postierte muss mehr sozusagen leisten, um weiter zu sparen.
In England gibt es Wembley-Wochenende, dann Finale. Das ist noch besser, weil dann gibt es halt nur noch ein Spiel. Ja, das ist geil.
Ja, und das Schöne ist halt, dass du da halt 30.000 hier, 30.000 da hast. Und wenn dann irgendwie noch in der, was war es, 97. Minute das entscheidende Tor fällt für Hall, wenn ich mich jetzt gerade nicht komplett erinnere. Dann ja, okay, Ausstiegsrelegation. Ich meine, ich muss sagen, es hat schon auch seinen Reiz. Also die letzten Spieltage in der 2. Liga der Männer in der Bundesliga. Das ist halt auch einfach, das ist halt auch Mayhem. Und ich liebe das, dass das ist. Und ich mag auch, dass es dann vorbei ist. Also dann 17.23 Uhr oder sowas. Letzter Abpfiff. Und dann weißt du, okay, jetzt arbeiten wir das alle noch mal auf und gehen jetzt alle erst mal drei Tage in die Eistonne. Aber ja, vielleicht sind das auch einfach andere Playoffs, weil das, also was halt jetzt bei den Abstiegs-Playoffs halt auch so hemmend ist. Also zum einen sind es keine guten Fußballspiele ganz oft. Und zum anderen ist auch wahnsinnig viel Aggressivität mit dabei. Ganz, ganz viel, was eben eskalieren kann. Und das scheint mir ja bei so einer Aufstiegsrelegation, wo man vielleicht dann ja sogar eher noch reingerutscht ist, in den letzten Spieltagen anders zu sein.
Da kannst du nur gewinnen versus du… Also nicht nur gewinnen, du kannst schon auch viel Geld verlieren. Also die Aufstiegsrelegation mit Southampton ist ja nochmal ein ganz eigenes Thema gewesen in England, mit dem Spygate jetzt, nach dem originalen Bielsa Spygate.
Also muss man ganz kurz sagen, da hat ein Mitarbeiter, wohl auch mit Wissen und auf Anweisung des Trainers, das Training der Gegner ausspioniert, wurde dabei fotografiert.
Mehrere Trainings sogar.
Genau mehrere. Und er wurde aber fotografiert. Bei einem stand da auch nicht so wahnsinnig auffällig hinter einem Baum. Unauffällig, würde ich jetzt mal sagen. Naja, und deswegen wurden sie aus dem Finalspiel abgezogen. Drei Tage vorher, oder was das war. Also das ist und Mittelsboro ist nachgerückt.
Genau.
Ja, genau.
Die sind auch im Training geblieben, das heißt, die haben schon drauf spekuliert. Aber das ist schon, also auch in der Strafhöhe, nenne ich es jetzt mal, beispiellos. Also weil nicht nur da extrem viel Geld flöten geht im Zweifel. Und ich bin mir eigentlich einigermaßen sicher, dass Southampton das geholt hätte. Weil die waren jetzt in den letzten drei Monaten das mit Abstand stärkste Team der Liga. Und da gibt es viel um Geld. Sonder Eker hat das den Job los, so gut wie. Also noch ist nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber alle gehen davon aus, der wird entlassen. Und das bedeutet natürlich, dass das dann in England erst mal für ihn nicht weitergeht. Dann muss es halt in Deutschland jemanden geben, der vielleicht sagt, okay, mit der Vertragsklausel bitte nicht spionieren lassen.
Man muss dazu sagen, das ist ein deutscher Trainer, 33 Jahre alt, also der ist quasi ein Baby im Maßstab von Fabian. Eigentlich Wahnsinn, dass er überhaupt sitzt im Hochstuhl wahrscheinlich. War mal U17-Trainer bei Bayern, dann ist er zu Barnsley und über Genua ist er dann irgendwann bei Southampton. Dann ist er gelandet, aber jetzt habe ich gelesen, dass es auch bei vergangenen Stationen durchaus schon mal Berichte da hingeben.
Ja, ich habe, also ich, I don't know, ich habe mal in Deutschland und meinem Bruder vor allen Dingen auch mal nachgefragt bei einzelnen Trainern. Da gab es ja auch diverse Dinge, dass der mal den ausspioniert hat und so weiter. Und jeder Trainer hat mir gesagt, ja klar, also entschuldige mal, aber selbstverständlich nutzen wir alles, was uns irgendwie hilft. Also wir müssen uns ja nichts vormachen. Jedes Medium, das etwas auf sich hält oder nicht auf sich hält, hat Leute hinter dem Baum auf… also ich bin auch im Praktikum, hat mir auch mal jemand gesagt, geh mal auf den Baum. Da habe ich dann gesagt, das mache ich sehr ungern, weil nein.
An der Säbener oder was? Saß du da oben in den Bäumen an diesem…
Nee, war nicht Säbener, aber genau, ja genau. Aber das ist mir auch erzählt worden von einem erfahrenen Kollegen dann, dass dann da jemand auf den Baum steigt. Und die Trainer sagen auch alle, du ganz ehrlich, es geht um so unfassbar viel und jeden kleinen Vorteil, den ich haben kann, den nutze ich. Wir treiben das jetzt nicht auf die Spitze und kleben jemanden einen Bart an und schleusen den vier Monate lang ein, um dann vielleicht im finalen Spiel von innen heraus den Verein zu zersetzen. Aber ja, dann gehen wir halt mit einem Fernglas da hin und schauen uns das an. Das ist wohl normal und das ist auch an den Ausbildungsstellen, an denen jetzt Tonda Eckhardt gewesen ist, wohl auch so gelehrt worden.
Auch bei Leipzig will ich es nur dazu sagen. Also kommen wir aus diesem Tree quasi. Jakob will was sagen.
Noch kurz zu diesen Verkleidungen. Also bei Tonda Eckhardt gab es doch aber sogar, dass sie bei dem einen Spiel auch den Spion als Fan verkleidet hatten, weil sie da auf einem anderen Trainingsgelände trainiert haben. Bei Eastlay war es glaube ich. Und der hatte dann ein Trikot von denen angezogen.
In der deutschen zweiten Liga war das auch so ähnlich. Ich bin jetzt nicht sicher, ob es in der Saison war. Vielleicht lasse ich es jetzt verschwimmen. Aber in der deutschen zweiten Liga gab es die Diskussion auch in einem Spiel. Das hat mein Bruder nämlich gemacht und hat mir das dann erzählt. Und hat dann auch gesagt, so etwas überrascht. Wow, das scheint einfach normal zu sein, weil selbst der gegnerische Trainer dann sagt, ja. Und?
So war das nicht. Lautern gegen Darmstadt mit Lieberknecht, der sich dann geäußert hat? Oder bin ich da gerade?
Nee, das glaube ich war es nicht. Vielleicht mag jetzt auch mein Fehler sein. Vielleicht tue ich es auch jetzt in die Saison. Das war in der letzten. Jedenfalls nicht so lange her. Seitdem habe ich das immer wieder genutzt, wenn sich das ergeben hat, um nachzufragen. Mein Bruder eben auch. Speziell in der 2. Liga und hat immer mal nachgefragt, wie wird das gehandhabt. Da sind aber auch die gegnerischen Trainer jeweils gar nicht sauer drüber. Ich habe das auch nicht so wahrgenommen, als würde jetzt sich großartig jemand in England von den Gegnern aufgeführt haben, sondern das war dann eher so ein, oh, da ist die Chance. Also finden wir es jetzt alle katastrophal.
Also es war laut an gegen den KSC und es gab das Gerücht, dass bei den Co-Traineren es einen Anruf gegeben hätte, hier wollt ihr wissen, wie wir spielen. Und dann hat lieber Knecht das outgekoert und hat gesagt, das findet er asozial und der KSC hat es aber dann dementiert, dass das eben nicht so gewesen sei. Also ein bisschen wilde Nummer. Es führt letztlich dazu, warum trainiert der FC Bayern, immer wenn es drauf ankommt, bei zugezogenen Gardinen, die damals Pep Guardiola hat installieren lassen, weil Uli Hebel im Baum saß und von oben, vom öffentlichen Grund, reingucken konnte, aus Trainingsgelände. Genau aus diesem Grund. Und das ist halt, finde ich, ist dann halt das Traurige, was halt ein Nebenprodukt dessen dann ist. Du kannst im Grunde kaum noch bei einer vernünftigen Trainingsanheit zugucken, anders als früher. Auch, weil eben so etwas passiert und natürlich auch bei Medien dann da sind. Also bei Bayern siehst du immer, es gibt einen Fotografen von einem Boulevard-Medium. Ich bin da ja viele Jahre lang fast täglich dran vorbeigelaufen, am Trainingsgelände. Und ich habe schon von Weitem gesehen, wenn er da war, wusste ich, also die Profis sind auf jeden Fall gerade da und wahrscheinlich trainieren sie bald. Weil er dann eben, wenn er noch auf die Fenster oben gehalten hat, dann war irgendein Höhenes-Thema gerade irgendwie wichtig und sie haben versucht irgendwie zu sehen, wie da irgendwie die Schatten miteinander reden, genau. Und wenn er auf dem Platz gehalten hat, dann wusstest du, ah, die trainieren jetzt gerade oder sie trainieren gleich. Aber eben ganz oft hinter dem zugezogenen Vorhang dann.
Ich würde schon sagen, dass das aber auch für absolute Spitzenclubs eher die Ausnahme ist, weil aus Italien kann ich euch sagen, du kannst mal probieren, in Milanello oder Vinovo oder Trigoria in Rom überhaupt reinzukommen.
Überhaupt reinzukommen.
Keine Chance.
Eine gated community.
Absolut, genau. Also klar, die haben dann immer wieder mal so punktuell öffentliche Trainings, wo sie die Leute reinlassen. Aber ich würde mal vermuten, dass das bei Bayern schon lange sehr luxuriös war, dass da irgendwie jeder reinschauen konnte. Also in Italien ist das seit Jahrzehnten unvorstellbar.
Ja, und auf der anderen Seite ist es aber doch auch so, also was ist denn hier eigentlich der Punkt? Also bis auf Standardvarianten und spielt der angeschlagene Spieler, war da irgendwie im Abschlusstraining, hatte er ein Leibchen an oder nicht, in welchem der beiden Teams war er, ist es doch eigentlich auch, also da wird doch auch so getan, als ob man da irgendwelche Geheimnisse erfährt. Jetzt sind sie so stolz darauf, dass sie alle scouten, dass sie sich 13 Spiele von jedem Gegner angucken, stehen da mit ihren 1000 Standardvarianten, die sie ihren Einwechsespielern sagen. Also ein bisschen viel Boi wird doch da auch drum gemacht, um so eine Trainingseinheit, oder? Also ihr habt doch auch schon welche gesehen. Und man denkt so, man kriegt so einen Eindruck davon, wie ticken die so als Gruppe und wie viel wird rumgebrüllt. Denn es wird immer viel rumgebrüllt. Trainings sind sehr laut im Männerfußball. Aber du siehst so, okay, ist ja interessant zu sehen, da ist ausgerechnet der so viel bröte, der sitzt doch immer nur auf der Satzbank. Aber ansonsten so krass viele Erkenntnisse hat man doch daraus auch nicht.
Deswegen finde ich die Strafe schon enorm. Klar, da steckt eine Energie dahinter, weil es über mehrere Male, das war kein Impuls zu sagen, okay, da sitzt das Halbfinale, da gehen wir jetzt mal Gas. Sondern es scheint schon über Wochen hinweg gewesen zu sein und punktuell immer mal wieder. Aber ja, ich stelle es auch immer wieder fest. Ich habe ja manchmal das Privileg, mit einem Trainer dann telefonieren zu dürfen vor dem Spiel. Und die sind manchmal, also gar nicht mal so sehr dann komischerweise in der Bundesliga, sondern je weiter du runtergehst, ist das fast schon das Beschützen der Aufstellung. Nicht, dass der Gegner einen Mini-Vorteil hat, weil es einfach um so viel geht. Das ist einfach dann am Ende auch die Wahrnehmung. Innen, der Druck ist einfach so krass. Und es ist potentiell so, dass Thunder Eckert, der ja de facto ein Unbekannter in Southampton, als der den Job bekommen hat, haben alle– Mir ging es auch so, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den kanntet, aber ich dachte mir, wer soll das sein?
Er war ja auch Interimstrainer und ist so dann da gelandet.
Genau. Ich kannte, ich hatte den Namen vorher nie, auch nur ansatzweise vernommen. Und dann wird der Chef-Trainer und es ging gut los und dann habe ich mich halt so ein bisschen beschäftigt damit und dann jetzt hinten raus etwas mehr. Und der gilt und galt als der absolut kommende Mann, weil alle gesagt haben, das ist unfassbar, wie der mit dem Kader das Ding aufgerollt hat, nachdem ja Will Still vorher da war, der vorher als der nächste Mann galt.
Der Football-Manager-Trainer war das doch, oder?
Ganz genau, ganz genau. Und Tondar Eckert ist potenziell jetzt als Trainer todesverbrannt. Also in England überlegen sie sich das zehnmal. Der Dragan Schollack, der Besitzer da, der lässt kein gutes Wort mehr auf den Kommen, weil er sagt, du hast meinem Verein Dermat beschmutzt und du hast uns die größte Chance– also er hat es ihnen auch gegeben, aber das würde er dann gerne mal vergessen– aber die größte Chance dann letztlich auch genommen. Und deswegen finde ich die Strafe extrem, muss ich sagen. Also ich hätte damit gut leben können, hätten sie gesagt, ich kriege keine Ahnung, drei Punkte Abzug, was ja auch für einen Aufsteiger schon hyper fies gewesen wäre in der Premier League. Und ihr müsst halt von den Geldern, die ihr jetzt bekommt, so und so viel als Strafe zurückgeben, wäre ja ebenfalls ein heftiger Schlag gewesen. Also was weiß ich, ich bin nicht juristisch dabei gewesen und kenne jetzt nicht die Aufsetzung dieser Strafe. Und nachdem das mit Bielsa damals ja seinerzeit war, hat man auch wohl kommuniziert sehr deutlich, dass sie das nicht durchgehen lassen werden oder wollen innerhalb der Ligen. Ich finde es trotzdem beispiellos hart. Also das ist das Heftigste, was ich seit langer Zeit erlebt habe, an Strafe, muss ich sagen.
Ja, ich vermute, dass da einfach auch aus Ligaseite die Gefahr sehr, sehr groß ist, dass du von anderen dann wiederum verklagt wirst. Also ich habe nur Teile der Begründung quasi gelesen, wo ja auch eben dann herausgearbeitet wurde, dass es auch SMS oder sonstige Nachrichten gegeben haben soll. Du hast schon gesehen, wie tief die in die Investigation eigentlich reingegangen sind, um diese Strafe zu treffen. Und das, was ich bisher immer so gehört habe von Ligen-Vertretern, im weitesten Sinne, wenn du mit ihnen über sowas sprichst, dass die dann eigentlich solche Entscheidungen und solche Fälle nur mit dem Blick darauf, was können wir jetzt tun, dass wir nicht von allen verklagt werden? Weil wir haben dafür weder die Zeit noch die Ressourcen und das würde uns extrem schaden. Vielleicht kamen sie dann auch so dazu.
Stimmt. Wie sicher hätte Middlesbrough und wie sie alle heißen, vermutlich dann auch Hull, hätten sie es nicht geschafft. Kann schon sein, dass ich da eine Sammelklage gefunden hätte, weil da geht es ja um ein paar Mark 50.
Eben, genau. Jakob, du wolltest noch was sagen.
Es ist ja auch wahnsinnig schwer, eine perfekte Lösung zu finden, weil theoretisch gerade dadurch, dass Southampton ja auch in der Liga spioniert hat, könnte sich ja auch Wrexham, die die Playoffs knapp verpasst haben, eigentlich noch beklagen. Aber was, glaube ich, bei dieser Strafe so merkwürdig erscheint, dass es halt so völlig relationslos dazu steht, dass man halt diese Strafen wegen der Finanzvergehen der großen Clubs in England, dass man da so ewig drauf wartet und man dann auch immer das Gefühl hat, dass die Vereine halt gar nicht richtig treffen.
Ja, wobei, das würde ich nicht sagen. Also wir haben auch vor zwei Jahren, glaube ich, war das oder? Über Everton und Nottingham gesprochen. Da haben sie auch hingelangt. Also das City-Ding steht halt aus und ich weiß nicht, inwiefern man…
Ja, aber auch das mit Chelsea, finde ich, was jetzt in den letzten Monaten hochgekommen war, wo man dann mitkriegt, ja, okay, sie haben zwar eigentlich nur irgendwie Leuten Geld zugeschoben, aber dadurch dann halt irgendwie auch drei Spieler gehabt, die sie sonst vielleicht nicht hätten haben können. Und da ist der Vorteil dann sicherlich viel größer, als da irgendeinen Scout an das Trainingsgelände zu schicken.
Man kann halt immer sagen, und das passiert ja auch ständig, in den Aussagen der Presse stellen dann der jeweiligen Gremien, ja, das kann man nicht miteinander vergleichen, das ist ja Juristerei, ja cool. Also ich check's halt dann auch am Ende nicht. Das muss ich halt auch fairerweise dazu sagen. Genau, da gibt's ja gar keine klare Linie. Okay, wo ist der Alex Trullka, wenn man ihn mal braucht?
Aber wirklich, ja, der muss ja seinen eigenen Rückblick aufnehmen. Ah ja, muss jeder wissen, wie er das macht. Uli, du musst gleich los, deswegen gebe ich dir mal noch die Chance, ich nehme an, du wolltest gar nicht über das Aufnehmen sprechen, wir sind da ja so ein bisschen falsch abgebogen. Welche Themen willst du uns hier noch präsentieren, bevor du dich gleich verabschiedest? Können es auch kürzere sein, wenn du magst.
Ja, ich muss mal überlegen, was muss man noch gewusst haben von der Saison? Also ich glaube, um zwei negative Themen oder eins vor allen Dingen zu nennen, ist glaube ich ein Thema, das wir hier aber auch schon mal hatten, auch vor gar nicht allzu langer Zeit und was ja auch an Straßburg im Endeffekt anknüpft, ist der FC Chelsea mit einem für Blue-Cow-Verhältnisse katastrophalen Finish, Platz 10 am Ende nur, natürlich nicht europäisch gespielt, zwar in der Champions League sich so weit ordentlich verkauft gegen Paris, dann am Ende... Da ist es passiert, aus meiner Sicht. Da ist es einmal in die... Es ist sozusagen der Bruch gekommen in der Saison und ab dann waren sie einfach nur noch geschlagen. Das führt jetzt dazu, das haben wir auch schon mal kurz besprochen, die Gehaltseinbußen der Schlüsselspieler sind enorm, weil die jeweils in den Verträgen, also sehr stark leistungsorientierte Verträge, da hat Blu-Code zumindest gelernt. Diese Kani-Chokoa-Mekka-Deals, wo sie einfach nur das Grundgehalt hingeschrieben haben, haben sie relativ schnell gemerkt, das würde nicht funktionieren, wenn man das durchzieht aufgrund eben der vor allen Dingen Nachhaltigkeitsregeln der Premier League, PSA. Und sind dann irgendwann dazu übergegangen, dass sie leistungsbezogene Verträge mit niedrigen Grundgehältern und sehr starken Boni installieren, die dann nur eben ausgezahlt würden bei entsprechender Einkunft für Qualifikationen für die Bewerbe. Sorgt aber auch dafür, dass die Grundgehälter für Schlußenspieler wie Enzo Fernandes, Cole Palmer, Levi Cole, Will, Rhys James und so sowieso schon relativ gering sind. Und die sinken jetzt nochmal drastisch, weil sie weder Champions League noch Europa League noch Europa Conference League, das wären die drei eingebauten Sockel, haben. Und jetzt könnt ihr euch vorstellen, dass die wahnsinnig glücklich sind mit ihren Verträgen und nicht wegwollen. Und Bluko hat halt das große Problem, dass das alles immer auf Kante genäht war, ohnehin schon. Das heißt, sie müssen jetzt mindestens einen großen Verkauf tätigen. Das ist zumindest das, was ich jetzt gehört habe. Einen großen Verkauf tätigen, um Jabi Alonso die gegebenen Versprechen zu erfüllen, die da heißen, er wollte Minimum zwei Spieler, die er auch genannt hat intern. Plus er ist der erste Manager von Bluko, nicht Trainer. Das ist in der Bezeichnung ganz wichtig. Und auch das ist nicht ungewöhnlich, dass man das jetzt auch so bezeichnet hat. Jabi Alonso ist definitiv der mächtigste Mann bei Chelsea, seitdem Bluko jetzt übernommen hat. Das klingt jetzt so, als würden wir eine wahnsinnige Ära besprechen. Letztlich hat Bluko jetzt in den Jahren, in denen sie da sind, eigentlich fast ausschließlich die Saisonziele verpasst, die Minimalen, die da heißen, Champions League-Qualifikation. Und das bedeutet, dass dieses Projekt, so wie sie es geplant haben, eigentlich so gar nicht funktionieren kann. Das heißt, sie müssen jetzt den nächsten Schlenker und den nächsten Schlenker und den nächsten Schlenker machen. Und um es einmal sportlich zu begründen, bei Chelsea ist es so gewesen, haben– ich lasse das gelten– haben die Klub-WM bis zum Schluss durchgezogen. Jetzt hat Paris das Gegenbeispiel geliefert, dass man– die haben sich eher in der ersten Saisonhälfte ausgeruht, in Anführungszeichen. Was, glaube ich, auch nicht so stimmt, insbesondere über den Spielstil, aber sind eher hinten raus stärker geworden. Bei Chelsea war es genau andersrum. Zunächst hat man wenig bemerkt. Schon teilweise Dinge, aber wenig bemerkt. Und je länger die Saison ging, umso mehr hat man gemerkt, oh, oh, oh, jetzt kommen die müden Beine. Die Saison, mit Verlaub in England, ist auch noch ein bisschen länger. Die waren bis zum Schluss auch im FA Cup dabei. Trotzdem, haben wir auch, glaube ich, schon einmal hier besprochen, im Nachhinein ist von Tag zu Tag die Entlassung Marézkas schlechter geworden. Rosengiorh hatte aus meiner Sicht eigentlich gar nicht so eine schlechte Phase. Zum Schluss sind die Ergebnisse gar nicht da gewesen, sodass sie es sich nochmal überlegt haben. Karl McFarlane hat aber auch gar nichts gebracht, also gar nichts gebracht. Und dazu ist, was man auch so hört, aus Jersey ein großes Kulturproblem da ist, ein großes Wort immer. Aber wir haben am letzten Spieltag auch nochmal gegen Sunderland eine rote Karte gesehen, schon wieder. Meist in der Liga rote Karten, ganz, ganz viele Spieler, die einfach nicht hören wollen. Unter keinem Trainer, wenn überhaupt, am ehesten unter Mareska. Also Garnaccio ist wahrscheinlich so.
Warum geht Alonso zum Wiederzug in so einem Team?
Weil Arne Schlott zu dem Zeitpunkt noch in Amt und Würden war wahrscheinlich. Also, I don't know, ich weiß es nicht, warum er das gemacht hat. Aber man hat ihm, also er hat sehr klare Forderungen gestellt. Das ist das, was ich weiß. Und man hat ihm gesagt, er kriegt alles, was er möchte, inklusive eben der Macht. Aber das Ding ist ja das, man muss ja immer noch sagen bei Chelsea, wenn man sich den Kader flach anschaut, ohne Wissen. Also einfach nur bei, weiß nicht, ihr könnt ja das Portal aussuchen, transfermarkt.de. Und man geht da hin und schaut sich das an, dann denkt man, ach so, ja, der ist talentiert, der, der, der. Und wenn das funktioniert, wow, wow, wow, wow. Es funktioniert halt nie. Und da gibt es halt gewisse Gründe dafür. Also Enzo Fernandez, der, der dann aus Versehen zwischenzeitlich fallen lässt, dass Madrid auch ein schöner Wohnort wäre. Ich glaube, haben wir hier auch besprochen. Ist natürlich so gemeint gewesen, nach Beraterwechsel, der natürlich nichts zu tun hatte mit einem potenziellen Wechselwunsch. Wissen wir alle, dass nie Berater gewechselt werden, weil irgendwas forciert werden soll. Cole Palmer hat nicht so performt, wie er das Jahr zuvor insbesondere performt hat. Da gibt es auch schon die Diskussion in England, war es vielleicht das beste One-Season-Wonder in der Geschichte der One-Season-Wonder. Ich glaube es nicht. Aber Levi Coble hat lange gefehlt. Das hat ihnen sehr wehgetan. Ich glaube, das ist nirgendwo besprochen worden, wie sehr ihnen das wehgetan hat. Weil das der Einzige ist, der von hinten raus, also erstens, der sowas wie, Christian hat das vorher schon mal gesagt, Leadership im weitesten Sinne gegeben hat, mit einer sehr flachen Hierarchie bei Chelsea auf Grund, allein der Altersstruktur, der einfach eine Persönlichkeit ist, der aber auch der beste Spieler ist in Sachen Passing Range von hinten raus. Vielleicht sogar der Einzige, der das so richtig gut kann, weil sie lange Zeit nur auf 1 gegen 1 eingekauft haben im defensiven Sektor. Joe Pedro, wenn er nicht da war, hat ihnen enorm gefehlt. Der macht es eigentlich ganz gut. Ansonsten finde ich Fernandez war ohnehin schon, also auch wenn da bei uns im Podcast immer alle auf die Barrikaden gehen, so ist es nun mal. Ich bilde mir das ja nicht ein. Ich habe da eine nachweislich ganz gute Quelle. Und Enzo Fernandez, wenn ihr euch erinnert, nach der Copa, dieser rassistische Gesang mit den argentinischen Nationalmannschaftskollegen gegen insbesondere schwarze Franzosen oder generell Franzosen mit Migrationshintergrund, das hat ihnen der Kernbatchel sehr übel genommen. Allen voran Wesley Fofana, der eben nicht so gering einzuschätzen ist mit seinem Status innerhalb der Mannschaft. Das sind halt Dinge, die sind nicht so leicht. Natürlich kannst du eine Pressemitteilung rausgeben und ein Dekret. Wir kommunizieren jetzt dazu nicht mehr. Aber das ändert ja nichts. Das löst ja nicht das Problem. Und das sind alles Dinge, das meine ich mit Kultur. Da muss jetzt jemand rein, der wirklich klar aufräumt. Maresqat hat das eigentlich okay gemacht. Aber es ist nicht ganz leicht, das alles zu erklären. Fabian?
Vielleicht ist es, so sehe ich es zumindest, für Xavi Alonso jetzt gar keine so schlechte Startposition. Weil er kann wahrscheinlich den Kader jetzt ein bisschen aufräumen. Er kann wahrscheinlich auch Spieler wegverkaufen lassen, weil er ja mit Sicherheit auch Geld oder weil sie Umsatz machen müssen. Er kann sich den Kader dann mehr oder weniger so aufbauen, wie er will. Finanziell stellt sich Chelsea immer noch dazu in der Lage sein, den ein oder anderen zu holen. Bei Leverkusen hat er es mit Grimaldu, mit Chaka, mit was weiß ich was gemacht. Er kann sich da schon was zusammenbasteln und hat natürlich den Vorteil nächstes Jahr keine Doppelbelastung.
Könnte. Könnte. Das Problem ist halt Blue-Cow. Was wir wissen über Blue-Cow, seitdem sie da sind, ist, dass Bidadig Bali seltsamerweise impulsiv ist für einen Geschäftsmann. Das heißt, der möchte manchmal einfach etwas machen, weil er es machen will. Er möchte manchmal einfach ein Statement in die Welt setzen mit der Verpflichtung von Enzo Fernandez zum Beispiel. Das weiß ich, dass Enzo Fernandez seinerzeit eigentlich ja schon woanders war. Dann hat er diese tolle WM in Qatar gespielt und dann hat er irgendwann gesagt, wir kaufen den jetzt, was müssen wir bezahlen? Dann ist ihm die Summe genannt worden intern. Aber eben auch die Weitsicht der Leute. Hör mal zu, der ist gerade auf einem Hype und es gibt 2, 3 Leute, 2, 3 Vereine, die ihn jetzt verpflichten möchten. Wenn wir warten würden und der Hype abflacht, der spielt in Portugal und Benfica möchte nicht verkaufen, dann kriegen wir ihn für unserer Meinung nach 20, 30, vielleicht sogar 40 Millionen günstiger. Und der Gbali sagt, es ist mir egal, er ist der beste Spieler der WM, wir kaufen den jetzt.
Aber an uns soll ja Manager sein, er soll ja auch dann, also theoretisch sagen wir mal so.
Aber es gibt halt 5 Sportdirektoren.
Ja.
Und Chelsea hat uns nochmal alle eine E-Mail geschrieben, mit der Begründung, welcher Sportdirektor was macht und jeder Einzelne ist brutal wichtig. Und da gab es dann auch, also ich glaube der Telegrapher weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber auf jeden Fall die haben nochmal mit Zusatzinformationen des Vereins, also so liest es sich zumindest und das hat mir ein Pressesprecher, also die haben ja externe Pressesprecher, das ist ja das Lustige daran. Die haben interne, aber die kommunizieren nicht, sondern die externen kommunizieren. Und die haben uns nochmal auch gesagt, ja, das ist wahr, also in diesem besagten Artikel, da hat Chelsea die eine oder andere Information gegeben, damit wir alle verstehen, jeder Sportdirektor hat natürlich seinen Wert und Beda Degbali macht gar nichts alleine, was natürlich auch nicht stimmt. Also, naja.
Okay, also das ist Chelsea. Uli, ganz kurz noch, Bournemouth, die unentschieden Könige Europas, 18-mal unentschieden, hat kein anderes Team aus den Top 5 Ligen, ähnlich geschafft. Damit sind sie auf Rang 6 gelandet, Europa League geschafft, aber Iraola ist jetzt weg. Ganz kurz deine zwei Cents dazu.
Ähm, die mit besten drei Jahre eines Trainers, von denen ich weiß, erstaunlich, was der aus dem kleinsten, mit Abstand kleinsten Verein der Liga gemacht hat in drei Jahren, egal, welche Spieler verkauft worden sind. Das hat keinen Unterschied gemacht. Im Gegenteil, die nächsten 100 Millionen Verkäufe sind schon wieder drin. Also, Rayan leg ich sehr ans Herz. Wenn der eine halbwegs vernünftige WM spielt, dann werden sie den, glaube ich, nicht mal über das halbe Jahr hinaushalten können. Am Ende ist es sogar irgendwie fast schade, dass Villa und Liverpool nicht in Spendierlaune waren. Sonst hätte ja sogar noch der sechste Platz auch für die Champions League gereicht, dadurch, dass Villa die Europa League gewonnen hat. Hätte nur Liverpool an Villa vorbeiziehen müssen, dann wäre es so gewesen. Ähm, ich habe, wir haben ja darüber gesprochen, haben bei Marco Rosi, der jetzt übernimmt, schon auch denken könnte, ja, passt vielleicht aufgrund des Umschaltansatzes. Ich verliere aber auch ihren technischen Direktor schon wieder. Die haben Richard Euse zu Liverpool verloren, jetzt im nächsten Jahr Simon Francis. Auch jeweils Schüler gewesen. Das heißt, komplett neue Führungsmannschaft. Ich fürchte, dass, also Senesic geht auf jeden Fall, der eine richtig gute Saison gespielt hat. Ich fürchte, dass sich für Alex Scott jemand interessieren wird von den größeren Vereinen, der eine tolle Saison gespielt hat. Ich fürchte, dass eben Rayan vielleicht das ein oder andere Angebot haben könnte. Dango Atara hat hinten raus brutal gut gespielt.
Gruppi zu PSG.
Gruppi, genau, vor allen Dingen.
Nein, zum FC Bayern, Jakob.
Wo kommt denn das jetzt auf einmal her?
Adrian Truffert war unfassbar in der Saison. Und wenn sie es irgendwann auf die Spitze treiben mit der Verkauferei, dann könnte das eines Tages schiefgehen, weil der, der es nicht schiefgehen hat, Lassen halt nicht mehr da ist. Von dem wissen wir es. Und ich bin, also das ist irgendwie auf der einen Seite total reizvoll für Marco Rose und auf der anderen Seite auch vielleicht auch echt riskant, was sie da jetzt tun. Und ich bin gespannt, ob er es im Kreuz hat. So sicher bin ich mir nicht tatsächlich, nicht mehr.
Eigentlich kannst du da nur verlieren. Du könntest schon quasi, wenn die Spieler blieben als Nachfolger von Iraola, wahrscheinlich nur verlieren. Und wenn jetzt da zwei, drei Stützen noch gehen, also ist schon mutig, das zu machen. Aber vielleicht musst du es auch einfach machen.
Also bis dato alles, was wir sehen, und das ist ja auch ein, also die haben ja mit die größte Ansammlung von Vereinen inzwischen, der Kollege, der da ist. Die haben ja unfassbar viele Vereine unter dem Hut. Aber bis dato sind die, seitdem die, ich habe jetzt den Namen gerade nicht parat, seitdem der Chairman da ist, ist Bournemouth unfassbar gut geführt. Sehr nachvollziehbar geführt, ruhig geführt. Und wenn das so weitergeht, dann ist das ein gutes Fundament. Wie gesagt, was wir alle nicht wissen, ist, inwiefern, wie stark Ira Ola wirklich war als Chef-Trainer. Da gibt es jetzt, sieht der so aus, als würde der zu Liverpool gehen, also eins drüber. Sodass Leverkusen auch wieder Pech hat. Die den schon lange im Auge haben. Das hätte auch, glaube ich, super gut gepasst. Gerade auch in der Bundesliga hätte es super gut gepasst. Das ist dann nochmal ein ganz eigenes Thema, weil ich nicht weiß, inwiefern Ira Ola, also ich habe den neulich mal so verglichen, um es zu erklären, mit Colambo, dem Fernsehdetektiv, der immer so ein bisschen auf dämlich macht, aber eigentlich in Wahrheit brutal scharfsinnig ist. Und Ira Ola steht da auch immer so und erzählt immer, ich mache immer Quizzes und spiele immer Fußballmanager und so, wie wir alle. Und hat immer seine Fingertapes, wo er sagt, ja, ich bin halt ein bisschen eigen und gibt immer so einen leichten, es gibt immer so ein Gefühl von, ich bin ein bisschen Dulli. In Wahrheit ist der natürlich genau das Gegenteil, sondern ist wahnsinnig hands-on und super im Training, vor allen Dingen sehr positiv den Spielern gegenüber. Das sieht dann nicht so aus, wenn es wiederum Spiel gibt. Ich glaube, der hat sehr genau für sich seine Ebenen festgestellt, wann, wie, wo, welche Person er nach außen gibt. Ich bin aber gespannt, ob das in Liverpool so funktioniert, wenn es dazu kommen sollte. Aber der Fußballtrainer, der Fußballlehrer, nach allem, was wir gesehen haben, hat jedes Jahr genau dasselbe auf den Platz bringen lassen, egal, von welchem Personal. Man hat auch immer von Monat zu Monat die Fortschritte gesehen. Jetzt hinten raus haben sie, ich weiß gar nicht, 17 oder so nicht in Folge verloren. Ich glaube, das ist total…
Ich glaube, seit dem Verkauf von Zimeno haben sie gar nicht verloren, sogar seit Januar oder so.
Genau, genau, genau. Obwohl ja das, das ist ja jemand, der… Also ich habe mir so meine Spieler-des-Jahres-Liste hingelegt und am Ende hat es jetzt nicht. Und wir haben dann am Ende 4 immer gemacht für unseren Podcast, die es dann sind. Am Ende hat es jetzt nicht in die Top 4 geschafft, aber er kommt unmittelbar danach auf 5 oder 6, weil er auch für City brutal transformative Wirkung hatte nochmal mit seiner Art und Weise. Und Dean Haussen, ehemaliger spanischer Nationalspieler, ich habe es gesagt.
Die WM-Hoffnung real ist, war jeder nicht geschafft.
Naja, der ist auch schon ein bisschen älter jetzt. Dann haben sie Kerkesz weggegeben zu Liverpool, redet gar keiner mehr drüber, auch weil Troféer Wahnsinn ist. James Hill kannte niemand, weil er einfach kein Faktor war, spielt eine nahtlose Saison. Marcos Senesi, ehemals Ehrenhilfverteidiger Nr. 3, Sabani ist zum Champions League-Sieger gegangen, kein Thema, passt schon. Alex Scott galt schon als Flop, läuft auf einmal in der Saison auf. Und eben Rayan ist für mich so mit der Spieler, den ich am liebsten mag im Moment, weil das ist einfach nur Spektakel, wenn der spielt. Also der nimmt den Ball, der hat gar kein Auge für den Mitspieler, gar nicht, das muss er auf jeden Fall noch ändern, aber der nimmt den Ball und fängt einfach an, durchzubrechen. Und ich weiß nicht, wo er uns noch führen soll mit dem. Der ist eigentlich noch, also so blöd das klingt, der ist eigentlich noch besser als Semenyo, weil er all die Dinge hat, die Semenyo hat, plus die Technik. Also es ist irgendwie crazy.
Also Jereola, nur ein Satz, also das ist schon beeindruckend wie der. Ich würde sagen, vor ein paar Monaten war noch so ein bisschen unterm Radar, das mit das heißeste Eisen. Und jetzt ist er halt mit Abstand das heißeste Trainer-Eisen. Also das ist schon krass. Ich weiß, aus Italien war es schon vor vielen Monaten, gab es immer wieder ein paar, die auch probiert haben, ein bisschen Kontakt herzustellen. Aber jetzt die letzten Wochen, der kann sich ja aussuchen, was immer er will. Und ja, am Ende wird es jetzt halt Liverpool werden.
Und ich sage es euch.
Das ist schon beeindruckend.
Ich sage es euch, auch Oliver Glasners größtes Problem, weil beides sind in England gegen den Balltrainer, die jeweils aus Underdogs super schwierig zu spielende Mannschaften machen mit ihren Strategien in der Defensive. Und weil Jereola noch besser ist als Glasner, wie blöd das klingt, ist er überall auf jeder Shortlist vor Oliver Glasner, was total blöd ist, weil eigentlich müsste Glasner jetzt auch bei Liverpool theoretisch, also bei Milan haben wir es ja schon gehört, da gab es ja auch die Jereola-Gerüchte immer jetzt noch.
Jaja.
Aber irgendwie überall, wo Glasner im Gespräch ist, Jereola auch im Gespräch und ist dann halt leicht favorisiert. Das ist irgendwie blöd. Aber das ist ja immer nicht, aber…
Aber er kann ja nicht überall hingehen, Jereola. Also klar, Liverpool ist halt damit dann wahrscheinlich dicht. Aber schon mal Leverkusen wäre dann frei für Uli Glasner.
Ja, aber da bockte er auf was?
Jaja, das war ein Witz. Alles klar.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, wahrscheinlich lässt er sich erstmal Zeit, weil es wird schon innerhalb der Premier League auch was aufgehen in der Saison. Relativ schnell. Aber ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, das ist nicht das, was er möchte, eigentlich jetzt zu warten, sondern ich glaube schon, dass er gerne angeschlossen hätte.
Ja, gut. Aber wir werden es beobachten. Uli, du verpasst deinen Call. Das möchte ich nicht. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst. Bis bald.
Adiós.
Ciao, Uli.
Ciao.
Wir machen weiter und blicken nochmal nach Spanien. Fabian, was hast du uns da noch mitgebracht? Gibt es noch Themen?
Ja, es gibt natürlich noch. Vielleicht wollen wir nochmal ganz kurz auf diesen harten Abstiegskampf blicken. Der war ja schon nicht ganz ohne. Und am Schluss hat es leider, muss ich wirklich sagen, Martin Demichelis mit seinem Real Mallorca erwischt. Und zwar auch nur, weil in Spanien nicht die Tordifferenz zählt. Bei Punktegleichheit, sondern der direkte Vergleich. Und da musste sich Mallorca mit Osasuna und Levante im Dreiervergleich, die waren nämlich alle punktgleich, dann doch noch geschlagen geben. Und ganz bitter auch, weil, ich glaube, vor 2 oder 3 Spieltagen erst auch Mallorca ein Spiel noch aus der Hand gegeben hat mit einem verschossenen Elfmeter. In der Endphase der Partie und so weiter. Also ein höchst dramatischer Abstieg für Mallorca. Bin gespannt, was dort jetzt passiert, denn es ist ja auch ein, weiß nicht, Unternehmenskonsortium ist zu viel gesagt, aber in der Hand einiger US-amerikanischer Investoren, einiger Sportler auch und bin mal gespannt, ob die Vorkaube dort weiterzumachen oder nicht. Man weiß es ja nicht immer ganz genau, was da dahinter steckt. Wer sich noch gerettet hat, was ich übrigens dann doch, obwohl ich ja kein Sevilla-Fan bin, als Malerganese sozusagen, aber der FC Sevilla hat sich noch gerettet und das sah teilweise sehr, sehr, sehr düster aus. Also da hätte es fast einen der großen Traditionsklubs erwischt. Die haben sich aber gerade noch so abgewendet und werden in der Liga bleiben. Und ja, vielleicht noch ein Wort zum Athletikklub aus Bilbao, der ja jetzt einen deutschen Trainer bekommt. Der Trend ist your friend. Die deutschen Trainer kommen vermehrt in die Primäre Division. Und ich bin sehr, sehr, sehr gespannt, was Terzic mit Bilbao machen wird. Denn wir wissen alle, Bilbao ist ja kein normaler Fußballklub, sondern dort dürfen wir nur Baskenspielen oder Leute, die im Baskenland geboren sind oder ähnliche Wurzeln haben und die aber sehr, sehr großen Wert auch darauf legen, dass ihre Trainer dann schon auch von außerhalb kommen dürfen. Jupp Heynckes war vielleicht das beste Beispiel, der nach wie vor, glaube ich, dort einige Denkmäler hat. Und jetzt bin ich dann doch echt sehr, sehr gespannt, dass sich Terzic für Bilbao entschieden hat. Finde ich extrem spannend, kann es überhaupt nicht einschätzen. Ich weiß natürlich, dass Bilbao jetzt auch spielermäßig was machen wird im Sommer. Die hatten wirklich eine schwierige Saison, viele Verletzungen in der Leistungsträger. Marco Williams war eigentlich mehr oder weniger die ganze Saison verletzt. Und die werden jetzt nochmal alles, was im Baskenland Rang und Namen hat und nicht eh schon bei Bilbao spielt, abgrasen und dem Terzic da hoffentlich ein gutes Paket hinstellen. Denn die Stadt und der Club und so weiter haben es natürlich deutlich mehr verdient, als die Tabellenposition 12, die es am Ende war. Nur drei Punkte vom Abstieg weg. Gut, da waren sie natürlich auch in einer Gemengelage mit vielen anderen Vereinen. Aber da bin ich doch sehr gespannt, auch auf die neue Saison mit Terzic beim Atletik-Club, mit Materazzo bei Real Sociedad, mit Flick sowieso bei Barcelona. Und mal gucken, ob sich der Traum der Königlichen erfüllt und Jürgen Klopp da noch bei Real unterschreibt.
Die sind ja auf dem Rindio festgelegt. Und da kann man sich ja wirklich nur beglückwünschen zu dieser Entscheidung. Aber lass noch ganz kurz mal bei Mallorca noch bleiben, weil wir haben ja über Martin Demekilis gesprochen. Und er hatte ja eigentlich eine ganz gute Bilanz. Also wir haben das ja schon mal angesprochen, der Ligatour, dass es so aussah, als würde Mallorca da wirklich rausführen. Geht es denn für ihn dann weiter oder ist es auch noch in der Schwebe nach dem Abstieg?
Noch ist es in der Schwebe. Man wollte ja aufgrund der guten Ergebnisse, die du schon angesprochen hast, eigentlich schon vorzeitig mit ihm verlängern. Da hat man aber nichts mehr gehört. Und jetzt ist, glaube ich, der Schock noch ziemlich groß dort. Und da wird jetzt erst mal noch sortiert, was dort die nächsten Tage und Wochen passieren soll und die Neuese so vorbereiten. Ich würde sie wünschen, dass er vielleicht noch eine Chance bekommt. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn er weiterhin hier in Spanien als Trainer bleibt. Er hat aber auch keinen leichten Stand bei der Presse gehabt, hat sich da teilweise auch mit den Leuten angelegt, weil die wohl angeblich interner ausgeplaudert haben.
Die Presse.
Die Presse, genau.
Weiß er, wie Presse funktioniert. In Spanien, das ist ja wie Albert Riere. Ihr mögt ja den Club gar nicht, ihr berichtet ja alles, was die Spieler euch erzählen.
Das war so ein bisschen auch seine Herangehensweise, was er gesagt hat. Wenn ihr den Club lebt, dann macht ihr sowas nicht. Ja, ist ein bisschen unglücklich gelaufen, war aber auch wohl eine Spielerinternen vom Spieler, der nicht zufrieden war und so weiter.
Sollten schon mal vorgekommen sein im Fußball, dass die unzufriedenen Spieler Informationen rausgeben.
Man muss sich aber zur Seite springen, in dem Fall, dass Mallorca die Stimmung aufgrund der Tabellensituation wirklich geladen war. Es ging wirklich um jeden Grashalm, den man noch umdrehen konnte. Und alles musste man noch irgendwie versuchen, irgendwie herauszufinden. Und jetzt hat es leider nicht geklappt, aber wirklich nur ganz, ganz bitter nicht wegen dem direkten Vergleich und wegen dem vergebenden Elfmeter. Und es ist die ein oder andere strittige Situation in einem ein oder anderen Spiel auch. Aber er hat eigentlich vieles richtig gemacht. Aber es hat halt, wie gesagt, nicht gereicht. Und wir werden sehen, was mit Mallorca passiert.
Ja, und was mit Martin de Mequiel es passiert. Da bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt drauf. Fabian, ein allerletztes kurzes Thema müssen wir noch machen. Also mein interner FC Malaga-Counter steht bei 2. Du hast sie vorhin zweimal erwähnt. Und jetzt sollst du aber nochmal die Möglichkeit bekommen. Ich weiß genau, was du am 7. Juni und was du am 10. Juni machen wirst. Jeweils ab 21 Uhr deutscher Zeit. Du wirst das Ausstiegs-Play of die Halbfinalspiele gegen Las Palmas beobachten. Wie ist die Lage bei Malaga? Wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du in der nächsten Saison über den ersten Legisten Malaga sprechen kannst und kein anderes Thema mehr mitbringen musst?
Das wäre natürlich für mich wunderbar, weil in keinem Club bin ich natürlich so sehr drin wie in diesem. Aber im Endeffekt ist es eine harte Play-off-Runde in Spanien. Es sind ja nicht nur das Duell gegen Las Palmas, sondern danach wird es ja noch mal weitergehen gegen die Gewinner aus dem zweiten Play-off-Halbfinale Almeria, dem Saudi-Club, der ja zumindest nominell nochmal eine ganz andere Kaderbreite aufbringt. Und die spielen gegen Castellón. Das gehört dem holländischen Unternehmer. Auch die haben finanziell nochmal ganz andere Mittel. Aber der FC Malaga– und das ist eben die Feel-good-Story– Sie sind seit sechs Jahren jetzt zwangsverwaltet mit einem juristisch eingesetzten Geschäftsführer. Sie können wirklich nur maximal das finanzieren in Spielermaterial, was sie selber erarbeiten. Und keinen einzigen Cent mehr. Wir haben diese juristische Schwebe, die immer über uns steht. Man weiß nicht, was mit Al Thani passiert. Und wir sind in diesen sechs Jahren auch in die dritte Liga abgestiegen. Vor zwei Jahren wieder aufgestiegen. Im ersten Jahr jetzt die zweite Liga gehalten. Und jetzt, wie gesagt, auf Eigengewächse gesetzt. Ich weiß nicht, was unser Durchschnittsalter ist. Aber ich würde sagen so 22, 23.
Ja, es ist 26,3. Aber das ist weiter noch ein paar ältere mit dabei.
Weil ein paar ältere mit dabei sind. Aber die Leistungsträger sind tatsächlich alle junge. Jüngere Eigengewächse aus der eigenen. Dementsprechend, du kannst dir gar nicht vorstellen, was hier in den letzten Wochen los ist. Das Stadion ist wochenlang vorher ausverkauft. Es gibt keine Plätze. Das Team wird jedes Mal mit Bengalos vor dem Stadion empfangen. Wenn sie aus der Auswärtsreise wiederkommen.
Also wir lehnen die Flugbüro-Technik ab. Das ist aber ja völlig klar. Es ist verboten.
Davon mal abgesehen.
Euch und andere.
Die Stimmung ist wirklich unfassbar groß. Wir kriegen so viel Lob von allen anderen Vereinen aus der 1. und 2. Liga, wie der Weg ist. Weil die Spielphilosophie des FC Malaga auch immer ist. Wahlbesitz aber immer nach vorne. Es geht immer nach vorne. Wir haben Spiele verloren, unglücklich z.B. in Almeria, weil wir einfach in der 90. Minute nochmal nach vorne rennen mussten und natürlich uns einen blöden Konter gefangen haben und dann noch dieses Tor kassiert haben. Aber die Philosophie des FC Malaga ist wirklich mit den Jungs im. Es geht immer nach vorne. Es wird immer nach vorne gespielt. Es wird mit so viel Mut gespielt. Und es wird zum Großteil eben auch belohnt. Und ich bin wirklich sehr, sehr gut da Dinge, auch wenn Las Palmas jetzt erstmal ein harter Knochen ist. Aber wenn sie weiterhin dabei bleiben, ihren eigenen Stil beizubehalten, dann können sie das Wunder tatsächlich schaffen. Und es wäre wirklich ein Wunder, weil, wie gesagt, nominell und was die Transferstrukturen oder das Budget zu den Top-Mannschaften der 2. Liga gehören. Aber sportlich sind wir im Moment ganz weit vorne. Und es wäre für die Stadt natürlich der Wahnsinn. Es ist hier die fünfte oder sechstgrößte Stadt Spaniens. Und meistens Maler gehört schon in die 1. Liga und drückt uns allen die Daumen, dass es klappt.
Werden wir tun, ich sag noch ganz kurz, wird denn das irgendwann mal enden mit der Zwangsverwaltung? Du hast ja gesagt, es ist noch in der Schwebe. Aber was schwebt da eigentlich wohin?
Ja, die Frage ist, wann das endlich mal gerechtlich jetzt festgelegt wird, welche Prozent oder Aktienprozentanteile dieser Altani noch hat oder nicht. Und warum dieses Gerichtsverfahren nach wie vor nicht stattfindet, da stellt sich bei uns allen die Frage. Natürlich hat Altani und seine Anwälte immer alles versucht, das Ganze hinaus zu zögern, hinaus zu zögern. Hier nochmal Revision, hier nochmal bin ich nicht da. Hier in Spanien waren sie schon lange nicht mehr. Aussage in Dubai wollen wir nicht machen und so weiter und so fort. Nach 10 Jahren, wenn man nach 10 Jahren dieses Verfahren nicht irgendwie gerichtlich lösen kann, dann fangen wir wieder bei Null an. Also hoffe ich doch, dass in den kommenden 4 Jahren… Dann ist die Anklage quasi nichtig und dann müsste man wieder von vorne anfangen und nochmal neu klagen und feststellen, ja wie viel Prozent dieser Aktienanteile gehören jetzt wirklich, Althani und ich. Und ich habe das Gefühl, der Mann aus Katar spielt ein bisschen mit der Justiz und hofft, dass er irgendwann seinen Verein wieder zurückbekommt, den er eigentlich rechtmäßig nicht mehr haben dürfte. Und naja, wir werden abwarten, aber es ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr traurig, wie langsam die Justiz hier gerade arbeitet. Aber ich glaube eben auch, weil sie viele Steine vor den Weg geschmissen bekommt, die ganze Zeit. Und leider gibt es auch in der Hinsicht überhaupt keinen neuen Stand.
Oh man. Wer mehr dazu wissen will, sowohl zu der Situation bei Malaga als auch, wie sind eigentlich die Saudi-Arabischen Scheichs reingekommen bei Al-Maria? Wir haben 2019 darüber gesprochen. Das ist Tribugengespräch Nummer 72 und ja leider aktueller denn je. Es ging damals auch noch über Burry und Bolton. Da war Hendrik Buchheister noch zu Gast und mit euch beiden habe ich eben über diese vier Beispiele von Vereinsübernahmen, von Insolvenzen, Fastinsolvenzen und so weiter gesprochen. Bis hin zu Lizenzentzug ging es ja. Ich werde es verlinken in den Show-Nots. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Und du lebst ja in dieser Welt und erzählst es einfach mit. Ja, das ist der Saudi Club. Ach so, ja, die gehören dem holländischen Unternehmer. Aber dass das einfach so, dass wir gar nicht mehr drüber sprechen. Ja, die kommen aus der und der Region und die haben die und die Fans, sondern dass wir quasi sagen, ja, wem gehört eigentlich der Verein? Das ist schon wirklich einfach etwas Besonderes. Fabian, wir drücken dir die Daumen.
Dankeschön.
Und vielen, vielen Dank dir und bis bald hier wieder. Danke für eine schöne Saison Ligatour mit dir.
Hat mich auch gefreut und wie gesagt, La Liga, glaube ich, wird nächstes Jahr wieder ein Stück weit heißer und da können wir uns alle drauf freuen.
Stark, das tun wir. Fabian, bis bald.
Ciao, ciao, macht's gut. Ciao.
Und wir bleiben dran. Das ist jetzt so ein bisschen hier einer nach dem anderen geht. Ich habe das schon mal zitiert und dann damals falsch gesagt. Das war Schumann war das, glaube ich. Der hat mal ein Stück komponiert, wo nacheinander alle Instrumente aufgehört haben zu spielen. Aber bevor ich es jetzt wieder falsch zitiere, höre ich lieber genau an der Stelle auf. Christian, lass nochmal in nach Italien blicken. Was hast du denn noch mitgebracht an Themen?
Ja, nachdem ich jetzt ja für die eher beschauliche Laune zuständig war, kommen wir jetzt aus Italien zum Märchen, das kein Märchen ist, nämlich Como. Schauen wir uns logisch Como nochmal an, genauer, weil Como an diesem verrückten letzten Spieltag in die Champions League gesprungen ist. Ganz kurz auch da, wie gesagt, es ging drum, Milan, Juve, Como, Roma, 2 Ja, 2 Nein. Como war genau wie Juve auf Schützenhilfe angewiesen, also die hatten es nicht allein in der Hand, haben ihren Job erledigt und dann hat Milan ihnen den Gefallen getan. Und ja, jetzt stehen Cesc, Fabregas und Como nach ihrer zweiten Serie A-Saison in der Champions League. Kurz die statistischen Fakten nur. Statistisch absolut verdient. Zweitbester Angriff, also nur Inter war erfolgreicher, deutlich erfolgreicher und aber beste Abwehr der Liga. Also Fabregas, wir haben ja schon ein, zwei Mal darüber gesprochen, hat da wirklich, ja, hat Fußballeres was geschaffen, gar keine Frage. Also hochintensives Pressing, wie gesagt, also diese beste Abwehr der Liga ist keineswegs geschuldet, dass die da im tiefen Block hinten drin standen, sondern aggressives Gegenpressing, durchschieben, hochschieben, viel Ballbesitz ist die Mannschaft mit den meisten Ballbesitz. Und dann eben aus all diesen, auch aus hohen Ballgewinnen raus, dann halt auch Offensive kreieren und deswegen, ja. Ist ja seit Fabregas, würde ich sagen, mittlerweile seit Monaten eines der ziemlich begehrten, oder mittlerweile sogar seit einem Jahr, glaube ich, kann man sagen, einer der begehrtesten Trainer auf dem Markt in Europa. Und ja, hat jetzt logischerweise diese Geschichte geschrieben in Kormor. Deswegen meint etwas ironischer Einstieg. Viel hin und wieder hat die Bezeichnung Märchen, aber Märchen ist es halt nicht, weil hinter Kormor steckt die Hartono Group. Das sind zwei indonesische Geschäftsmännerbrüder, von denen einer der beiden jetzt vor wenigen Monaten gestorben ist. Da reden wir über ein Vermögen, geschätztes Vermögen von 50 Milliarden Dollar, was diese Herrschaften sozusagen über ihre Geschäfte entwickelt haben. Und vielleicht ist es nochmal doch ganz gut, dass wir jetzt nochmal über Kormor sprechen, weil ich finde, ich habe ein paar neue Sachen recherchiert, ist schon ein interessanter Ansatz. Also zum einen müssen wir, Max, das haben wir vielleicht mal nicht ganz aufgelöst. Also es handelt sich nicht um den Multiclub-Ownership bei Kormor. Also Kormor ist wirklich diese Hartono Group, hat nur Kormor. Und sie führen das Ganze, sprechen sie auch ganz offen wie ein Start-up. Die haben gesagt, wir sind da rein. Und am Anfang, wie man es bei Start-ups so macht, die sprechen von Fabregas, bezeichnen sie immer als CEO. Also wirklich auch die ganze Sprache ist Start-up-Sprache. Sie sagen da, das ganze Fußball-Team sei ein Proof of Concept. Also du kommst da wirklich vor, als wärst du da in einem Business-Call drin, wenn du Interviews von den Verantwortlichen liest.
Wie früher bei Hertha unter Fredi Bobic. Wie liegt das eigentlich?
Und die meinten halt, am Anfang müssten wir sehr viel Geld in die Hand nehmen, also Infrastruktur, aber vor allen Dingen den Kader. Deswegen jetzt eben kein Märchen, weil Cormo hat mittlerweile, obwohl es erst im zweiten Jahr in der Serie A ist, schon dreistelligen Millionen im Bereich allein in den Kader investiert. Also allein in den letzten drei Transferfenstern sind wir da bei 100, 150 Millionen plus Investments. Das ist einfach, da ist viel Geld da und das Geld wurde aber halt interessant, sage ich mal, auf den Transfermarkt angelegt, weil halt nicht irgendwie große alte Namen geholt wurden, sondern auch dank des klingenden Namens von Fabregas und seiner grandiosen Kontakte nach Spanien. Hast du jetzt halt sehr viele talentierte Spieler, also so ein Jesus Rodriguez zum Beispiel eben, der mit neun Torvorlagen nach die Marcos der beste Assis-Geber der Liga, der hat halt letztes Jahr schon in der spanischen Nationalmannschaft debütiert und ja, warum wird der wohl in Como gelandet sein? Ja, weil Fabregas da angerufen hat. Warum sind Nico Paz und Jacobo Ramon beide von Real aus der eigenen Jugend? Warum landen die da? Ja, weil Fabregas da logischerweise eine Strahlkraft hat. Also sie spielen die Fabregas-Karte auch in Sachen Transfermarkt richtig gut und haben da einfach einen wirklichen spannenden Kader zusammengestellt, der in weiten Teilen eben sehr jung ist, weil du hast Baturiná, du hast Nico Paz. Das sind junge Spieler, wo sie auch ganz offen sagen, das ist auch unser Ansatz. Wir holen junge Talentierte für 15, 20 Millionen. Das Ziel ist, die dann irgendwann für 40, 50, 60 weiter zu verkaufen. Also da steckt logischerweise auch die dahinter. Sie haben aber immer auch punktuell ein paar Namen dabei, die niemand auf der Liste hatte. Zum Beispiel bin ich gespannt, ob Jakob ihn hatte. Jean Boutet, der Torhüter. Das ist ein 30-jähriger Franzose. Den haben sie aus Belgien geholt für 2 Millionen Euro. Und der war jetzt mit der beste Torhüter der Liga. Ich habe sogar aus Frankreich gehört, der war bis zum Schluss noch ein Kandidat für einen dritten Platz im Kader, also für die Nummer 3 der Franzosen, der WM. Und der kam halt, den hatte niemand. Den haben die aus von Reuel-Entwerpen, haben die denn geholt für 2 Millionen. Unfassbar ballsicher, für mich der fußballerisch beste Torhüter der Serie A, sogar ein Tick besser als Mignon. Passt perfekt eben, perfekt gescoutet, was sie brauchen. Dann so ein Duvikaster, griechische Stürmer, der kam von Celta Vigo für 14 Millionen Euro, nicht fürs große Geld und ist jetzt mit 14 oder 15 sind tot. Das ist unter und glaube ich die Nummer 3 in der Liga. Also Kempf, der von der Hertha kam, ist jetzt logischerweise auch nicht einer, wo du das riesige Geld ausgepackt hast, aber es funktioniert. Und vielleicht das Symbol ist D'Acunha, der Kapitän. Der kam schon zu Zweitliga-Zeiten aus Frankreich für 950.000 Euro, der hat weniger als eine Million gekostet. Ist Kapitän, ist einer der Taktgeber im Mittelfeld, einen, den Fabregas halt auch perfekt in diese Systematik eingeführt hat. Und ja, und jetzt hast du diese Mannschaft, die logischerweise, ja wie sagt man, alle Etappenziele, die sie sich selbst gestellt haben, gebrochen haben, dem gesagt, niemand hat von der Champions League logischerweise geredet. Das haben die vor vielleicht in 3, 4, 5 Jahren vorgehabt. Jetzt sind die da reingerutscht. Und letzter Satz, bevor ich euch gleich lasse, warum es vielleicht, was ich jetzt am spannendsten bei der Noch-Tiefern-Recherche fand, eben sie sind kein Multiclub-Ownership, aber sie sagen, Achtung, zitiere jetzt, wir wollten ein Multiclub-Servicing-Model werden. Das heißt, sie bieten an, dass alles, was sie rund um den Club etablieren, wollen sie anderen Sportorganisationen auch zur Verfügung stellen. Da reden wir über Software für Datenanalyse, Spieneranalysen, nochmal neues Feld, Gesundheits-Tracking. Also ihr Ansatz ist zu sagen, schaut mal her, was wir hier rund um Kormor aufstellen, bieten wir euch sozusagen als Paket auch für andere Clubs an. Mal schauen, ob das erfolgreich oder zukunftsfähig ist.
Ja, vor allem vor dem Hintergrund. Man stellt sich ja immer die Frage bei diesen Milliardären, die irgendwo reingehen, ja wie wollen sie eigentlich Geld verdienen? Weil es ist extrem schwierig, Geld rauszuziehen aus dem Fußball. Und was in den USA sich schon ganz lange, schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten etabliert hat, ist, dass du mit der Peripherie des Sportes verdienst. Also sprich, du hast zwar die Kansas City Chiefs, aber die gehört vor allem das Stadion. Und du erlöst damit eben schon mal Geld. Oder die gehören eben irgendwelche Datendienstleister. Das ist das, was sich auch so ein bisschen in der NBA durchgesetzt hat. So Software und Technik in der Peripherie des Basketballs. Du hast noch eine Franchise, aber vor allem verdienst du eben Geld über diese Unternehmen. Und da haben jetzt tatsächlich die Milliardäre, die hinter Como stehen, eben einen wirklich einzigartigen Ansatz. Eben zum einen dieses, wir machen auch dich fit für Geldverdienen im Fußballmodell. Dass du eben quasi Software as a Service fast so ein bisschen machst. Also dass du eben das, was du bei Como als Proof of Concept eben zeigst, anderen verkaufst. Und dann aber, dass das eigentliche Geldverdienen mit der Region passiert. Und deswegen ist es auch kein Zufall, dass sie in Como gelandet sind. Also sie beschreiben das selbst als, ich zitiere, Disney-Modell. Also das Team Como ist nicht das Endprodukt, sondern eigentlich nur der Content-Motor für eine weltweit skalierbare Lifestyle-Marke. Es tut mir leid, es klingt, als würde ich hier direkt von LinkedIn vorlesen, indirekt Tuis auch, weil so reden die halt. Aber sie wollen Como zur Welthauptstadt des Fußball-Tourismus machen. Und da ist eben dann eben das Team zwar wichtig für, aber eben nur Vehikel. Und Geld verdient wird aber dann eben mit Tourismus, mit eben den Software-Angeboten, die sie rundherum machen, mit der Marke, die sie aufbauen. Deswegen spielt auch eben Dokus spielen da eine wichtige Rolle. Hollywood-Stars spielen da eine Rolle. Und ich habe mich gefragt, Christian, wie sehen das eigentlich die Leute vor Ort? Denn Como als Region steht immer so ein bisschen im Schatten von anderen. Es ist also früher war es mal so ein Geheimtipp, so wie der Lago Maggiore zum Beispiel. So hier die Münchner, die wussten es, wenn du keinen Bock hast auf Gardasee, weil da sind alle, dann könntest du zum Beispiel dahin. Wie kommt denn das in der Region an? Denn eigentlich wäre das ja nichts Schlechtes. Also wenn die jetzt wirklich zu einer fußballtouristischen, zumindest wichtigen Destination würden, würden ja tatsächlich viele daran auch profitieren.
Erstmal Respekt, Max, wie tief du auch eingetaucht bist. Das ist jetzt auch wahnsinnig, wahnsinnig gut weitergeführt. Ich knüpfe ganz gleich zu deiner Frage. Ich knüpfe direkt an. Sie sagen es ganz offen auch, der Kormorsee steht bei uns im Mittelpunkt. Also es ist, wie du im sagst, der Club ist, also ja, das klingt jetzt vielleicht alles ein bisschen komisch, ist aber wirklich so. Sie vermarkten auch den Club über den Kormorsee, weil, wie du es sagst, der Kormorsee ist logisch alles andere als ein Geheimtipp. Frag mal nach, die George Clooney Villa und so. Also da reden wir, ja, da reden wir über riesen Hollywoodstars. Es waren auch in dieser Saison wieder NFL-Spieler, sind zu den Spielen gekarrt worden. Wir haben auch Rii gesehen, die ganzen Geschichten kennen wir schon. Das haben sie ganz von Anfang an auch schon gemacht. Sie probieren wirklich, wie du sagst, ein Lifestyle-Erlebnis mit der Region, mit dem See, das alles so zusammenzuführen. Und um auf deine Frage zu kommen, sie probieren es. Sie haben schon verstanden, Como war zwar ewig nicht mehr in der Liga, in der höchsten Liga, aber Como hat eine Fußball-Tradition. Du sagst es, Como steht logisch total im Schatten von Mailand. Como ist nicht weit weg von Mailand. Jetzt stehen die plötzlich, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, der Como-Fan, Fußball-Fan, sieht jetzt nächstes Jahr Champions League-Fußball, und der Milan-Fan sieht es nicht. Das hätte man ja sicher vor ein paar Jahren. Ja, 0,0 vorstellen können. Sie haben zum Beispiel, sie probieren schon, die alte Garde, auch die alten Fans mitzunehmen. Sie haben zum Beispiel auch mal in den Raum gestellt, sie wollen den Fans, die schon lange dabei sind, irgendwann gratis eintritt, in die Kurve ermöglichen. Also es ist anscheinend auch ein Ziel von ihnen zu sagen, wir verdienen über die anderen teuren Plätze so viel, dass wir die Kurve oder zumindest bestimmte Teile sozusagen den Leuten dann, sozusagen kostenlos zur Verfügung stellen. Also sie versuchen schon, das sozusagen Hand in Hand zu bekommen. Jetzt erst mal ist die Begeisterung einfach riesengroß. Wie gesagt, es gibt in Kormor, hallo, die spielen nächstes Jahr Champions League. Die träumen jetzt davon, ob die jetzt gegen Real oder Bayern nächstes Jahr spielen. Und dementsprechend ist das logischerweise schon erst mal jetzt alles, was ganz besonderes und das werden sie auch erst mal weiter transportiert bekommen, weil auch durch den Namen Fabregas– das ist logischerweise was Spezielles im Moment. Wie nachhaltig das Ganze dann ist, bin ich auch sehr gespannt, weil mein ist nur meine bescheidene Vermutung. Obwohl die logisch schon im Hintergrund, glaube ich, jetzt gute Basis legen auch, da bin ich fest davon überzeugt. Aber für mich steht und fällt das halt schon trotzdem weiterhin wahnsinnig mit Fabregas. Und Fabregas wird irgendwann, der hat den Anspruch, den hat er als Spieler gehabt, zu Höchsten zu stoßen. Der wird auch als Trainer jetzt irgendwann den Anspruch haben, einen Top-Club zu trainieren. Und dann bin ich halt gespannt, wie fest das Fundament dann ohne ihn dann sein wird. Aber das ist jetzt erstmal eine Zukunftsfrage, denn, Klammer auf, auch wenn die nicht in die Champions League gekommen wären, wäre Fabregas geblieben. Also der läuft das so schnell nicht weg. Der will das schon erstmal weitergehen. Der will sein Spielzeug sozusagen weiter ausleben. Deswegen jetzt noch der kleine Blick nach vorne. Das ist schon sehr spannend. Dadurch, dass sie sich selbst überholt haben, durch die Champions League-Quali kommen jetzt schon ein paar Aufgaben auf sie zu, auf die sie nicht vorbereitet waren. Erstens Stadion. Die haben jetzt schon direkt am Spieltag oder am Tag nach dem letzten Spieltag angefangen zu arbeiten, weil das Stadion ist logischerweise im Moment nicht Champions League-reif. Sie sagen, sie sind optimistisch, dass sie es über den Sommer hinkriegen, um die UEFA-Bestimmungen zu erreichen. Sie haben eventuell als Backup das Marpey Stadion in Reggio Emilia, also da, wo Sao Suolo spielt. Das wäre der Backup, wenn sie es nicht hinkriegen sollten für die Champions League-Spiele. Und spannend ist auch die UEFA-Richtlinien, sei es im Kader als auch wirtschaftlich. Denn du musst jetzt ja den UEFA-wirtschaftlichen Richtlinien gerecht werden. Da haben sie anscheinend, da sprechen sie auch ganz offen darüber. So ein Case-Wunst gab es eigentlich noch fast gar nicht, dass du vor zwei Jahren noch in der 2. Liga, jetzt Champions League. Also sie müssen nicht sofort alle wirtschaftlichen Parameter erfüllen, weil das ginge gar nicht. Die haben anscheinend so ein Zeitfenster von zwei, drei Jahren, wo sie jetzt schon ein bisschen quasi auch in Vorleistung gehen können. Aber was den Kader trifft, den sie melden müssen, da gibt es ganz klare Regeln. Und da gibt es Regeln, dass du gewisse Spieleranzahl aus der eigenen Jugend haben musst und eine gewisse, wie sagt man, nationale Spieler, also auch Spieler, die in der jeweiligen Nation fußballerisch ausgebildet wurden. Und ein Teil der Geschichte ist, dass Kormos so gut wie kein Italiener ist. In dieser Saison haben italienische Spieler gar keine Rolle gespielt. Das heißt, die müssen jetzt auf dem italienischen Transfermarkt tätig werden, allein um diese UEFA-Regularien zu bedienen. Und fairerweise muss man aber dazu sagen, die Academies, sie haben auch eine Jugendacademie, wo sie jetzt schon die letzten ein, zwei Jahren mit die talentiertesten Jungen, 2.8., 2.9. von Milan Juweta Lantar geholt haben. Also das läuft auch im Hintergrund, nur das wird ihnen jetzt halt im September noch nicht sozusagen den Hintern retten. Aber das ist schon auch Teil ihres Konzeptes, sie sagen, in zwei, drei Jahren wollen wir mit die talentiertesten Italiener hier auch mit rausbringen, aus unserer Akademie.
Ich meine, da kann man unsere Sendung hören, nach dem Nicht-Erreichen der WM Italiens, warum das vielleicht auch noch mal ein gutes Modell sein könnte, weil da eben andere noch hinterher hinken. Aber das ist eben sehr wichtig, was du gerade eben sagst. Sie haben Ausnahmeregelungen bekommen, aber eben nicht bei der Meldeliste. Und sie sind ganz, ganz weit über den Ausgaben, die sie hätten haben dürfen. Also was die UEFA angeht, sollten sie so 90 Millionen drüber sein, also die sie eigentlich rein theoretisch reinholen müssten. Und was die Squad-Cost-Kontroll angeht, da sind sie sogar 50 Millionen drüber. Was aber insgesamt irgendwie, also sie müssten 36 Prozent der jetzigen Personalkosten müssten sie quasi reduzieren, um erstmal wieder da drunter zu kommen. Also das ist eine riesige Aufgabe. Und was ich mich eben frage ist, also ich verstehe dieses Geschäftsmodell besser als ganz viele andere Geschäftsmodelle. Und ich finde es auch ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so schlimm wie andere Geschäftsmodelle, weil es basiert auf der Region, es basiert auf dem See. Ich meine, wenn man sich es auch mal überlegt, ist die Idee auch genial, weil der See, das Stadion am See und so weiter, das hat einfach, das hat ein irres Potenzial. Und man hat es eben nur nicht gesehen, weil eben Mailand immer alles überstrahlt. Trotzdem frage ich mich aber, wie attraktiv ist das in Jahr 4, 5 und 6, in dem du dann vielleicht zum dritten Mal Europa League spielst und eben dann doch nicht die größten Spieler bei dir spielen, weil du musst die dann auch immer wieder transferieren. Und ob das dann– also mir sind quasi die Farben, in denen die ihren Business-Case zeichnen, die sind ja logischerweise immer zu grell, müssen sie auch letztlich sein. Aber das ist– also ich rieche LinkedIn, wenn ich das lese, was da Komo hat. Und dann wäre eben meine Sorge, dass wir in zehn Jahren da stehen und sagen, die Idee war gut, aber sie war zu groß gedacht und irgendwann ist ihnen das aufgefallen. Und dann haben sie aber dasselbe Ding umgesetzt in der MLS oder wo auch immer. Das ist so ein bisschen meine Sorge, die ich habe.
Bin ich voll bei dir, deswegen habe ich es auch gesagt. Es ist wirklich der Sprech ist komplett Business Sprech, also wirklich durch und durch. Und schon ein interessanter Punkt, zum Beispiel, um noch mal jetzt zum Ende noch mal kurz sportlich zu werden. Du hast jetzt halt auch, du hast Nikko Pass von Real bekommen, den du nie bekommen hättest. Aber Real hat halt jetzt die Rückkaufklausel für neun Millionen Euro. Nochmal neun Millionen Euro über einen Spieler, der also, ich hab Berichte gehört, schon vergangenen Jahr aus England kamen da schon Richtung Kormor 60, 70 Millionen Angebote. Sagen die halt einfach nein, weil die das nicht interessiert, aber Real legt jetzt einfach diese neun Millionen Euro hin und dann ist Nikko Pass wieder bei Real. Also, das nur, um zu sagen, sie hoffen logischerweise noch, dass sie Real noch mal davon überzeugen können, ihn vielleicht jetzt für die Champions League auch noch mal dazulassen. Aber der letzte Punkt, worauf ich hinaus wollte, der voll bei dir anknüpft, Max, ist, die Spieler, ich habe mir die Spielergehälter mal angeschaut. Und dadurch, dass du sehr viele junge Spieler hast, sind die auch noch sehr gering. Also, wenn das stimmt, ich habe gesehen Jakob Aramon, der von Real, der Innenverteidiger, für mich, ich habe ihn in die Top-Eff der Serie A-Saison gewählt, weil der, der steht so für all dieses Moderne, was Fabregas mitbringt. Superspieleröffnung, körperlich stark, torgefährlich, super Innenverteidiger. Ich glaube, der war vielleicht sogar noch von Real am nächsten, am spanischen WM-Kader, wirklich. Der überragende Sohn, der verdient anscheinend 200.000 Euro da, weil der logischerweise erst mal aus der Real Jugend kam. Ja, lange hältst du den nicht bei 200.000 Euro. Da ist ja ganz klar, müssen wir nicht drüber reden. Und solche Spieler werden jetzt sehr mehrere kommen. Und dann bin ich voll bei dir. Bin ich gespannt, wie sie das wirklich ausbalancieren können, weil wirtschaftlich sind die jetzt schon erstmal in Minus gegangen, was du ja schon erstmal aufholen musst.
Also ohne einen Trick geht das eigentlich. Weil die haben für die Saison 2024, 2025, haben sie Matchday-Einnahmen von insgesamt 6 Millionen Euro. Sie haben Commercial-Einnahmen, also Sponsoren und Werbung, Bandenwerbung, haben sie 11 Millionen Euro. Also das muss so sein, dass dann irgendwann das Unternehmen der Indonesia bei denen auf der Brust steht und ihnen völlig überraschend 80 Millionen Euro für das Trikot-Sponsoring zahlt. Und dann ist es genauso schäbig wie alles andere, wie alles andere, absolut. Ja, aber ich finde es schön, dass wir hier mal tiefer reingegangen sind. Das hat mich ehrlich gesagt immer so ein bisschen gewundert, dass das ist das nicht so anders, wo es auch schon häufiger gab. Jetzt in den letzten Wochen, glaube ich, ich habe die 11-Freunde-Story zum Beispiel dazu noch nicht gelesen, aber ich vermute, da steht wahrscheinlich auch manches von dem dringend, was wir hier erzählt haben. Aber eigentlich lag es ja so auf der Hand, mal da genauer hinzugucken, was machen die da eigentlich. Schön, dass wir es mal gemacht haben. Ach, Christian, auf dich ist einfach immer Verlass. Sehr, sehr gut. Jakob, du hast genau zugehört, hast dir Notizen gemacht, was quasi das nächste Geschäftsmodell in der Liga sein könnte. Aber hast du uns denn noch ein Thema mitgebracht?
Ich hatte es ja schon gesagt, dass es bei Le Mans tatsächlich so ein bisschen vergleichbar ist. Also wir haben es dann ja jetzt in der nächsten Saison. Können wir ja schauen, ob es anstelle des Sees auch mit einer Rennstrecke funktioniert in der Nähe.
Ja, wobei ich schon sagen muss, es ist halt interessant. Also dieser Rexam-Effekt, der bedeutet ja quasi ein Fokus auf Content-Kreation, auf Inhalte, die du machst und aber eben da ist dieser Hollywood-Aspekt mit drin. Und ich finde das schon witzig, dass das jetzt quasi kopiert wird. Und ich frage mich aber, wie lange das wirklich tragen kann. Weil ich finde das jetzt auch lustig, dass da Philippe Massa mit drin hängt. Aber wenn ich 3-mal ein Bild von ihm auf der Tribüne gesehen habe, ist es mir ehrlich gesagt auch völlig egal. Weil ansonsten ist mir nämlich auch immer egal, wer auf der Tribüne sitzt. Es ist halt nur witzig. Es passt halt nicht so. Und bei Wrexham ist ja quasi die Verbindung und die Art und Weise, wie die sich auch… Also, die waren quasi schon sehr tief drin, dann quasi auch im Sportlichen. Und deswegen gab es da immer diese Verknüpfung. Und die sehe ich halt bei Leomord jetzt einfach von außen, ohne dass ich mich viel damit beschäftigt hätte. Gar nicht. Und bei Como, ehrlicherweise ob da Thierry Ory im Stadion sitzt, letztlich interessiert es mich in der nächsten Saison auch nicht mehr, wenn der dann eingeblendet wird. Oder George Clooney, der aus der Villa rübergefahren ist. Also das allein wird nicht reichen.
Ja, und selbst wenn man so einen Doku-Ansatz oder so, wie es ja bei LeMond zumindest auch immer mal wieder debattiert wird, ob man das nicht machen sollte, ist es halt auch irgendwie, es ist dann halt auch nicht mehr so das Original. Denn also wir hatten ja vorhin über Sunderland Till I Die gesprochen. Das war so die große Offenbarung der Fußball-Dokus im neueren Rahmen. Dann Welcome to Wrexham ja schon auch sehr erfolgreich, gerade auf den amerikanischen Markt. Da war jetzt die x der Doku über irgendein Verein. Das hat sich dann ja auch irgendwann ausgelutscht.
Ja, das ist wahr. Also wer guckt das alles noch? Und ich meine, Spieler und Trainer werden dran gewöhnt, dass Kameras überall sind. Das ist vielleicht so der Effekt, den man hat, dass da irgendwann nicht mehr so drüber geredet wird. Aber auch, was die damals, also jede Wrexham-Folge, so ich glaube 1,5 Millionen Dollar an Produktionskosten gehabt haben, zumindest so runtergerechnet. Das ist auch ein irrer Produktionsaufwand, der ja inzwischen eigentlich nirgendwo sonst mehr betrieben wird. Also wenn du dir anguckst, wie das Geld runtergeht bei Netflix und anderen Anbietern, die eben solche Dokus produzieren. Oder guck dir die Sommermärchen-Doku vom ZDF an. Wird überall gefeiert. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung warum, aber ist halt einfach so, ist halt wahrscheinlich ein nostalgisches Thema. Aber soll anknüpfen an FC Hollywood, wo sie richtig reingebuttert haben, wo die BTF auch wirklich so Standards gesetzt hat, was quasi so kreative Umsetzung eines Themas angeht. Die Sommermärchen-Doku ist schon 20 Prozent weniger gut. In allen Aspekten. Und die wird noch gefeiert, aber wenn jetzt die dritte Doku dann kommt, die die BTF mit dem ZDF produziert, werden sie auch machen. Und das geht gar nicht gegen BTF, geht auch nicht gegen ZDF, aber es hat einfach einen Abnutzungseffekt. Und das wirst du bei diesen Dokus auch sehen. Und dann ist halt Le Mans doch nur Le Mans. Muss man ehrlich sagen. Vielleicht bin ich bei Koma da positiver, weil halt, ja, der Koma See, das ist halt, wenn du in München wohnst, da hast du einen Bezug zu. Du kennst Leute, die da waren. Du kennst auch die Bilder. Es ist halt ein bisschen ikonischer vielleicht noch. Wobei, da tue ich gerade Rennstrecke schon ganz schön unrecht, merke ich. Naja, bevor ich mich hier weiter reinreite. Jakob, worüber wolltest du denn eigentlich noch sprechen?
Eigentlich wollte ich natürlich nochmal über das Gesamtkunstwerk der Saison von Olympique Marseille sprechen. Denn wir hatten es ja immer wieder in Teilen angesprochen. Aber ich glaube, es lohnt sich schon über diese Chaos-Saison nochmal so den Gesamtbogen zu spannen.
Vom wunderschönen See über die Rennstrecke kommen wir zur brennenden Müllkippe.
Ja, oder zumindest ins Auge des brodelnden Vulkans, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe es jetzt natürlich nur metaphorisch gemeint. Also ich wollte es nicht gerade Marseille als Müllkippe bezeichnen. Das ist wohl hoffentlich klar. Also ja, zeichne uns dieses Gesamtkunstwerk nochmal.
Genau, denn es ist ja schon auch in den letzten Jahrzehnten, und es ist ja weitaus bekannt, dass Marseille so das, also eigentlich also mit der größte Verein in Frankreich ist, was die positiven Stimmungen angeht, aber halt auch was das Negative angeht. Ich finde aber schon, dass man in dieser Saison auch den ganzen, also zumindest einen sehr extremen Ausschlag hatte ins Negative, denn wir haben ja drüber gesprochen ganz zu Beginn der Saison, dass es schon nach dem ersten Spieltag die Kabinenprügerei gab zwischen Jonathan Rowe und Adrian Rabiot, wo dann im Anschluss daran auch beide gegangen sind, gerade bei Rabiot ja als Schlüsselspieler und Wortführer und verlängert im Arm von Roberto de Zerbi auch ein riesiger sportlicher Verlust. Und dann sah es ja zwischenzeitlich wochenlang so aus, als würde trotzdem die Saison ganz gut laufen. Man stand ja bis in den Herbst auch noch paar Mann immer so mit dabei. Es gab so eine Art Dreikampf zuerst zwischen PSG und Lens und eben Marseille. Und man dachte, vielleicht kann man sogar ins Titelrelimm eingreifen. Und so richtig bitter wurde es eigentlich erst zu Jahresbeginn 2026. Man hat erst die in der Trophäde Champagne, also dem französischen Superpokal, ist jetzt an sich gar nicht so bedeutsam. Aber eben im Kontext, dass Marseille jetzt schon seit über zehn Jahren auf überhaupt irgendeinen Titel wartet, war es dann doch für den Verein an sich sehr wichtig, dass man gegen PSG eigentlich geführt hat und dann völlig unnötig sich in der Nachspielzeit ein Konter gefangen hat, also nur noch ein paar Sekunden vor Schluss. Also auch wirklich total unbegreiflich, wenn man sich das Tor nochmal anguckt, in der Art und Weise, sich auskontern zu lassen. Und so hat man dann da mal wieder ein Titel verspielt. Kurz danach ist man dann in der Champions League ausgeschieden, ja auch im Zusammenhang mit dem Torwarttor von Anatoly Trubin. Da war letztendlich Marseille der leidtragende Verein, weil sie eben dadurch und aufgrund der eigenen 0-3-Blamage gegen Brügge ausgeschieden sind. Obwohl sie eigentlich vor dem Spieltag, hatten sie glaube ich eine 0,5% Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie es nicht in die Playoffs schaffen. Aber sie haben es dann natürlich doch geschafft. Kurz danach dann die Entlassung von Roberto de Serbi, hatten wir ja auch viel drüber gesprochen. Christian, gerade du hattest ja auch viel dazu geäußert, dass de Serbi weiterhin natürlich eigentlich ein super Trainer ist und so ein bisschen ein Opfer der Umstände auch geworden ist. Diese Entlassung von de Serbi hat ja auch Chaos ausgelöst. Dann ist erst Mehdi Benassia zurückgetreten als Sportdirektor, weil er das eigentlich nicht cool fand, ist dann ein paar Tage später doch geblieben. Hatte dann mit dem Präsidenten und Eigentümer, nee, mit dem Eigentümer Frank McCourt ausgehandelt, dass er mehr Macht bekommt, was de facto die Entmachtung des Präsidenten Pablo Longoria bedeutet hat, der wiederum dann ja zurücktreten wollte. Das hat erst, hat er das noch nicht so richtig gemacht. Am Anschluss ist er dann aber doch gegangen. Und Benassia hatte aber auch direkt gesagt, dass er eigentlich nur bis Sommer bleiben will. Das heißt, er ist jetzt auch weg in der Sommerpause. Man hat dann mit Abi Bay einen neuen Trainer geholt, der ja zuvor bei Rennen entlassen wurde. Unter ihm lief es sportlich total schlecht. Er hat einen der schlechtesten Punkteschnitte in der Geschichte des Vereins. Hat es geschafft, Marseille aus dem Champions League-Rennen so weit. Also natürlich ist auch er logischerweise nicht allein dafür verantwortlich. So will ich es gar nicht darstellen. Aber es wurde halt alles eher schlechter auf dem Platz unter ihm. So dass Marseille am letzten Spieltag sogar theoretisch noch bis auf Platz 7 hätte abrutschen können. Sie haben dann zwar gegen Stadtrännen gewonnen und sind jetzt am Ende Fünfter geworden, haben aber halt die Champions League verpasst. Was auch gerade aufgrund der ganzen finanziellen Situation in Frankreich im generellen, aber auch im speziellen von Marseille durchaus von Bedeutung ist. Weil wir wissen alle, der Unterschied zwischen Europa League und Champions League finanziell sind das Welten und Marseille hat sowieso große finanzielle Probleme, wird jetzt im Sommer wahrscheinlich viele Spieler verkaufen müssen, was generell auch ein Problem ist. Denn wir hatten es auch schon mal gesagt, es sind allein in dieser Saison fast 40 Kaderbewegungen gewesen im Sommer und im Winter. Also es ist ein reines Hin und Her. Ganz viele der entscheidenden Spieler stehen vor einer ungewissen Zukunft bei allem, was wir ja auch schon häufig angesprochen haben. Zum Beispiel Mason Greenwood soll eigentlich auch gehen, der ja sportlich zumindest einer der Besten auch in dieser Saison war, auch wenn er immer wieder Spiele hat, wo er sich Auszeiten nimmt. Aber halt auch alles andere hat nicht großartig funktioniert. Es gab dann zum Saisonende hin auch noch mehr Baustellen. Also es gab erst Trainingslager in Spanien. Das hatte man in der letzten Saison auch schon, wo man unter de Serbi mehrere Wochen lang sein Camp in Italien aufgezogen hatte und dann immer nur für die Spiele zurück nach Frankreich gereist ist. Ganz so extrem war es in dieser Saison nicht. Man war dann in Spanien und kurz vor den letzten Spielen hat der Abi Bey dann gesagt, dass die Spieler alle auf dem Trainingsgelände schlafen müssen. Also über mehrere Tage lang, was ja auch im Kontext vom Fußball vielleicht auf den allerersten Blick sich gar nicht so absurd anhört. Aber wenn man mal drüber nachdenkt, dass es den Spielern, obwohl sie in der Stadt sind, verboten wird, zu ihrer Familie zu rückzukehren abends und so. Ich kann mir schon auch vorstellen, dass das für die Stimmung, gerade wenn es nicht so gut läuft, auch nicht unbedingt so eine Superlösung ist. Und dann haben die Spieler…
Ich mag deine Diplomatie.
Sorry, das ist die Einschüchterungsmethode in Italien. In Italien gibt es einen Begriff dafür, Rettiro. Also du ziehst die Mannschaft zusammen. Und das ist das, wo ganz… In der thälenischen Kultur ist das so veranlagt. Deswegen, logisch, hat das der Zerbi auch so gemacht. Das so, wenn du weißt, wenn eine Mannschaft in Rettiro geholt wird, dann weißt du, dass das oben kurz vorm Explodieren ist. Dann probieren die halt nochmal alles zu sagen. Jetzt komm, wir müssen zusammen sein. Keine Ablenkung zu Hause. Geht logischerweise oft auch schief. Gar keine Frage.
Genauso ist es dann hier nämlich auch gekommen. Es wurde dann Donnerstag bekannt. Okay, Freitag dürft ihr alle nach Hause. Dann haben sich einige Spieler gedacht, okay, dann machen wir Donnerstagabend eine Riesen-Fete auf dem Feeningsgelände unter Führung von Pierre-Emerick Aubameyang. Der ja vielleicht so als Routinier einer der, ja, vernünftigen Spieler sein könnte, ist man dann mit einem Feuerlöscher in den Funktionärstrakt eingebrochen oder eingedrungen. Hat dann den einzigen, der da übernachtet hat, mit einem Feuerlöscher besprüht und so, dass dann Aubameyang zum Beispiel auch fürs Wochenende suspendiert wurde. Also, es hat dann auch das nächste absolute Highlight natürlich gegeben. Ja, man hat jetzt zwar sportlich die Saison zu einem halbwegs vernünftigen Ende gebracht, aber steht jetzt halt trotzdem vor einem absoluten Scherbenhaufen, auch wenn man sich jetzt noch für die Europa League qualifiziert hat. Denn Abi Bay, es gibt jetzt noch keine offiziellen Meldungen, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der über die Saison bleibt. Dafür war das viel zu schlecht, abgesehen davon, dass er auch immer im Zusammenspiel mit den Medien ein bisschen, ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man es genau beschreiben kann, vielleicht unglücklich. Von vielen wird er als arrogant bezeichnet. Er hat jetzt auch sich drüber beschwert, dass im Zusammenhang mit ihm immer nur von ihm gesprochen würde. Und bei allen anderen Trainern wäre immer davor noch, dass sie Trainer von dem und dem Verein wären. Er selbst würde immer nur als Abib Bey an sich bezeichnet werden. Was bei ihm ganz interessant ist, dass er eigentlich vorher in den Medien ein sehr geschätzter Experte war, bevor er als Trainer tätig war. Aber ich kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass er eine Zukunft hat. Es gibt jetzt einen neuen Präsidenten. Aber es ist halt, wie ich schon gesagt habe, sportlich. Welche Spieler noch da sind, wer da überhaupt Bock drauf hat. Es war schon auch so, dass viele Spieler hauptsächlich auch wegen der Serbier gekommen sind, weil er halt gerade auch in den Experten oder Spielerkreisen dann sehr geschätzt ist und sie unter ihm spielen wollten. Inwieweit Marseille jetzt noch wirklich gute Spieler ziehen wird. In diesem Sommer zeigt sich dann, wird sich dann auch zeigen. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es da weitergeht.
Klingt nach einem Doku-Thema.
Ja, da wird ein Doku, ja das ist ja genauso wie Release the Windhorst, härter Doku. Es gibt ja die Dokus, die gut sein könnten, aber dann trauen sie sich nicht sehr raus zu hauen.
Ja tatsächlich sollen auch bei Marseille Kameras mitgelaufen sein in dieser Saison. Also ich bin aber auch nicht ganz so sicher, was davon jetzt tatsächlich den Weg an die Öffentlichkeit finden wird.
Aber Rabiot und Ro müssen noch die Freigabe teilen, oder?
Ja, und dann ist sie ja auch ab 18, wahrscheinlich.
Das mit der Feier in dem Trainingslager, nenne ich es jetzt mal, das hatte ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Aber ehrlich gesagt zeigt einem ja das auch wieder. Das sind alles talentierte Fußballer und die haben ganz viel in ihrem Leben geopfert, um eben diesen Leistungssport zu auszuüben. Aber man sollte die nicht idolisieren. Vielleicht sollte man auch nicht erwarten, dass die eine ähnliche politische Haltung oder andere haben. Da spreche ich jetzt auch in meine Richtung, weil ich da selber ja manchmal enttäuscht bin, wenn die dann den Mund aufmachen und dann kommt da nur Quatsch raus mit allem, was nicht mit Fußball zu tun hat. Aber das zeigt es ja nochmal. Das ist ja so eine Geschichte. Also ja, bei uns auf Klassenfahrt gab es das auch mal. Aber ich hatte es nicht mitbekommen. Und es ist ja auch irgendwie schwierig, Jakob, denn wir wollen ja eigentlich gar nicht so sehr über so boulevardeske Themen sprechen. Es hat ja mit Sportlichen gar nichts mehr zu tun. Aber bei so etwas wie Marseille, was ja quasi so ein Zusammenkommen von vielen solchen Ereignissen ist, da kann man ja das Sportliche nicht mehr davon trennen. Dann muss man auch drüber reden.
Ja, total. Also es führt ja auch bei Marseille seit Jahren schon zu Problemen. Also wir hatten ja vorher, hatte ja Fabian über Marcelinho gesprochen. Der war ja auch mal bei Marseille Trainer, ist dann aber gegangen, weil er auf diesen ganzen Quatsch keinen Bock mehr hatte. Also der war ja auch gar nicht so unerfolgreich da, aber wurde dann auch von den Fans angefeindet und die Unruhen in der Klubführung. Und dann hat er halt, wie wir auch angesprochen haben, hat er da halt keinen Bock drauf und sagt dann, okay, nein, tschüss.
Ach, Wahnsinn. Aber es wird nicht spannend werden, nicht langweilig werden in der nächsten Saison auch mit Olympique. Das ist schon wirklich krass. Ja, ihr zwei, ich weiß nicht, habt ihr noch irgendwelche Themen, die offen sind? Wir sind ja jetzt völlig frei. Wir können machen, was wir wollen. Ich weiß nicht, Christian, hast du noch irgendwas kurzes Kleines aus der Serie A oder noch irgendwas auf dem Zettel?
Ja, hätte ich schon ein ganz kurzes Ding. Jetzt haben wir aus Serie A sich so viel über Probleme gesprochen, müssen wir schon nochmal kurz interhuldigen, nicht nur eben als Meister, sondern auch als Dubelsieger. Haben wir ja, glaube ich, schon mal in einer der letzten Folgen. Ich würde vielleicht nur nochmal explizit auf Kivo eingehen, Christian Kivo, der ja also kurz, wie ging die Saison von Inter los? Die ging so los, dass Inter vergangenen Mai alles verloren hat, was sie bis zum Schluss hätten gewinnen können, nämlich Champions League, Liga und Pokal. Die stehen da mit leeren Händen, da müssen dann zur Club-WM in die USA. Also ich bin mir sicher, der Verein hat sich gefreut, weil da kam ordentlich Geld rein, aber ich bin mir sicher, kein einziger Inter-Spieler hatte Lust, in diesen Flieger zu steigen nach diesen ganzen sportlichen Enttäuschungen. Und da kam aber KiWu eben rein, der ja der überraschende Nachfolger von Simone Nsagi wurde. Und ich habe es damals schon gesagt, ich glaube, diese Club-WM war das Beste, was KiWu unter der Mannschaft passieren konnte, weil da konnten die den Frust rauslassen, er konnte sie kennenlernen, ein bisschen unter Wettkampfbedingungen, also nicht nur hier ein bisschen Trainingsspiel hier, Trainingsspiel dort. Dann gab es ja auch diese ein, zwei, vielleicht erinnern sich noch ein paar diese Interviews, wo Lautaro sich hinstellt und sagt, wer keinen Bock hat, soll gehen. So quasi öffentlich anfängt, mit Giorgiannolo zu streiten, weil bei dem hieß es ja womöglich Kalataserei. Also da hat man wirklich so das Gefühl, das ganze Ding kann auseinanderfliegen. Aber ich würde sagen, da ist so die Energie entstanden, da hat Kibo verstanden, okay, Frust weg. Und jetzt fahrt ihr alle in den Urlaub und dann fangen wir an. Und dann muss man sagen, hat das wirklich funktioniert mit einem Trainer, der, bevor er jetzt Inter übernommen hat, 13 Serie-A-Profi-Spiele hatte und gewinnt halt einfach in seiner ersten Saison das Tubel. Hatten wir Champions League logischerweise sehr enttäuschend, gar keine Frage. Aber meist gleich das Tubel zu holen, was bis jetzt nur Mourinho auf dem Platz bei Inter gelungen ist, ist logisch als großes Kino. Und Kibo steht halt auch ein bisschen für diese Generation, neuer Trainer, junger Trainer. Ich glaube, das Zitat hatte ich auch schon beim letzten Mal von ihm, wo er sagt, es gewinnt mittlerweile nicht mehr die beste Abwehrmeisterschaft seiner Meinung nach. Der Fußball hat sich verändert, die Offensive macht es aus. Und Inter hat eben, wenn man alle Top-5-Ligen vergleicht, nur die Bayern und Barca hatten einen besseren Offensivtorschritt als Inter. Also kein Engländer, auch nicht PSG in der französischen Liga. Also da hat Kibo schon einiges im ersten Jahr bewegt. Und deswegen bin ich gespannt, wie es da, wie Inter darauf aufbaut mit Kibo.
Ja, sehr, sehr gut, Christian, dass wir da noch mal über ihn gesprochen haben. Er lief immer so mit, aber sich das nochmal so vor Augen zu führen, was das eigentlich für eine Saison von ihm war. Absolut angemessen. Jakob, hast du noch was aus der Liga?
Ich habe noch ein positives Thema, aus dem ich dann noch auf die Trainer-Thematik überleiten könnte. Also erstmal geht es um vier Vereine, die die Klasse gehalten haben. Wir haben ja vorhin darüber gesprochen, dass mit NHTSA ein Riesenteam fast abgestiegen wäre. Mit Nantes hat es ja eins der zumindest traditionsreichesten Teams auch erwischt, die dann direkt runtergegangen sind, auch mit unschönen Szenen, Platzsturm während des Spiels, sodass am 34. Spieltag das Spiel gar nicht zu Ende gebracht werden konnte. Aber da muss man auch schauen. Und mess halt das JoJo-Team der Liga, hatten wir auch in der letzten Folge schon gesagt. Aber die vier Teams, die den Klassenheit geschafft haben, sind mit Angé, Le Havre und Auxerre, die auf den Plätzen 13, 14 und 15. Alle drei vereint, dass sie sehr wenig Mittel haben. Das sind drei der besten Beispiele dafür, was ich vorhin angesprochen hatte, dass manche Teams einfach keine Ablösesummen zahlen können. Und was alle drei auch vereint ist, dass sie die Saison über an ihren Trainern festgehalten haben. Über Angé hatten wir ja zwischenzeitlich sogar als Positiv-Überraschung gesprochen, die ja so ein riesiges Hoch hatten. In der Jahresmitte, man muss sagen, davon haben sie jetzt auch sehr gezehrt. Also wenn das die Saison noch ein paar Spieltage länger gegangen wäre, wären die, glaube ich, abgestiegen, weil die haben jetzt auch deutlich abgebaut zum Ende hin. Ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen die Frage, ob einfach dann auch ein bisschen die Luft raus war vielleicht. Bei Le Havre und Auxerre ging es jetzt bis zum Ende. Auxerre hat sich ja jetzt auch erst am vorletzten Spieltag vom Relegationsplatz hochgeschoben. Davor waren sie auch ganz, ganz lange auf den letzten beiden Plätzen. Also da eine richtig starke Rettung. Da hatten wir auch schon mal drüber gesprochen. Die haben ja stark unterperformt. Aber man hat halt an Trainer Christophe Pellissier festgehalten und wurde letztendlich belohnt. Le Havre ist so ein bisschen die, ja, so eine Festung in der Ligue 1 gewesen, haben auch nur 44 Gegentore kassiert. Also beispielsweise weniger als Marseille und Rennes, die auf den Plätzen 5 und 6 gelandet sind. Also eine richtig starke Abwehr. Didier Degas hat da ein wahnsinnig schwer zu schlagenes Team geformt. Sie haben auch 14 Mal unentschieden gespielt. Also auch damit sich dann letztendlich in der Liga gehalten. Das positivste Team, das aber auch wenig Mittel hat, ist Lorient. Die gehören zwar wie Bournemouth zu der Black Knight Group, haben aber trotzdem nicht sonderlich viel eingekauft vor der Saison. Sie haben zum Beispiel auch Krupi, der bei Bournemouth jetzt richtig gut war. Der war letzte Saison Torschützenkönig für Lorient in der Ligue 2. Sie haben da also ihren besten Angreifer verloren. Die hatten eigentlich die ganze Saison über keinerlei Abstiegssorgen unter Olivier Pantaloni. Obwohl die auch gar nicht so gut gestartet sind, dann aber im Herbst eine richtig gute Serie hingelegt haben, insgesamt nur dreimal zu Hause verloren. Also da vor allem das heimische Stadion zur Festung gemacht. Konnten zwischenzeitlich sogar ein bisschen auf Europa hoffen, aber hatten halt die ganze Saison keine Abstiegssorgen, obwohl sie vor der Saison so mit als einer der Top-Kandidaten auch auf den Abstieg galten. Und diese vier Teams auf jeden Fall dann vor allem halt ohne den Trainerwechsel, was es ansonsten bei den anderen Teams sehr, sehr viel gab, ist das sehr positiv, dass die dann alle den Klassenerg geschafft haben.
Aber wirklich. Gut, Paris hat das Aufsteiger auch geschafft, aber mit anderen Mitteln.
Genau, da hatten wir ja schon drüber gesprochen. Aber wie man da jetzt überleiten kann, soll ich das letzte Thema direkt anhängen?
Sehr gerne.
Gut, das ist nämlich die Trainer-Debatte. Denn es gab allein während der Saison extrem viele Trainerwechsel. Und auch jetzt im Sommer wird es ganz, ganz viele geben. Also es könnte bis zu zehn Veränderungen auf den Trainerpositionen geben. Das wäre auch Rekord in der Liga. Und da ist unter anderem mit Auxerre auch ein Beispiel, wo es auf völliges Unverständnis stößt. Also da ist ein chinesischer Besitzer, der jetzt nach der Saison gesagt hat, ok, Christophe Pellissier, du hast uns zwar jetzt hier die Klasse gehalten, aber geh doch bitte trotzdem. Es soll auch mit Will Still, der Nachfolger, schon unterschrieben haben. Allerdings hat der Clubpräsident jetzt setzt sich vehement dafür ein, dass Pellissier doch bitte bleiben solle. Und ist jetzt auch nochmal in Kontakt getreten mit dem chinesischen Eigentümer. Muss man mal schauen, was sich daraus entwickelt. Ob man vielleicht eine Doppelspitze macht in der nächsten Saison, ist natürlich völliger Quatsch, aber... Also es gibt halt auch gar keinen Grund, warum die Fans sind, waren völlig schockiert davon. Gerade weil sie jetzt auch in den letzten Wochen, also ich hatte es glaube ich ja angesprochen, die waren, sind seit Februar, haben sie glaube ich nur ein Spiel verloren oder so in der Liga, also sind wahnsinnig gut in Form. Total unverständlich und tatsächlich ist die Trainer-Fluktuation wirklich extrem. Ich habe mal nachgeschaut, es sind nur bei PSG, bei Lyon und Lens kann man sicher sein, dass noch der Trainer auf der Bank sitzt, der zu Saisonbeginn da war. Also es ist momentan noch offen. Bei Le Havre läuft der Vertrag von Didier Degard aus. Er hat sich jetzt auch noch nicht fest dazu bekannt, dass er bleiben will. Und bei Stade Brest und Angers haben die Trainer theoretisch noch Vertrag. Es steht aber nicht fest, dass sie wirklich bleiben. Und ansonsten haben alle Teams unter der Saison den Trainer gewechselt oder werden jetzt im Sommer den Trainer wechseln. Also da wird es einen riesigen Umbruch geben.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Jakob, als könntest du Gedanken lesen, weil das wollte ich auch nochmal aufgreifen. Da kann ich dich jetzt nämlich gleich anschließen. Ich habe nämlich ein paar Nummern da, Statistiken. In Italien, in der Serie A, ist ein Trainer im Schnitt 11 Monate im Amt.
Krass, unter einem Jahr sogar nur.
Genau. Ich habe eben nämlich die anderen Ligen auch zum Vergleich. Also, danach kommt die Ligue 1 anscheinend mit 17 Monaten im Schnitt. Also, sind wir bei 1,5. Dann kommt angeblich die Bundesliga mit 23, also knapp zwei Jahren. Dann kommt die Premier League mit 28 und La Liga mit 29 Monaten. Jetzt bei der Premier League, alle anderen habe ich jetzt nicht, würde ich mal sagen, verwässern Guardiola und Arteta stark. Das Ganze, weil er redet einmal über zehn Jahre und einmal über sieben Jahre. Also, ich glaube, das müsste man nochmal rausrechnen. Aber wie gesagt, die Serie A ist mit elf Monaten da halt wirklich mit Abstand am unteren Ende. Und da kann ich nur nahtlos anknüpfen, Jakob, es geht jetzt so weiter. Milan, neuer Trainer. Napoli, Antonio Conte hat sich verabschiedet. Zwei im Guten, also wirklich alles sehr schöne Verabschiedung. Jetzt mit Napoli, kein Auseinandergehen im Streit. Napoli, neuer Trainer. Vincenzo Italiano hat sich von Bologna verabschiedet. Atalanta bekommt mit Sarri einen neuen Trainer. Die Fiorentina wird einen neuen Trainer bekommen. Sassuolo, das sind jetzt nur die ersten 6, 7, die mir da einfallen. Also, dieses Thema Trainer-Fluktuation ist in der Serie A schon ein sehr großes, weil wir da halt, ja, oft dann, hat man hier schon oft genug, logischerweise an Punkte kommen, wo du dann halt immer wieder bei Null beginnst und es schwierig ist, logischerweise was Nachhaltiges aufzubauen. Ich muss sagen, ich war wirklich auch überrascht, dass die Statistik da bei der Serie A so massiv gegen die Serie A spricht. Also, 11 Monate ist schon, ja, wow. Also, ich glaube, da gibt es wenig Gegenargumente. Ja, da muss ich schon, glaube ich, muss schon ein Umdenken stattfinden, ganz klar.
Ich kann für die Bundesliga noch sagen, die Bereinigte, die um Christian Streich und Frank Schmidt bereinigte Langliste anderthalb Jahre. Also, man spricht immer so von 18 Monaten.
Das ist das, was ich in der Serie gekriegt habe. 18 Monate mehr, auf Serie A-Verhältnisse auch noch mal einiges mehr. Also, ja, ist schon Thema und passt vielleicht da. Deswegen wollte ich es anknüpfen noch. Gasperini zum Beispiel, um nochmal was Positives zu bringen. Gasperini war jetzt acht Jahre bei Atalanta, macht jetzt den Schritt, kommt zur Roma und bringt die Roma in die Champions League zurück. Das wollte ich schon nämlich auch nochmal erwähnen, denn die Roma war sieben Jahre nicht in der Champions League. Also, für die Roma war das jetzt wirklich auch, wir wissen, wer bei der Roma in der jüngeren Vergangenheit war. Da waren Morinius und so, also da waren große Namen. Und Gasperini hat es wirklich geschafft, bei diesem Machtkampf mit Ranieri für sich zu entscheiden, hatten wir ja, und ab da haben wir jedes Spiel nur noch gewonnen. Also, es hat anscheinend auch diese interne Kraft, die freigesetzt wurde, als klar war, dass der Klub komplett hinter Gasperini steht. Und ich kann euch wirklich nur ans Herz legen, ich freue mich so mega drauf, also die Atmosphäre im Olympico. Hört gerne mal die letzten Minuten vor Anpfiff bei der Roma rein. Es ist sensationell, was da im Stadion ist, wenn da die zwei römischen Leader gespielt werden. Wenn die das jetzt wieder in der Champions League aufführen können, das ist sehr grosses Kino. Also, das wird sehr emotional, dass die Roma da zurück ist. Und da eine Name, in dem wir da reinigen müssen, ist logisch Donjan Malden, weil der kam im Winter und schließt jetzt die Torschützen auf der Torschüttensliste auf Platz 3 ab mit 14 Puden. Der hat seit dem Winter 14 Puden gemacht. Ich habe sogar die Statistik, anscheinend vor dem letzten Bundesligaspieltag, er korrigiert mich gerne, glaube ich, als Kane noch mal ein Head-Wag gemacht hat, oder? Vor dem letzten Bundesspieltag hatten Malen gleich viele Tore in der Rückrunde oder in dem Zeitraum wie Harry Kane. Also, Malen war genau das, was Gasperini gebraucht hat. Er hat immer gesagt, bringt mir Stürmer, bringt mir Stürmer, Ludolf Bek war kaputt, Stibala war kaputt, Suley war monatelang kaputt. Malen, er und Malen nahmen die Roma in die Champions League zurück.
Und du hast aber vorhin gesagt, sieben Jahre. Es ist dieses Spiel, wo Roma gegen Barca das 0 zu 3 aus dem Hinspiel aufgeholt haben, im Rückspiel. Ist das schon sieben Jahre her?
Das muss, genau. Oder es war sogar, war das sogar 2017, 2018, das legendäre eben da, als Manolas dann das entscheidende Tor macht gegen Barca. Genau, wo ja bei Real.
Ja, das war tatsächlich im April 2018.
Genau. Ja, ja. Und wer war damals noch Trainer? Eusebio Di Francesco. Der jetzt, da schließt sich jetzt der Kreis, der sich jetzt am letzten Spieltag mit Lecce gerettet hat. Und dann muss ich sagen, das sind sehr viele in Italien, die haben es unfassbar gegönnt, weil der ist in den letzten zwei Spielzeiten jeweils am letzten Spieltag mit Venezia und Frosinone abgestiegen. Der hatte so den Limpus, okay, du holst Frosinone, halt du holst Di Francesco, der macht es gut, aber am Ende geht er runter. Und jetzt hat er sich am letzten Spieltag mit Lecce gerettet. Und da schließt sich der Kreis. Genau, Max. Das war der letzte Champions League-Trainer der Roma.
Das ist sehr witzig.
Sehr lang her. Ja, deswegen schön, dass die Roma wieder zurück ist.
Und dann muss ich, wenn wir jetzt beim Trainer-Thema sind, aber dann muss ich noch ganz kurz den rasenfunkartigsten Witz machen, den mir Donato auf Instagram geschrieben hat. Mir selbst wäre es gar nicht aufgefallen. Aber es ist natürlich wunderschön, dass Bologna den Trainer Italiano verliert und vermutlich durch den Trainer Tedesco ersetzt.
Ach ja, das hatte ich so nicht auf dem Schirm.
Wunderbar.
Sehr gut. Und mein wirklich auch allerletzter Satz dazu, weil es ist mir schon ein Anliegen, nochmal zu sagen, ich bin ja der, der gerne die Serie A hervorhebt und lobt auch für viele Sachen. In der Saison, muss man logischerweise sagen, ist italienische Fußball angefangen, logisch von der dritten verpassten WM-Teilnahme bis hin über eine sehr schwache europäische Saison. Also Napoli als Meister, schon in der Gruppenphase, in der Champions League raus, Inter gegen Böder, Juve im K.o.-Phase. Also dieses Jahr ist italienische Fußball generell schon sehr, sehr viel schuldig geblieben. Also da müssen sie nächstes Jahr definitiv wieder was drauf packen, weil das war im Vergleich zu den Jahren davor, wo es ja immer wieder auch sehr viele schöne Geschichten gab, war das gerade international in dem Jahr schon sehr schwach. Ich bin nur ein Freund davon, das jetzt nicht gleich alles mit einem Hammer zuzuhauen, weil ich lieber ein bisschen den langen sozusagen Horizont sehe. Also wenn sich der Trend nächste Saison fortsetzen sollte, dann kann man da logisch auch tiefer reingehen. Aber jetzt erst mal für diese Saison gilt es logischerweise, dass das schon sehr schwach war, italienischer Seite.
Aber das ist schon richtig da quasi nicht so sehr die Extreme mitzunehmen. Das können andere machen, aber…
Ich fühle mich da immer ein bisschen wohler, ja, weil es ist halt auch noch nicht so lange her, da hat Atalanta die Europa League gewonnen, auf ziemlich beeindruckende Weise und Intra war zweimal im Champions-League-Finale. Und genauso wenig, wie ich damals den italienischen Fußball plötzlich als den neuen großen gefühlt habe, fühle ich jetzt halt, dass alles kaputt ist. Aber man muss es schon im Auge behalten, gar keine Frage.
Und das werden wir auch in der nächsten Saison tun. Ich habe noch nicht mit euch darüber geredet, aber ich hoffe einfach, dass ich euch dann wieder hier begrüßen darf. Denn es war ganz, ganz fantastisch mit euch und natürlich auch allen anderen, die jetzt hier nicht mit dabei sein konnten, bei dieser letzten Sendung über den europäischen Männerfußball zu sprechen. Vielen, vielen Dank an euch beide und stellvertretend natürlich an alle anderen Gäste in dieser Saison. Danke euch beiden.
Vielen Dank.
War mir ein Vergnügen.
War wieder eine ganz große Ehre.
Also die Ehre ist meinerseits. Aber ich fand es auch wirklich eine schöne Saison. Und ich danke natürlich euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, weil ihr macht das Ganze hier möglich. Der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir hier machen, auch die Gästehonorare, die ich hier für Sendungen wie diese hier immer überweise, die kommen von euch, weil ihr freiwillig einen Betrag eurer Wahl überweist. Wie das geht, erfahrt ihr in der Video- und der Podcastbeschreibung. Oder wenn ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht und dort auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt, da könnt ihr auch sehen, wenn ihr denn mögt, wofür wir in der Vergangenheit euer Geld verwendet haben. In diesem Sinne, danke an alle, die das getan haben. Stellvertretend danke ich Tillmann, Roman, Pseudonym Raul Brauers. Und Frankfurter Laird. Sie alle haben sich auch registriert auf rasenfunk.de und dementsprechend konnte ich Ihnen hier nach dem Zufallsprinzip danken. Ich danke euch auch für all den Input im Forum, in den entsprechenden Threads, auch für alles Feedback oder mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Und dann möchte ich euch auch an der Stelle hier nochmal kurz sagen, wie es während der WM weitergehen wird im Rasenfunk, weil ich das jetzt sehr oft gefragt wurde. Es wird wahrscheinlich keine WM-Vorschau geben. Es tut mir leid, es sind zu viele Teams. Ich kriege es nicht hin und ganz kickt die WM bei mir auch noch nicht so rein emotional, muss ich jetzt sagen. Was es geben wird, ist im Nationalteams-Feed werden wir nach jedem Deutschland-Spiel eine Sendung machen mit Martin Rafet und Caroline Kipper und abonniert unbedingt den Tribüngespräch-Feed, denn da werden wir einmal pro Woche ein wöchentliches WM-Panel machen mit einer festen Gäste-Runde. Ein bisschen habe ich mich hier so an dem Ligatour-Modell orientiert. Wenn wir wollen, reden wir über Sportliches. Wir sind aber auch darauf ausgerichtet, über Politisches oder Sport-Politisches zu sprechen. Wir reden einfach über das, was wir in der vergangenen Woche wichtig fanden, das, worauf wir Lust hatten. Weil ich konnte und kann auch jetzt noch überhaupt nicht abschätzen, habe ich aus sportlichem Sinn auf eine WM-Lust, in der einer der WM-Teilnehmer stand heute, 1. Juni, 13.43, noch nicht mal Visa ausgestellt bekommen hat, weil sie zufällig aus dem Iran kommen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Lust habe, dann über die einzelnen Spiele zu sprechen. Es kann sein, dass diese Lust noch kommt im Turnier, dann reagieren wir darauf im Panel. Es kann aber auch sein, dass das einfach alles bleibt, was wir machen. Und es ist schade, weil bei den Mehrsendungen, die wir machen, dann kann ich noch mehr tolle Gäste mit dabei haben, auf die ich auch immer sehr viel Lust habe. Aber ich denke, ihr könnt auch nachvollziehen, dass es nicht so ganz einfach ist, dieses Turnier zu behandeln wie jedes andere. Vor allem, wenn bei vorherigen Terminen gerade ich hier immer so einen Riesenfass aufgemacht habe und deswegen von der WM-Kata berichte ich gar nicht, zum Beispiel aus den bekannten Gründen. Deswegen, so wird es weitergehen im Rasenfunk. Ich könnte natürlich aber trotzdem sehr gerne im Forum über die WM und so weiter diskutieren und ich freue mich auch über euer Feedback zu dieser Entscheidung. Und wie es dann genau wird, kann ich ehrlicherweise auch immer noch nicht ganz exakt sagen, weil ich komme direkt aus dem Rasenfunk-Royal, bin hier jetzt reingerutscht in diese Sendung und der Kopf ist noch gar nicht bei der WM. Deswegen, ja, gebt mir da, es geht los am 8. Juni. Am Montag vor der WM-Eröffnung wird die erste Pennesendung erscheinen und alles Weitere muss ich dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen spontan machen. Jetzt wisst ihr Bescheid. Vielen, vielen herzlichen Dank für euren Support, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Freue mich auf euer Feedback. Danke euch für eure Treue in dieser Saison. Es gibt in diesem Feed hier auch noch einen Rückblick auf die Zweitligasaison der Männer. Das werden Marco und Eva in den nächsten Tagen kochen. In diesem Sinne lohnt es sich abonnieren. Es lohnt sich hoffentlich auch, uns weiterzuempfehlen. Bitte sagt anderen, dass es uns gibt. Und wenn ihr wollt, abonniert sehr gerne alle Feeds des Rasenfunks. Und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich bald hier wieder. Bleibt oder werdet gesund. Bis bald. Macht's gut. Ciao. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.